FOR SOME THE JUDICIARY WHICH IS
SCHEDULED TO START AT NINE WE DO
NOT HAVE A CORE OF FACT WE DO
NOT HAVE OTHER MEMBERS.
WILL BE ABLE TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE SHOULD BE GET THE
REQUISITE MEMBERS HERE.
AND THEN HOPEFULLY ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS
SO A LITTLE BIT OF PATIENCE
SORRY ABOUT THE WAY
.
ALL RIGHTS GOOD MORNING ALL WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN OUR HEARING
AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
THE ARRIVAL OF ENOUGH FOR A
QUORUM.
AND FIRST UP IS MISTER BERMAN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB SIX SO.
TWO WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND FOR
OFFERING A MEANS OF HARMONIZING
THE BILL WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF
EXISTING LAW.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED AB SIX OH TWO
WOULD EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S
REVENGE PORN STATUTE. TO ACCOUNT
FOR WHAT ARE COMMONLY KNOWN AS
DEEP FAKES.
DEEP FIX OUR HYPER REALISTIC
PICTURES VIDEOS AND AUDIO
RECORDINGS OF AN INDIVIDUAL
FALSELY APPEARING TO DO OR SAY
SOMETHING.
MADE WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TECHNOLOGY THAT
SEAMLESSLY SUPERIMPOSES THE
MOVEMENTS IN WORDS OF ONE PERSON
ONTO ANOTHER DEEP FAKES DISTORT
THE TRUTH MAKING IT HARDER TO
DISTINGUISH REAL EVENTS AND
ACTIONS.
FROM FICTION AND FANTASY.
ALTHOUGH THIS TECHNOLOGY COULD
HAVE BROAD IMPLICATIONS FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY ELECTION
OUTCOMES AND DIPLOMACY IT IS
PREDOMINANTLY BEING USED TO
HARASS AND HUMILIATE WOMEN.
BY SCRAPING THEIR PHOTOS FROM
THE INTERNET AND MANIPULATING
THEM INTO SEXUALLY EXPLICIT
MATERIAL.
BEYOND NATURAL FEELINGS OF
EMBARRASSMENT FALSELY APPEARING
IN A DEEP FAKE PORN VIDEO CAN
CAUSE IRREPARABLE HARM TO A
VICTIM'S REPUTATION.
JOB PROSPECTS PERSONAL REAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND MENTAL HEALTH.
RECOGNIZING THAT A PERSON WHOSE
FACE APPEARS IN A DEEP FAKE PORN
VIDEO COULD BE JUST AS
TRAUMATIZED AND VICTIMIZED AS
ANY VICTIM OF REVENGE PORN.
SB SIX OH TWO WOULD GRANT A
VICTIM OF AN AFFAIR IS SEXUAL
DEEP FAKE THE SAME RIGHTS AND
REMEDIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE FOR A VICTIM OF HER OF
REVENGE PORN -- AND WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT ALL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU GIVE ANYWAY THIS IS A
SPORT -- NO WITNESSES OKAY AS
WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE WOULD ANYONE
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SAY NONE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MUST.
SO OKAY FORCE OUT OF YOU MAY
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY -- WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE?
WE SHALL DO SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
ALL RIGHT MISTER GLORIA ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN YEAH.
BUT WHAT WAS CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A SURFER ALLOW
ME TO PRESENT AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THIS MORNING OR
START BY.
STATING THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENT WITH
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR AND
HIS STAFF -- FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS BILL -- FOR FOR
THE MEMBERS UNDER EXISTING LAW
ONLY PUBLIC PROSECUTORS MAY FILE
LAWSUITS CHARGING UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES THESE ACTIONS
MAY BE BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR CITY ATTORNEY WITH A
POPULATION.
OF A CITY OF A POPULATION WITH
GREATER THAN SEVEN FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU TWENTY GENERAL OR D. A.
BRINGS THE FORWARD ACTION UNDER
THE UNFAIR?
COMPETITION ACTED THE OFFICE
RECEIVES ALL OF THE CIVIL
PENALTIES AWARDED BY THE COURT.
HOWEVER WHEN THE CITY ATTORNEY
BRING SUCH ACTION THE CIVIL
PENALTIES MUST BE SPLIT EVENLY
WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF
THAT COUNTY.
THIS DISCREPANCY HAS LEFT THOSE
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEY'S WITH A
DIFFICULT CHOICE.
COUNTING THE PURSUIT OF LEGAL
RECOURSE AGAINST UNSCRUPULOUS
ACTORS WITH THE REALITY OF
FINITE PUBLIC RESOURCES.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES PENALTIES COLLECTED BY
THE ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEY FROM
AN ACTION UNDER THE FAIR UNFAIR
COMPETITION ACT TO BE PAID
ENTIRELY TO THE CITY.
A BY ENSURING AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF PENALTIES
AWARDED UNDER THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION ACT THIS BILL WILL
EMPOWER THOSE ELIGIBLE CITY
ATTORNEYS TO PROSECUTE AGAINST
UNFAIR BUSINESSES.
I IN THE INTEREST OF CONSUMERS
IN THE INTEREST OF THE
ENVIRONMENT A WITH ME THIS
MORNING IS MARKET IN COURT I
WILL WHOSE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF
CITY TO CITY ATTORNEY MARK
ELLIOTT.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
MY NAME IS MARK AND CORN AND THE
CHIEF DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY FOR
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN SEVEN BRINGS
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW BACK
INTO BALANCE.
IT ALLOWS CITY ATTORNEYS FROM
THE THREE LARGEST CALIFORNIA
CITIES TO KEEP ALL THE CIVIL
PENALTIES WHEN THE ACT
INDEPENDENTLY. TO ENFORCE THE U.
C. L..
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN SEVEN DOES NOT
INCREASE OR DECREASE THE AMOUNT
OF PENALTY IN ANY WAY.
THE TRIAL COURT JUDGE IS STILL
IN POWER TO IMPOSE ONLY THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF PENALTY.
AB ONE FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
ENCOURAGES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
WORK TOGETHER BY PUTTING THEM
ALL ON AN EQUAL FOOTING
EXPRESSLY PRESERVES WHATEVER
AGREEMENTS THEY STRIKE. FOR
JOINT PROSECUTIONS WE URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON A. B. ONE FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN I THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS ADULT.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
DOWN HERE GALLAGHER CHAU
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
YES.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF MR GLORIOUS BILL.
MR TURN MEMBER SILVIUS ALICIA ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE FEWER -- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL BE AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL IN THESE
CONSUMER PROTECTION ACTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM.
NUMBER THE STAFF I JUST HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION SO UNDER THIS --
MEASURE OB CITIES ON THE THE
POPULATION THRESHOLD WAS STILL
BE REQUIRED TO SHOW A SPLIT THE
PROCEEDS WITH THE COUNTY THEN.
YES THEY WOULD BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO FIRST GO TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO GET PERMISSION. TO
INITIATE LITIGATION THE FIRST
PLACE.
BECAUSE THE BIG CITIES DON'T
HAVE TO GET PERMISSION FROM THE
DA WE THINK IT'S FAIR THAT THEY
SINCE THEY CAN ACT INDEPENDENTLY
AND FILING.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP
WHATEVER THEY GET BACK WITH THE
RATIONALE FOR SPLITTING THE
PROCEEDS WITH THE COUNTY TO
BEGIN WITH BUT QUITE HONESTLY
I'M NOT SURE I THINK IT'S A I
THINK IT GOT CAUGHT UP PROBABLY
IN THE DRAFTING IS IS YOU CAN
SEE FROM SEVENTEEN TO A SIX IT'S
IT'S LONG.
AND IT'S NOT VERY CLEAR WITH THE
VARIOUS LEVELS I THINK THE
TREATED ALL CITY ATTORNEY'S
TOGETHER -- AND THEN WENT BACK
AND CARVED OUT OF SOME
EXCEPTIONS FOR THE BIG CITIES.
UP BUT DIDN'T FIX THAT LITTLE
BIT SOMEONE WATER WAYS I THINK
IT JUST MAKES IT MORE CONSISTENT
WHAT'S WITH WHAT SEEMS TO BE THE
THE INTENT OF THE DRAFTERS ALL
ALONG AND WAS TO SPLIT WITH
PERCENTAGE WISE OR OTHERWISE.
RIGHT NOW THE DEFAULT A FIFTY
FIFTY FIFTY I GOT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
RIGHT SINGER THIS GLORIA YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEES EITHER THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE.
A QUORUM THE MOTION THAT I'M
ASKING FOR IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHOW.
CHOW I CHOOSE.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE SO FOR THE
BILL ON CALL THANK CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU.
I THINK THIS FRIEDMAN YOU HAVE.
SNEAKED IN AHEAD OF OTHER SO
WE'LL BRING YOU UP.
THAT IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B. --
ITEM VIçT TWO AND FOUR DO YOU
HAVE A PREFERENCE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE FIRST WELL SIX SEVENTY
OR OF INTENT LET'S TAKE THE RENT
NOTICING [inaudible]
FIRST TONIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH NUMBER
FOUR A. B..
ELEVEN TEN YES AB ELEVEN TEN IS
A BILL THAT THE CITY OF GLENDALE
ASKED US TO HELP WITH AND WE'RE
VERY HONORED AND HAPPY TO DO
THAT.
IT IS TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT THE CITY CAN REQUIRE
FOR NOTICING OF SUBSTANTIAL RENT
INCREASES.
ALL RIGHT NOW UNDER CURRENT LAWS
A CITIES ARE CAPPED WE WOULD
LIKE TO INCREASE THAT ABILITY
FOR CITIES TO GIVE PEOPLE.
MORE TIME TO FIND OTHER
ACCOMMODATIONS -- IF THEY SO
CHOOSE -- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY ARE TWO VERY SMART
PEOPLE WHO WILL INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES.
YOUR FIRST WITNESS PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITY OF GLENDALE AS
THE MEMBER MENTIONED IT'S A VERY
I THINK WE VERY STRAIGHT FORWARD
BILL -- WE HAVE -- HOUSING
CRISIS WE WANT TO GIVE -- THOSE
TENANTS ADEQUATE TIME TO FIND --
RELOCATION OF THE NEED TO END
WITH THE RANK CREASES --
SKYROCKETING ACROSS THE STATE WE
THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE APPROACH TO GIVE
THOSE TENETS THAT EXTENDED
AMOUNT OF TIME TO SEE IF THEY
WANT TO FIGURE OUT FINANCES TO
STATE WITH THE RENT INCREASE OR
BE GIVEN THE ADEQUATE TIME TO
FIND A NEW PLACE. TO TO RESIDE
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL PICKED A
REASONABLE APPROACH.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SUPPOSITORY AND I'M FROM THE
CITY OF GLENDALE.
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS I THANK YOU
WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
MISTREATMENT DID YOU THE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
YES OUR CHIEF OF THE MEMBERS ARE
EXCEPT MISTER TERRY MEMBER I'M
SORRY RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
IT'S HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION
DIVISION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WERE
ACTUALLY A TWEENER.
WE WERE PART OF THE NEGOTIATIONS
THAT TOOK PLACE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND TO ESTABLISH A THIRTY
DAY SIXTY DAY NOTICE -- WHICH
WERE ULTIMATELY -- SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT COMPROMISE I WOULD JUST
SIMPLY NEED TO GET DIRECTION
FROM OUR BOARD WHICH WILL BE
DOING LATER THIS WEEK SO.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THIS IS.
TWO I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD WE NEED
AS MANY PROTECTIONS OF OUR
TENANTS AS WE CAN.
THE ONE THING I JUST WANNA
MENTION AS AS YOU KNOW IS -- I
HAVE A SEPARATE BILL -- THAT IF
WE ARE SUCCESSFUL GETTING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
ESTABLISH AN ANTI RENT GOUGING
CAP AT THIS POINT -- THE BILL
WOULD CAP RENT INCREASES AT CPI
PLUS 5%.
MY HOPE IS THAT -- ASSUMING BOTH
OF THESE GET THROUGH THE PROCESS
WE CAN RATIONALIZE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE TRIGGERS -- WORK BUT
WITH THAT I THINK THE CONCEPT OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO MAKES
AN AWFUL LOT OF SENSE AND I'M
HAPPY TO MAKE THE MOTION TO MOVE
IT FOR THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS OUR
SECOND.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THREE
MEN YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHOOSE. TO AYE GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MR BLOOM.
ALSO YOU HAD A SECOND BUT I DO --
IT IS ARE YOU KNOW SAME AS WELL
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB.
SIX SEVENTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY AND FIRST
OF ALL I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AND MISTER -- THE
CHAIRMAN WORKING WITH US ON THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THERE ARE OVER FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND COMMUNITY INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE STATE THAT
MAKE UP APPROXIMATELY SIX
MILLION TOTAL HOUSING UNITS
APPROXIMATELY A QUARTER OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING STOCK.
RESIDENTS IN THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN DENIED THE ABILITY TO
BUILD AN EIGHTY YOU -- WHICH WE
ALL AGREE IS A BIG PART OF THE
STATE'S SOLUTION TOWARDS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS -- BECAUSE OF
THEIR AGE AWAY REGULATIONS THAT
OVER THAT TRUMP ON THE STATE'S
RULES SOMEHOW WHICH I BELIEVE IS
NOT INTENDED IN THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION AND PROBABLY NOT
KNOWN.
I'M.
SO AB SIX SEVENTY ALLOWS WERE
APPROPRIATE THOSE HOHNER
HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD A SECOND UNIT IT
APPLIES TO ALL EXISTING
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS AND ALLOWS
REASONABLE RESTRICTIONS PROVIDED
THAT THOSE RESTRICTIONS DO NOT
EFFECTIVELY PROHIBIT.
THE USE OF THE SECOND UNIT OR A
JUNIOR -- EIGHTY YOU THIS IS A
TARGETED APPROACH OF COURSE THAT
FOCUSES ON SINGLE FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ASSOCIATION MANAGERS ON THE
SOLUTION -- IN LIGHT OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS THE
EIGHTY USE ARE A VERY IMPORTANT
SOLUTION AND WE CAN'T ALLOW ONE
SMALL GROUP -- TO PROHIBIT THEIR
PROPERTY OWNERS FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THIS IMPORTANT --
A SOLUTION ARMED WITH ME TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS DAVID
JONES REPRESENTING THE TOWN OF
TRUCKEE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DAVID JONES ABOUT THE
TOWN PRESS -- WE DO THINK THAT
THE STRIKES A VERY REASONABLE
BALANCE SIMILAR TO BILLS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S PASSED
ALLOWING -- HOMEOWNERS IN H. A
WAYS TO HAVE SOLAR A WATER
EFFICIENCY SO WE THINK THAT THE
LEGAL PRECEDENT IS GOOD -- WE
WOULD RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF AN
H. AWAY -- TO MAINTAIN ALL THOSE --
COVENANTS THAT WOULD NOT
INTERFERE WITH HAVING AN EIGHTY
OLDER.
UNIT THEN THE THE RESIDENTS
WOULD BE RESTRICTED FOR FIFTY
FIVE AN OLDER SO WE WE WANT TO
MAINTAIN THE CHARACTER IF IT'S A
SPANISH STYLE ARCHITECTURAL
EIGHTY YOU I MEAN H. AWAY WE
WOULD HAVE A SPANISH STYLE
DESIGNS WE TRY TRY TO STRIKE THE
BALANCE.
OF RESPECTING -- THE TENANTS
RIGHTS THE H. AWAY RIGHTS AND
THEN ALLOWING THOSE -- THAT
DESIRE TO HAVE ANY EIGHTY YOU TO
BE ABLE HAVE THEM TRUCKEE IS
UNIQUE WE'VE GOT TWENTY FIVE
MILES OF NATIONAL FOREST AROUND
US WE HAVE AN ACUTE SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR WORKFORCE
HOUSING -- WE HAVE A MASSIVE H.
AWAY THAT IS DENIED -- EIGHT
EIGHTY USE IN THAT THAT -- THAT
PLACE THAT -- REST THOSE
RESIDENTS -- WE HAVE.
NEED -- FOR WORKFORCE HOUSING
AND SO THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
THOSE HOMEOWNERS THAT CHOOSE TO
TO BE ABLE TO GO AHEAD GO AHEAD
AND HAVE AN EIGHTY YOU SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
TONY WE WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SOCIAL XIN HERE IN
SUPPORT.
DENISE BANKS THAN WITH A CASITA
COALITION THE STATEWIDE
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION IN FAVOR
OF EIGHTIES THANK YOU FOR THIS.
AND LOSE MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA
ME IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS OUR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE ARE THERE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO TOO WEAK TO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SING THEN THE THREE MEN YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER -- I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
CONSOLES I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORRIS I RACE.
RACE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU HI MISTER BLOOM. SIX IS THAT
A NUMBER TEN AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE SEC THANK
YOU RYAN ADDRESSED -- BUT MOST
MORNING THE SECOND AIR AND
MEMBERS THE THIS BILL WILL MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE ELLIS
ACT THAT ARE INTENDED TO BOTH
ENSURE FAIRNESS FOR TENANTS.
AND REMOVE AMBIGUITY FOR BOTH
LANDLORDS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE ELLIS ACT WAS INTENDED AS A
MEANS FOR LANDLORDS TO EXIT THE
RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS NOT AS
AN END RUN AROUND LOCAL
PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY SOME LANDLORDS ARE
USING A LOT TO DO THAT.
OF THESE LANDLORDS ARE EVICTING
TENANTS UNDER THE GUISE OF
EXITING THE RENTAL HOUSING
BUSINESS BUT WITH NO INTENT OF
ACTUALLY LEAVING THE MARKET
INSTEAD.
THEIR GAMING THE SYSTEM TO AVOID
LOCAL PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS.
SO TO ADDRESS THESE ABUSES THIS
LEGISLATION WILL CLARIFY THE
ELSE ACT IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS.
FIRST IT WILL REAFFIRM THE LAWS
ORIGINAL INTENT THAT THERE CAN.
BE ONLY ONE WITHDRAWAL DATE FOR
PURPOSES OF DETERMINING WHEN
TIME LINES UNDER THE ACT BEGIN
TO RUN.
SECOND IT WILL CLARIFY THAT ONCE
ANY UNIT IN A BUILDING IS
RETURNED TO THE RENTAL MARKET
THE ENTIRE PROPERTY IS
CONSIDERED BACK ON THE RENTAL
MARKET FOR PURPOSES OF THE ACT.
AND FINALLY THE BILL MAKES CLEAR
THAT THE PAYMENT OF PUNITIVE
DAMAGES UNDER THE ACT DOES NOT
EXTINGUISH THE LANDLORDS
OBLIGATION TO COMPLY WITH THE
LAW.
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW IS STILL
REQUIRED.
I AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT WE
REACH AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ON AMENDMENTS THAT WILL
TAKE IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE AND
ARE CLOSE TO REACHING AN
AGREEMENT WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
WHICH I HOPE TO HAVE RESOLVED BY
THE NEXT DURING.
THIS BILL GETS TENANTS SOME
SECURITY AND KEEPING THEIR HOMES
IN A TIME WHEN HOMELESSNESS FOR
OUR POOR SENIORS DISABLED AND
EVEN WORKING CLASS IS A REALITY
THAT MAY.
BE JUST A PAYCHECK OR RENT
INCREASE AWAY DUE THE LACK OF
READILY AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH BRIAN AUGUSTA HERE
TO ADD HIS COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FIRST WHAT A SECOND
CHAIR MEMBER TRYING TO GUESS IT
JUST LET ME CLARIFY ONE THING --
A MY FATHER MISTER BURN READ IT
THAT WAY BUT WE HAVE ACTUALLY
TAKEN THOSE.
AMENDMENTS TO SATISFY THE
REALTORS OPPOSITION THOSE ARE IN
PRINT AND I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THEM THAT THEIR OPPOSITION
IS REMOVED -- WE ARE WORKING ON
SOME LAST MINUTE.
DISCUSSIONS WERE DOWN TO ONE
WORD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND AND IF
YOU WORK IN THIS BUILDING OF
THAT THAT WERE PROBABLY MATTERS
AND SO WE'RE VERY CLOSE THOUGH
AND WE HAVE GOTTEN.
I THINK --  97% OF THE WAY
THERE SO THIS BILL AS MISTER
BLOOM AS DISCUSSED.
MAKE SIMPLE CLARIFYING CHANGES
TO THE LAW TO REALLY ENSURE THAT
THE ACT -- THAT CLARIFIES THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE ACT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THERE IS ONE
WHICH ALL DATE AND THERE'S ONE
DATE FOR RETURNING THE UNITS.
TO THE RENTAL MARKET NOT ONLY
WILL THIS HELP.
PROVIDE CLARITY TO BOTH PROPERTY
OWNERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
BUT IT WILL ALSO REDUCE A
POTENTIAL LITIGATION OVER THAT
REMAINING AMBIGUITY --
LITIGATION THAT WE ARE SEEING
NOW IN MISTER ROOMS DISTRICT AND
SO WE THINK WITH THOSE
CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WE CAN ENSURE THAT WE ARE.
REDUCE OUT LITIGATION AND
PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR BOTH
PROPERTY OWNERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND PROTECT.
TENANTS AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ORDERED AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MITCHELL PARASITE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
YES THE LEASH ON BEHALF OF CITY
SANTA MONICA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TO PROTECT TENANTS
THANK YOU.
KAELIN DEAN ON BEHALF OF POLICY
LINK PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL.
SASHA HER NAME AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
RAND MORE NOW WE HAVE THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALI I PHELPS ON BEHALF OF ACE IN
SUPPORT.
QUESTION A LOT OF PICOULT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THAT COMMITTEE AROUND KINGSTON I
REPRESENT THREE OF REGIONAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS EAST BAY
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION.
ASSOCIATION ORANGE COUNTY AND
THE APARTMENT SITUATION
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES WE
HAVE ONE ISSUE WITH THE BILL.
WHICH WE STRONGLY BELIEVE.
ACTUALLY WILL HURT.
BOTH PARTIES.
THE BILL AS AMENDED APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH JUST LAST WEEK.
PAGE SIX ONE SENTENCE RIGHT THE
LAST SENTENCE OF THAT PAGE.
SAYS IN PERTINENT PART.
THAT SHOULD I AS A PROPERTY
OWNER EXTEND THE TIME PERIOD FOR
A TENANT TO MOVE.
THAT THAT EXTENDS ALL THE TIME
PERIODS FOR ALL THE OTHER
TENANTS TO MOVE -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS A STRONG INCENTIVE.
FOR THE PROPERTY OWNER NEVER TO
GIVE AN ACCOMMODATION OR
EXTENSION OF TIME SO THAT TEN IT
CAN MOVE.
BECAUSE THE TENANT HAS COME TO
US AND SAID WE NEED ANOTHER
MONTH OR TWO MONTHS OUR NEW
RENTAL UNIT IS NOT AVAILABLE
QUITE YET.
NOW IF THIS BILL SHOULD BE
SIGNED INTO LAW.
I CAN TELL YOU THE ADVICE TO OUR
CLIENTS.
WHO DECIDE TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS
WOULD WOULD DETERMINE THAT THEY
WILL NOT EXTEND THE -- RENTAL
UNIT FOR ONE TENANT -- AND
CONSEQUENTLY IT WILL HURT THAT
ONE TENANT PERHAPS TO TENANTS.
WE HAVE BEEN IN ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH MISTER BLOOM
AND WITH THE SPONSORS -- BRANDS
LOOKING.
LOOKING LIKE HE WANTS TO TALK TO
THIS -- AND WE HAVE.
HAD DISCUSSIONS LAST NIGHT THIS
MORNING HOW DO WE FIX THIS WE
FIX THIS BY SAYING IF YOU.
AS A PROPERTY OWNER DECIDE TO GO
OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND DECIDE TO EXTEND -- THE
AMOUNT OF TIME FOR ONE OF THE
TENANTS -- BECAUSE OF THE
REQUEST OF THE TENET DUE TO THE
REQUEST OF THE TENET THAT THAT
SHALL ONLY APPLY TO THAT ONE
TENANTS.
NOT TO EVERYBODY WHO IS ALREADY
DECIDED TO MOVE IT CETERA SO
THAT'S OUR REQUEST TO FIX.
THIS ONE SENTENCE OR
SUBPARAGRAPH PAID.
SIX LINE FORTY WOULD CHANGE AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF WHAT OUR REQUEST
IS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AS INTRODUCED C. R. DID
HAVE AN OPPOSED LIST AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL HOWEVER THE
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH THE MEN'S --
DO SATISFY OUR CONCERNS AND
AGAIN WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US TO RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THIS WILL PERHAPS
YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
IT JUST SEEMS THAT AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT'S WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED ACTUALLY CUTS A BECAUSE
IF THE PROPER AIR IS GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS AND FOR SOME REASON
EXTENDS ONE TENET WHY WOULDN'T
THEY EXTENT ALL THE OTHER
TENANTS.
BUT THEN I THINK THE QUESTION IS
DOES THAT.
CHANGE THE BEHAVIOR.
PRIOR TO THE DECISION TO GO OUT
OF BUSINESS AND WHAT THE INITIAL
SORT OF CURVE IS AS I UNDERSTAND
THIS BUT HOT PROPERTY WHAT I I I
I I DON'T THINK SO I THINK YOUR
THE FIRST PART OF YOUR ANALYSIS
IS THE ONE THAT REALLY APPLIES
HERE -- WE'VE ONLY HAD THIS
ISSUE SINCE.
MID DAY YESTERDAY -- BUT MISTER
GUS HAS GIVEN IT SOME THOUGHT
AND TO LET HIM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN STEP.
JUST TO EXPAND FURTHER THAT'S
NOT WHAT MISTER KING SENATE'S
DESCRIBE IS NOT THE INTENT OF
THAT SECTION THE ONLY PURPOSE.
OF THAT LANGUAGE.
IS TO MAKE CLEAR THAT WHATEVER
THE TIME PERIODS ARE OF ALL THE
TENANTS.
IN THE BUILDING SO SOME MAY HAVE
A SHORTER NOTICE AND SOME MAY
HAVE A LONGER NOTICE BECAUSE THE
LAW ALLOWS FOR EXAMPLE.
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES TO HAVE UP TO A
YEAR NOTICE -- AND SO YOU MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT.
TIME PERIODS DIFFERENT NOTICE
PERMITS IS IS OF THE BILL IS TO
CLARIFY THAT THE WITHDRAWAL DATE
FOR DETERMINING WHEN ALL THE
OTHER TIME LINES IN THE BILL.
FOR THE LOG BEGIN TO RUN THAT
THAT DATE IS TRIGGERED.
A BY THE LAST TENANT -- THAT
TENANTS TERMINATION DATE SO THAT
THERE ARE NOT MULTIPLE
WITHDRAWAL THERE'S THERE'S ONLY
ONE AND IT'S THE LAST DATE THAT
THE LAST AND IT.
MOVES OUT ESSENTIALLY AND THAT'S
THAT'S WITHOUT LANGUAGES
INTENDED TO DO THE FACT THAT MR
KINGS AND REPORTS SAY THIS WE
HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF TIME TO
CONSIDER HIS COMMENTS BUT THAT'S
OUR GOAL AND I THINK WHAT HE'S
DESCRIBING IT'S NOT --
IMPLICATED BY THAT LANGUAGE IN
ANY WAY THEN.
THE OWNER STILL MAINTAINS THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHETHER TO
EXTEND TENANTS ARE NOT BUT OUR
OUR LANGUAGE AS A CHANGE THAT AT
ALL IT JUST SAYS.
THIS BAT LAST DATE THE LAST
TENANT THAT'S THAT WITHDRAWAL
DATE THAT'S ALL WE'RE DOING
THERE.
OKAY SO IF THE IF IF THERE'S A
DEAL TO BE HAD HERE AND AND AND
ARE YOU GOING TO KEEP WORKING ON
IT I WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU
MAKE SURE YOU.
LOOK BACK THAT WHATEVER CHANGES
YOU COME WITH THE COMMITTEES
THAT WE HAVE UNDERSTANDING OF
WHERE THAT GOES YEAH THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND WE WILL -- REFERENCE
BACK ANY CHANGES.
TO OKAY THANK YOU -- ANYBODY
ELSE WAS GALLAGHER.
THIS SO TO THE OPPOSITION IT IF
IF THAT.
IF THIS IS IF YOU WERE TO BE
ADDRESS WOULD YOU GUYS BE MOVING
TO A SUPPORT POSITION OR A
NEUTRAL POSITION -- NEUTRAL MR
GALLAGHER OKAY AND I I THINK
LISTENING.
TO YOU AND YET IS QUESTION SO
YOU KNOW AND I I THINK WHAT
MISTER KING SIN IS GAIN AS NOT
THE STATUTORY.
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS BUT SAY THAT
THEY ACCOMMODATE A TENANT.
YOU KNOW THAT THE STATUTORY
TIMED NOTICE TIME TO GET OUT IS
LET'S SAY IT'S A YEAR FOR
SENIORS -- IF THEY ACCOMMODATE
THAT TEN AND IN THE END OF THE
YEAR IS COMING UP AND THE AND
THAT TEN IT SAYS HEY.
I NEED.
NO MAYBE ANOTHER COUPLE MONTHS
RIGHT AFTER THE STATUTORY NOTICE.
PERIOD IS ALREADY RUN.
AND THEY GIVE THAT PERSON AN
ACCOMMODATION.
SHOULD THAT EXTEND IT FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
YOU KNOW THE REST OF THOSE
DEADLINES AND I IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE REALLY
GETTING THAT NOT THAT IF.
YEAH I MEAN THE DEADLINE IS
WHATEVER IT IS RIGHT DEPENDING
ON THE STATUS OF THE PERSON
THAT'S INVOLVED -- BUT IF YOU
ACCOMMODATE SOMEONE IN THAT AND
THEY EXTEND BEYOND BECAUSE
YOU'RE TRYING TO HELP.
THERE ARE PARTICULAR SPECIFIC
SITUATION SHOULD THAT ALSO
EXTEND.
THE DATE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE'S AB
YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING YES
MISTER GALLAGHER I THINK
ACTUALLY HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB
OF EXPLAINING MISTER KING SINCE
ARGUMENT TENDING AND HE HAS SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT I THINK WE
WILL -- IN LIGHT OF THAT AND
WILL CERTAINLY GO BACK AND TALK
FURTHER ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT MIGHT BE
AND SEE IF THERE ISN'T SOME
COMPROMISE THEIR IT.
I'M NOT ONE OF COURSE NOT
SPEAKING FOR THE AUTHOR.
THAT'S CERTAINLY MY POSITION.
THANK YOU THIS FEATURE IS.
THIS DOES SEEM TO ME LIKE A VERY
COMMON SENSE APPROACH AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR.
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO THIS
POINT TO NEGOTIATE AND ENGAGE
WITH THE OPPOSITION I AND FOR
YOUR CONTINUED WILLINGNESS TO DO
SO.
AND GIVEN THAT AND VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU
WE'RE PLEASED TO AFTER TWO YEARS
THAT WERE CLOSE TO A RESOLUTION.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SIGNAL MISTER BLOOM YOU MAY
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND THAT MOTION IS
DUE PASSED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAO.
CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
HI MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE RACE.
RACE AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER SANTIAGO SO THIS TAKES US
TO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B..
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE ONE OF FIRST
BANK -- THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING US.
TO CONTINUE THIS WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WE ACCEPT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS ON STRETCHERS YOU
KNOW AB FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE
WOULD ADD ANOTHER LAYER
PROTECTION.
AT THE MOST AFFORDABLE
POPULATIONS AND ENCOURAGE
GREATER CENSUS PARTICIPATION --
BY PREVENTING ANYBODY FROM FALLS
FALSELY REPRESENTING THEMSELVES
HAD TO BE STATE LOCAL OR FEDERAL
OFFICIAL -- EMPLOYEE WITH THE
INTENT THAT -- TO GATHER OTHER
INFORMATION FROM BOOKS.
THANK MISTER OUR STATE LAST
NIGHT ABOUT THANK YOU WOULD
ANYONE.
ALL RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISTER GALLAGHER.
SO I MEAN MY QUESTION THIS BILL
WAS LIKE ARE WE ARE WE ACTUALLY
SEEN THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY
OCCURRED.
THE WOMEN WE HAVE BEEN BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE SENSE IS COMING UP
AND I MEAN IT IT HAPPENED IN THE
LAST CENSUS AT ALL I MEAN THAT'S
I'M KIND OF TRYING TO SEE IF
THIS IS ACTUALLY A PROBLEM.
WHY DO I BELIEVE IT MIGHT BE A
PROBLEM ABSOLUTELY -- SO I'D
LIKE TO PREVENT THE PROBLEM FROM
GETTING GREATER.
WHY DO YOU BELIEVE THAT MIGHT BE
A PROBLEM?
WHAT MIGHT BE A PROBLEM I MEAN
LET'S LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THIS
OKAY SO LET'S GET TO THE CORE
THE QUESTION YOU'RE ASKING?
RIGHT -- AND LET'S GET TO THE
CORE OF WHAT I'M TRYING TO
PREVENT I WOULDN'T WANT TO ANY
AGENTS -- THAT ARE NOT CENSUS
EMPLOYEES KNOCKING ON DOORS
ASKING PEOPLE FOR IMMIGRATION
STATUS -- AND THEN -- THE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THAT INFORMATION IN
DOING OTHERWISE.
I WOULD SENSES WORKER WOULDN'T
DO WHICH IS JUST COLLECT
INFORMATION BUT LOOK.
THE OTHER THING THAT'S IMPORTANT
HERE TOO IS THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THE CALIFORNIA GETS ALL
THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS WHICH I
THINK WE WOULD BOTH AGREE.
RIGHT BUT THIS COULD ALSO APPLY
TO OTHER YOU KNOW IS I MEAN I I
HAVE I GET THAT MAYBE THE TARGET
IS LIKE ICE.
BUT WHAT IF IT'S JUST.
SOME OTHER RANDOM GROUP THAT'S
REPRESENTED THERE A CENSUS TAKER
JUST TRYING TO GET INFORMATION.
WELL I WOULDN'T WANT ANYBODY
FALSIFYING WHO THEY ARE KNOCKING
ON THE DOOR I THINK WE BOTH
AGREED -- THAT WE WANT THE
PUBLIC -- THE PUBLIC TO BE SAFE --
IF YOUR SENSES WORKER THEN
THAT'S FINE YOU CAN FIGURE
CENSUS WORKER -- BUT I THINK
MOST PEOPLE MOST REASONABLE
PEOPLE WOULD AGREE -- THAT YOU
WOULDN'T WANT SOMEBODY
MISREPRESENTING -- WHO THEY ARE
WHEN THEY'RE NOT GONNA DOOR
[inaudible]
RIGHT -- YEAH I MEAN.
I GUESS FOR MORE SPECIFIC
TALKING ABOUT ICE OR ANY OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY OUT OUT
THERE.
I SUPPOSE THAT THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW THEY USE STING
OPERATIONS I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY USE IT IN THIS EXACT
FASHION.
AGAIN I NOT FAMILIAR WITH THIS
EVER.
COMING UP AS AN ACTUAL -- THAT
THIS WAS SOMETHING THEY ACTUALLY
DID -- BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES
HAVE IN IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
RIGHT I I WOULD ASSUME YOU WOULD
WANT FOR EXAMPLE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE TO GO OUT
AND USE STING OPERATIONS TO GET
OUT POLLUTERS.
YOU KNOW YOU WOULD WANT YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO WHATEVER
THEIR PURPOSES.
WHATEVER THEY ARE TASKED WITH
ENFORCING YOU WOULD WANT THEM TO
GO OUT.
AND ENFORCE THE LAW THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO ENFORCE RIGHT EVEN
IF WE MIGHT.
LOOK.
I THINK A LOT OF US AGREE APPEAR
THAT.
IMMIGRATION LAW HAS A LOT
THERE'S A LOT OF IMPROVEMENT AND
HE'S BEING MADE. TO IMMIGRATION
LAW AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL BUT
NONE THE LESS WE DO HAVE TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
AND I THINK IN ANY OTHER
CAPACITY WOULD WANT TO SAY --
HADE AGENCY DON'T ENFORCE THE
LAW DON'T USE YOUR ENFORCEMENT
POWERS. TO DO THAT RIGHT.
YOU MAY RESPOND OUT ALWAYS
WANTING YOU RESPOND I WAS TRYING.
TO PUT OUT LIKE THIS COULD HAVE.
OTHER PRESIDENTIAL IMPLICATIONS
RIGHT THAT'S WHAT I'M GETTING.
WELL NUMBER ONE THE ONE SAYING
FOLLOW OR DON'T FOLLOW THE LAW
IN THIS BILL WITH THIS VERY VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT NOT IMPERSONATING --
ANY INDIVIDUAL SO LET'S TAKE
THAT OFF THE TABLE NUMBER TWO IF
YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT I NEVER
HEARD OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
PRETENDING TO BE SOMEBODY ELSE
WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THEY'RE
WALKING IN IN IT.
AND IF THERE IS A STING
OPERATION THERE IS ALREADY A SET
PROCESS IN PLACE -- WE'RE NOT
CHANGING ANY OF THAT BASICALLY
WHAT THIS SAYS IS YOU CANNOT
IMPERSONATE SOMEONE -- WHAT WHEN
YOU'RE NOT GOOD LORD WE KNOCKING
OR TALKING TO SOMEBODY TO
COLLECT INFORMATION?
SO I DON'T SEE ANY OF THOSE
OTHER ARGUMENTS BEING RELATIVE
BUT IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE YOU JUST
CAN'T FALSIFY -- IF YOU IF
YOU'RE A PUBLIC -- EMPLOYEE OR
AN OFFICIAL -- TO SAY THAT YOUR
FEDERAL AGENT -- GETTING OTHER
SORTS OF INFORMATION PRETTY
SIMPLE PRETTY NARROW BUT BUT I
THINK YOU MOST REASONABLE PEOPLE
WOULD AGREE -- THAT ANY OF THE
OTHER LAWS THAT ARE IN THE BOOKS
WE WOULD WANT THEM UP HELD THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH A BUT
LOOK I TELL YOU AT THE END OF
THE DAY WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE IS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WHICH I THINK.
MOST REASONABLE PEOPLE WOULD
AGREE -- THAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
GET ITS FAIR SHARE FROM FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
ABSOLUTELY AND THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO GET OUT THERE AND DO SO
IN AND WE NEED PEOPLE OUT THERE
TAKEN.
CENSUS INFORMATION RIGHT AND SO.
THE TWO I'M ON THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WE WERE REALLY FOCUSED
ON THIS RIGHT NOW -- YOU KNOW
I'M JUST.
NO WONDER WHAT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF OF THIS MIGHT BE
I I THINK MAYBE COULD EVEN BE
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM GOING OUT RAY AND
AND TAKING CENSUS INFORMATION I
THINK THE ONLY INFORMATION IS
THAT IS THAT GIVEN THE
SENSITIVITY AND GIVEN THE FEAR.
FOR MISUSE OF THE SYSTEM ALL
THIS SAYS IS WHATEVER YOU CANNOT
REPRESENT YOURSELF AS A CENSUS
TAKER MUST YOUR CENSUS TAKER
THAT'S THAT'S ALL THIS BILL DOES.
AND I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING LIKE COULD THIS STOP
COMMUNITY GROUPS FROM MAYBE
GOING OUT AND HELPING WITH
CENSUS NOTE COLLECTION THAT
COULD BE ONE THING.
AND THEN AND THEN I GUESS.
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S MANY
CASES WERE LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES
DO UNDER COVER OPERATIONS WHERE
THEY DO REPRESENT THEMSELVES TO
BE.
SOMETHING SOMETHING ELSE.
IN ORDER TO GET OUT A LEGAL
ACTIVITY.
AND SO.
YOU KNOW DOES THAT SWORE
LEGITIMATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES AS IS OR IS MY IS MY
CONCERNS OF THE BILL I I
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM WITH IT.
BUT I THINK THERE COULD BE OTHER
IMPLICATIONS.
THAT WE'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT
HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN I RESPOND
[inaudible]
YES.
WHAT NUMBER ONE AT THE I WOULD
TAKE BECOME BUT ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES OFF THE
TABLE BECAUSE THIS DOESN'T
PREVENT THEM IN IT?
AND IF YOU THINK THAT DOES I'D
LIKE TO SEE WHAT YOU THINK THAT --
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT
ACTUALLY HAPPEN BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY A PROCESS IN PLACE --
AND IT DOESN'T STOP COMMUNITY
GROUPS FROM PARTICIPATING ANY
ANY CENSUS WORK EITHER BECAUSE
IF THEY'RE NOT IMPERSONATING
THEMSELVES FALSELY THEN THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DO ANY SORT
OF WORK -- YOU AND I CAN
CONTINUE -- TO KNOCK ON DOORS
WITH THIS IN YOUR DISTRICT OR MY
DISTRICT TO HELP PEOPLE -- GET
COUNTED FOR THE CENSUS -- ALL IT
SAYS IS YOU AND I COULDN'T --
MRS REPRESENT OURSELVES A KNOCK
ON THE DOOR AND SAY THAT WERE A
CENSUS WORKER AND COLLECT OTHER
INFORMATION -- THAT'S ALL IT
SAYS.
SO I MEAN I THINK IF -- I MEAN
IF YOU DON'T IF IF -- I WOULD
HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE PASSES
A BILL THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T
FALSIFY WHO YOU ARE -- WHEN
YOU'RE KNOCKING ON THE DOOR?
OR COLLECTING INFORMATION.
THANK YOU THIS IS US.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THIS PREVENTS ONE ACTIVITY THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT MIGHT UTILIZE --
HOWEVER DISGUSTINGLY -- TO GET
INFORMATION FROM AN INDIVIDUAL
TO HAVE THEM SELF REPORT THAT
THEY'RE NOT -- HERE WITH
DOCUMENTATION CRACKED JUST ONE
ACTIVITY THAT'S LITERALLY
IMPERSONATING A CENSUS TAKER OR
OR ANYBODY ELSE RIGHT AND
ANYBODY ELSE WHO KNOCKS ON THE
DOOR WHO SAYS.
GRAHAM -- CENSUS WORKER CRACKED
I I'M JUST I I'M I'M A LITTLE
CONFUSED WHAT ROAD WE'RE GOING
DOWN WITH MY COLLEAGUE'S
QUESTION.
SO SO.
ICE CAN STILL HOLD BOGUS -- COME
PICK UP YOUR LOTTO WINNIE AND
STING OPERATIONS THEY CAN STILL
GO TO A DOOR IF THEY HAVE AN
ARREST WARRANT THEY CAN STILL
PULL PEOPLE OVER IF THEY IF THEY
HAVE REASON TO BELIEVE THAT --
THEY'RE HERE UNLAWFULLY IS THAT
CORRECT THIS WOULD BE CORRECT
THE DIFFERENCE IS THEY COULD NOT
IMPERSONATE SO THE ONLY ACTIVITY
ON THIS THAT WE'RE WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
IS NOT TO BE THAT SO PRECIOUS
AND SOME POINT WERE PUTTING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO OUR
BUDGET ON TOP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPENDS BECAUSE WE
WANT A COMPLETE COUNT AND ALL
WE'RE SAYING IS.
NOBODY SHOULD GO TO A DOOR.
AND SAY I AM A CENSUS TAKER IF
THEY ARE NOT CORRECT THAT IS ALL
THIS LADAS PLANE SIMPLY I AM OF
THE BILL.
SO I THINK IF WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MR CHOLERA
AND THE MISTER OPEN ALL DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SUMMER SANTIAGO FIRMING THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S THIS HAS
CREDIBILITY. TO THE CENSUS
TAKING PROCESS.
THE REALITY IS AND ALONG FORSMAN
CONTACTS WERE TALKING ABOUT
STING OPERATIONS WHAT HAVE YOU --
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO USE AS A
ONE OFF INTERACTION THAT CENSUS
TAKERS HAVE.
WITHIN IT WITH INDIVIDUALS AS A
RUSE -- THE THE ONES THAT WOULD
MOST LIKELY USE IT WAS OUR ICE
OR OTHER IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
WHICH ARE NOT PEACE OFFICERS
UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE LAW.
AND IT ALL COMES UNDER PUBLIC
POLICY DISCUSSION THE DECISION
ON A BALANCING ACT AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
A. N. ONE ICE AGENT.
IMPERSONATING A CENSUS TAKER FOR
THE PURPOSES OF DOING THEIR
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE SUCH
CHILLING AFFECT.
A DRUM I MEAN RIGHT RIGHT NOW
WHEN I'M IN SAN JOSE AND THERE'S
EVEN A RUMOR.
THAT ICE IS IN IT IS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD -- IN TOWN.
EVERYONE OF A RAISE THE ALARM
AND SO THIS IS ABOUT AN ACCURATE
COUNT THAT'S WHAT THE SENSE
ABOUT IT'S NOT ABOUT IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT NEVER SHOULD BE.
AND WE HAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AT STAKE.
AND SO -- IT'S REALLY PUZZLING
THAT WE WOULDN'T WANT EVERYONE I
I'D BE SHOCKED IF THIS IS NOT A
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS VOTE TO
MAKE SURE THOSE ARE ASKING.
THAT ARE UP.
ARE PUTTING THEMSELVES FORGED
ESSENCE TAKERS ARE ACTUAL CENSUS
TAKERS HEY IT'S I I DON'T I
DON'T SEE HOW IT'S ANY MORE
SUPPORT IN THAT.
AND BE ABSOLUTELY DON'T WANT ICE
ANYWHERE NEAR THE CENSUS TAKING
PROCESS -- UNLESS YOU REALLY
WANT AN UNDERCOUNT.
OF OF THOSE THAT THAT WOULD BE
THAT WOULD REACT TO THAT
CHILLING EFFECT AND I REALLY
WOULD HOPE THAT NO COMPANY
LEGISLATOR WOULD WANT THAT.
THANK YOU MR BRILL THING --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE IS
SUPPORTIVE OF OF MY QUESTION IS.
MY READING OF STATE LOG
INDICATES THAT THAT'S ALREADY
ILLEGAL FALLS PERSON NATIONS
ALREADY A CRIME UNDER CALIFORNIA
STATE PENAL CODE SO HOW DOES
THIS BILL DO ANYTHING MORE
THAT'S NOT ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
OR WILL IT WHEN WE WANT TO PUT
AN EXTRA LAYER ON A PLAIN AND
SIMPLE AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF YOU'RE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YOU HAD A
HESITATION ABOUT OPENING THAT
DOOR.
THAT YOU ARE INSURED 1100% --
THAT THIS INFORMATION WILL NOT
BE USED FOR ANY OTHER PURPOSE
AND AND I WOULD ECHO WHAT I SAID
EARLIER WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID LOOK AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE CERTAINLY LOOK THERE IS --
WHAT DO YOU ROOT WHATEVER SIDE
OF THE AISLE YOU'RE ON?
IT THAT WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO TRY TO ACCESS AS MANY DOLLARS
AS POSSIBLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT A PARTISAN
ISSUE IT'S QUITE FRANKLY BI
PARTISAN ISSUE WITH THE YOUR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA RULE AREAS.
OR URBAN AREAS LIKE I REPRESENT
YOU WANT YOUR POPULATIONS COUNTY
BECAUSE WHAT'S AT STAKE IS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- AND SO
THE ATTEMPT AT THIS IS TO ACT AN
EXTRA LAYER OF PROTECTION LIKE I
MENTIONED AND THEN TO THE SIGNAL
AND ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS --
DOCUMENTARY AND DOCUMENT
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE
PROTECTED UNDER THE LAW AND THAT
THE INFORMATION WILL NOT BE USED
FOR SOMETHING DIFFERENT BECAUSE
THE PERSON AT THE DOOR -- IS NOT
A FALSIFYING WHO THEY ARE.
BUT IT DOESN'T PREVENT.
ANYTHING ELSE OTHER THAN THAT
ONE PARTICULAR ACT.
OF KNOCKING ON SOMEONE'S DOOR
NOW HE'S KNOCKING THE THAT'S ONE
GENERAL WAY THAT HAPPENS.
AND SAYING -- THEY CAN STILL
KNOCK ON THE DOOR AND SAY WHO
THEY ARE THEY JUST CAN'T KNOCK
ON THE DOOR SAY ON THE CENSUS
WORKER COLLECT INFORMATION AND
THEN DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT WITH
IT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
IT AND TO BE CLEAR THIS IS
ACTUALLY AN AREA THAT'S A LITTLE
THAT IS NOT THAT CLEAR
UNDERSTATE LAW OR FEDERAL LAW.
BECAUSE THOSE LAWS ARE TYPICALLY.
TO PREVENT SOMEONE FROM.
POSING AS AN OFFICIAL IN ORDER
TO GAIN ACCESS TO SOMETHING OF
VALUE.
THIS IS DOCUMENTATION STATUS IS.
ARGUABLY NOT IN THAT CATEGORY SO
WE FIELD AND THAT'S WHY --
SUPPORTING THIS BILL WE FEEL
THAT THIS IS A POTENTIAL
LOOPHOLE AND GIVEN THE CHILLING
THE FACT.
THAT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAD NOT
REALLY BEEN CONTEMPLATED PRIOR.
IT WAS GALLAGHER.
SO JUST TO GET KIND OF MORE
SPECIFIC ON THE LANGUAGE -- THIS
SECTION WHERE IT SAYS OR FALSELY
ASSUME THE ROLE OF SO IT.
I GET I GET A FALSE
REPRESENTATION I'M A CENSUS
WORKER AND I'M HERE TO GET
INFORMATION THAT'S ONE THING BUT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
NONPROFIT GROUPS INVOLVED IN THE
CENSUS.
GOING OUT AND I MEAN ARE.
ARE THEY ASSUMING THE MAYBE
THEY'RE NOT AN OFFICIAL CENSUS
WORKER BUT THERE.
YOU ENCOURAGING PEOPLE GETTING
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN MAKING SURE
THEY FILL OUT CENSUS DATA.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT LEAVE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT.
WHAT IS ASSUMING THE ROLE OF A
CENSUS WORKER YOU KNOW I THINK?
IN A NICE TO KINDA TIGHTEN UP
SOME OF THAT LANGUAGE I GUESS
I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THE TIGHTENING UP BECAUSE I MEAN
THAT'S JUST THE THE THE ALL THE
BILL SAYS IT SHALL BE UNLAWFUL
FOR ANY PERSON TO FALSELY
REPRESENT THEMSELVES TO BE IN ON
A PUBLIC.
OFFICIAL OR PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
CONDUCTING A GOVERNMENT CENSUS
WITH A KNOWING INTENT TO DECEIVE
AND AND DOCUMENTARY -- THAT'S
THE WORST THAT.
THAT'S ABOUT OKAY.
I'M SORRY MS GALLAGHER.
I WAS LOOKING AT THAT
[inaudible] THREE JUST THAT
[inaudible]
ONE OKAY.
AGAIN THE KEY I MEAN THIS THIS
WAS A A COMMITTEE MEMBER THE KEY
TO THAT IS THAT THEY ARE FALSELY
ASSUMING THAT ROLE SO I DON'T
THINK THAT RUNS AFOUL OF SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN.
WHO IS ASSISTING?
IN THE IN THE THE UNDERTAKING SO
SOMEONE WHO IS ASSISTING IT NOT
NECESSARILY SAYING THAT THEY'RE
A GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL BUT SAYING
WE ARE ASSISTING THE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL BUT ON A FULL SPACES OR
TO COLLECT INFORMATION.
THAT'S WHERE THAT LIKE WHICH IS
INTENDED TO COVER.
WELL IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU WANT TO
WORK OUT WE SEE -- IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU WANT TO WORK ON
LANGUAGE ANYWAYS SO.
YEAH THAT THAT WAS KIND OF YOU
KNOW.
MY CONCERN.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SIGNAL MISTER SANTIAGO YOU
MAY CLOSE I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN RESPECT LAST FOR FOR AN
I. BOWED AND WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR ARE WORKING HELPS
CLARIFY WHERE WE'RE GOING THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU BUT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO SECOND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHOW. TWO BY CHU I CONSOLIDATES.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
COLDER I KYLIE.
MAIN SHINE HI MAIN SHINE I OVER
MULTI.
CRIMINAL T. I. PETRI NORRIS.
BEACH NORTH I RAISE.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT BRINGS US TO MISS
COME AUGER DEATH SO ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE GOOD
MORNING THE CHAIR MEMBERS.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
FIVE WHICH WILL REQUIRE
LANDLORDS IF THEY SEEK TO
DISPLACE THE TENANT OR LEASE SEE
UNDER THE ELLIS ACT. TO PROHIBIT
ACCESS TO THE UNLAWFUL DETAINER
ACTION RECORDS AND REQUIRE THE
LANDLORD TO IDENTIFY THE TYPE OF
UNLAWFUL DETAINER ACTION IN THE
CAPTION OF THE LANDLORDS
COMPLAINT.
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY FIVE WOULD
ENSURE THAT WHEN A LANDLORD HAS
ELECTED TO EVICT A TENANT UNDER
THE LS ACT.
NOT A PUBLIC EVICTION RECORD
DOES NOT UNFAIRLY PENALIZE THOSE
TENANTS SO CURRENTLY.
WHEN A LANDLORD DECIDES TO
RECLAIM THEIR PROPERTY THEY CAN
EVEN ACT A TENANT -- BUT WHAT
WILL IN IT AN ADVERT ONLY HAPPEN
IS.
HE VIXEN WILL SHOW UP ON THE
TENANTS CREDIT REPORT.
EVEN THOUGH WHILE TECHNICALLY
THEY WERE AFFECTED THEY WERE
EVICTED THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN SO THIS IS A RATHER
SENSIBLE AND PRACTICAL SOLUTION
TO THAT SITUATION THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS WE KNOW.
THAT THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
ARE DEALING WITH NOW.
AND THE LACK OF SUPPLY MAKES IT
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR TENANTS
WHO ARE LOOKING FOR RENTAL UNITS
TO FIND THEM AND IT WOULD BE
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM.
IF THEY HAVE THIS THE VIXEN ON
THEIR CREDIT REPORT.
IT IS ALSO I THINK THE CHALLENGE
FOR LANDLORDS WHO ARE LOOKING
FOR PROSPECTIVE TENANTS -- TO
FIND THAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT A
SHRINKING POOL OF PROSPECTIVE
TENANTS BECAUSE THERE ARE FOLKS
OUT THERE THAT HAVE THE VIXEN
NOTICES ON THEIR CREDIT REPORT
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN EVICTED
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
SO THIS BILL AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
FIVE WOULD ADDRESS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
AND WITH ME I HAVE IN SUPPORT
LARRY DOLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BAR ASSOCIATION AND BRING
BRIAN AUGUSTA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU FOR SWISS PLACE
MORNING LARRY DOYLE AND HAVE THE
CONFERENCE THE CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS NO LONGER THE STATE
BAR.
FOR BUT STILL -- AND THIS IS A I
REALLY HAVE NOTHING TO ADD TO
THIS DEBATE OTHER THAN WHAT WAS
IN THE ANALYSIS IS AN
EXCEPTIONAL.
ANALYSIS THAT GOES THROUGH THE
DETAILS AS TO THE WHY OF THE
BILL.
THE REASONS THAT THE IT IS
TAKING WE'VE TAKEN SUCH AN
INCREDIBLY FOCUSED.
EFFORT TRYING TO FIX.
HAVE A MENTAL EXCLUSIVELY ON
ELLIS ACTIVATIONS WHERE THERE IS
NO FAULT WHATSOEVER IN PART ON
THE PART OF THE TENANT.
BUT WHERE THE TENANT IS UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
POSSIBLY BEING CAUGHT WITH A
BROAD BRUSH AND HAVING THEIR
REPUTATION OF THEIR ABILITY TO
GIVE SUBSEQUENT HOUSING -- TAKEN
AWAY IT'S A IT'S YEAH I THINK
WE'VE DONE A GOOD JOB WE
APPRECIATE.
HIS CATALOGUER DOVE -- CARRYING
THE BILLING WE AS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT A SPLIT
MIXTURE MEMBER MEMBERS BRIAN
AUGUSTA.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
WE KNOW FROM TALKING TO
ATTORNEYS IN OUR FIELD OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE EVERY DAY
THAT.
AND IT'S AN AFFECTION ON YOUR
RECORD AS THE AUTHOR DISCUSSED
WILL HAVE LONG TERM IMPLICATIONS
OF THEIR ABILITY TO FIND.
HOUSING AND IN THIS INSTANCE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN ELSE
ACTIVE ACTION IN WHICH THERE IS.
NO FAULT ON THE TENANTS PART --
THE LANDLORD IS GETTING OUT OF
THE RENTAL HOUSING BUSINESS
THERE'S A VARIETY OF REASONS
THAT.
THAT ACTION MIGHT BE FILED IN
THAT MIGHT ULTIMATELY END UP ON
THE TENANTS CREDIT REPORT AND
IMPAIR THEIR ABILITY.
TO RENT HOUSING FOR SEVEN PLUS
YEARS AND THIS IS A SENSIBLE
PROTECTION THAT SAYS.
WE RECOGNIZE IT'S NOT FALL AND
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THAT MASKED SO THAT THAT DOES
NOT BECOME PART OF THE TENANTS.
PERMANENT RECORD AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE VIRGIN ABOUT.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
THESE THANK YOU.
YES I'M WILLIAM CASEY WITH A
SIDE DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
SASHA HER NAME AT THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT -- RUBBER CALLED A
SECOND A TENNIS YOU NEED SUPPORT.
MICHELLE PARASITE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTIAN ALONE -- PICO
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
JAMES DALE'S AMAZE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
AND JUST HEARD AGAIN IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE IS THEIR
OPPOSITION
.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS NEVER
CALLED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME STATE OUT OF
ALL DUE RESPECT THERE SHOULD
NEVER BE AN EVICTION IN THIS
SITUATION.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
CONFUSION BEING CREATED HERE.
THERE IS AND WE HAD ALWAYS
WORKED IN GOOD FAITH TO CREATE
LONG TERM NOTICES SO IN THIS
CASE OF THE ELLIS ACT.
TENANTS ARE GIVEN IN MANY CASES
A YEAR NOTICE IT'S NOT A FORMAL
OBJECTION.
WHAT'S HAPPENING UNFORTUNATELY
IN MANY OF OUR RENT CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS ON DAY.
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE AN
ATTORNEY HELPS ATTENDED STAY IN
THE UNIT BY SAYING DON'T LEAVE.
FORCE THE EVICTION ACTED ACTION
TO TAKE PLACE.
THE OWNERS ALREADY COMMITTED TO
EXTENSIVE RELOCATION COSTS IN
SAN FRANCISCO THERE'SEXTENSIVE
RELOCATION COSTS.
AND NOW.
BECAUSE THE THE TENANT HAS NOT
LEFT AFTER THAT THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAY NOTICE.
THERE IS A FORMAL OBJECTION THAT
IS FILED.
THE OWNER AND LET ME MAKE IT
ALSO CLEAR THESE OWNERS ARE NOT
LARGE OWNERS THEY'RE VERY SMALL
OWNERS.
IN MANY CASES THE AVERAGE SIZE
OF AN ELLIS ACT IS ABOUT TEN
UNITS VERY SMALL SO IT'S A MOM
AND POP NOW AFTER PAYING
RELOCATION.
AND NOW BEING FORCED TO FILE AN
EVICTION BECAUSE THEY IN MOST
CASES WANT TO MOVE INTO THE UNIT
THEMSELVES -- HAVE TO NOW PAY AN
ATTORNEY.
IN MOST CASES IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THEY'RE NOT GETTING RENT
BECAUSE THE TENANT IS NOT GOING
TO PAY RENT UNDER THIS SITUATION.
SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THERE SHOULD NEVER BE AN
EVICTION THIS CASE BECAUSE OF
THE EXTENSIVE NOTICE THAT IT'S
ALREADY HAPPENED.
AND WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION -- CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING WOULD BE PROUD THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL -- AT THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE BILLS CUTTING OFF
ACCESS TO THE COURT RECORDS AND
REALLY CUTTING OFF THE ONLY
MEANINGFUL WAY THAT A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC OR JOURNALIST OF
THEY'RE INVESTIGATING THESE
ISSUES.
COULD GET ACCESS TO THOSE
RECORDS THEY BASICALLY HAVE TO
KNOW ALL THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE CASES ARE READY TO GET
ACCESS.
UNDER THE BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN -- WE'VE BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
HAVING A GOOD DIALOGUE THERE SO
WE'RE HOPING WE CAN WORK OUT.
MORE NARROW WAY -- TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM THIS BILLS AIMED AT
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THIS REBUILDING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THE ELSE
ACT BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
THAT UNDER THE ACT YOU CAN
PROVIDE NOTICE AND THE TENTATIVE
SUPPOSED TO MOVE OUT AT THE END
OF THAT NOTICE PERIOD OF THE
TENANT DOESN'T MOVE OUT AT THE
END OF THAT NOTICE PERIOD.
THEN YOU HAVE TO FILE AN
EVICTION UNDER THE ELLIS ACT SO
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT.
YOUR BILL WOULD BE -- FOR
PROTECTING OTHER PEOPLE THAT
REFUSED TO MOVE OUT AFTER THE
END OF THE NOTICE PERIOD IS THAT
RIGHT BECAUSE I I'M JUST I'M
JUST WONDERING WHEN A WALK.
IT IF THESE PEOPLE THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN HAD TO MOVE
OUT THEN I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE ON
THEIR CREDIT REPORT BUT IF THEY
REFUSED TO MOVE OUT MAYBE THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT SHOULD BE OF
CONCERN TO A FUTURE LANDLORDS OF
JUST.
WONDERING HOW YOU REACT TO THAT
[inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
ADAM.
JOE DIRT TWO THINGS ON THAT
QUESTION I AM ONE THERE ARE A
VARIETY OF REASONS IN WHICH AT
THE TIME PERIOD THAT AS A
LANDLORD MIGHT BE ENTITLED TO
FILE THEIR ACTION.
THERE.
ARE THAT THE ACTION COULD BE
FILED WITHOUT THE TENANT.
WELL WE SEE FREQUENTLY AN ACTION
FILED EVEN THOUGH THE TENNIS
COMPLIED WITH THE NOTICE SO
THAT'S ONE POSSIBILITY THAT THE
ACTION WOULD BE FILED.
AND THE TENANT HAD MOVED OUT AND
SO THEN THEY WOULD BE IMPLICATED
POTENTIALLY IN ESSENCE -- TO IF
THE ACTION WERE PROSECUTED
FURTHER BY THE LANDLORD.
SECONDLY THERE MAY ACTUALLY BE A
LEGITIMATE DISPUTE ABOUT THE
SUFFICIENCY OF THE NOTICE AND
THAT'S WHY OUR COURT SYSTEM
PROVIDES THE REVENUES THAT IT
DOES TO ALLOW IT. TO DEFEND HIM
OR HERSELF AND SO.
ALTHOUGH THERE WAS NO FAULT ON
BEHALF OF THE TENANT THEY WERE
ASSERTING A DEFENSE THAT THEY
ARE ENTITLED TO UNDER THE ELLIS
ACTIVE GET.
ADEQUATE NOTICE AND SO THAT MAY
LEAD ALSO -- TO TO THE ACTION
PROCEEDING IN A WAY THAT COULD
OTHERWISE SHOP ON THEIR CREDIT
REPORTS I THINK.
ALTHOUGH IN THE VAST NUMBER OF
CASES PEOPLE WILL MOVE OUT THERE
ARE INSTANCES IN WHICH THEY ARE
LEGITIMATELY DEFENDING THEIR
RIGHTS OR HAVE HAD THE ACTION
PROCEED WITHOUT -- THEIR ABILITY
TO DEFEND BECAUSE THEY HAVE IN
FACT MOVED OUT AND THEN THAT
COULD SHOW UP ON THE RECORD AS
WELL OKAY BUT THE I MEAN THE
BILL'S VERY BROADLY WORDED.
I MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
THAT IS NOT SAYING THAT IT'S
GOING TO PROTECT JUST THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE CHALLENGING THE
SUFFICIENCY OF THE NOTICE.
IT SAYING THAT IT'S ALSO GOING
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE
TO IGNORE THE NOTICE AND NOT
MOVE OUT.
THE BILLS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
THOSE TENANTS WHO.
ARE GIVEN AN EVICTION NOTICE
BECAUSE THE LANDLORD IS
RECLAIMING THE PROPERTY FOR
THEIR OWN USE.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
THESE TENANTS ARE BEING VICTOR
PUTS THE LAW ALLOWS THE LANDLORD
TO DO.
RIGHT BUT THE LAW ALSO SAYS THAT
YOU STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND RIGHT NOW THE
PROCESS IS CALLED.
EVICTION NOT NONE OF THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE DISAGREEING BECAUSE
WELL I MEAN IT.
THE LANDLORD PROVIDES NOTICE.
AND UNDER THE LAW THE TENANT HAS
TO VACATE WITHIN THE NOTICE
PERIOD IS OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO
VACATE.
IF THEY REFUSED TO VACATE.
THEN THE LANDLORD FILES AND
FICTION NOTICE UNDER THE ELLIS
ACT AND THAT FALLS UNDER THE
CATEGORY FOR BILL.
I MEAN WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO.
HAVE -- YOU KNOW THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN BEING FORCED
OUT IN AND I'M I'M SURE OUR
HEARTS ARE WITH WITH THOSE
PEOPLE.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE REFUSED TO LEAVE.
I IT LOOKS I MISUNDERSTAND WELL
THERE ARE A LOT OF INSTANCES
WHERE.
INDIVIDUALS MAY HAVE -- THE
TENANTS MAY WISH TO BE -- YOU
MAY BELIEVE THAT THE L. SECTION --
EVICTION IS OR THE REMOVAL
WHATEVER YOU CALL IT -- GUN. TO
THE NOTICES INSUFFICIENT THEY
KNOW THEY'RE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE.
INCORRECTLY EVERYTHING ELSE AND
THEY HAVE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS -- THERE'S A
MENTIONED IN THE LETTER THAT
WOULD WAS RECEIVED THAT.
IS OVER IT'S CAN BE A YEAR'S
NOTICE BUT THEN THAT'S ONLY
LIMITED IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
IS THAT THE GREATER NUMBER OF
NOTICES ARE A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS WHICH IS SUBSTANTIALLY LEFT
LESSENED THE LEGAL UNIVERSE.
AND THE PROBLEM IS RIGHT NOW
WITH IT.ONE THING THAT YOU HAVE
IS THAT IF YOU SEEK TO DEFEND
YOUR RIGHTS AS A TENANT. TO SAY
THAT THE NOTICES INSUFFICIENT OR
THEIR OTHER.
OF FAILINGS IN THE EFFORTS TO
HAVE YOU REMOVED AND THE ELLIS
ACT WHATEVER THAT IF YOU DO THAT
WITHIN THAT TIME FRAME YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO BE REX KING.
BEING IN AN EVICTION SITUATION
AND THEREFORE YOUR CHANCES OF
GETTING HOUSING DOWN THE LINE.
ARE GOING TO BE -- CERTAINLY ARE
GOING TO BE HURT WHAT
SUBSTANTIAL JUST TO BE CLEAR IF
THE BILL HAD BEEN WORDED.
SO THAT IF YOU CHALLENGED AND
ALICE ACT.
EVICTION AND PREVAILED THAT THE
COURT RECORD WOULD SEAL.
I THINK -- WE WOULD BE A 100%.
BEHIND YOU BUT IT'S NOT WORTH IT
THAT WAY IT'S WORDED TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN CONVICTED.
UNDER THE ELLIS ACT EVEN THE
PEOPLE WHO KNEW THEY HAD TO
VACATE REFUSED TO VACATE DIDN'T
HAVE A LEGITIMATE REASON FOR
REVIEWS THAT REFUSAL.
AND THE LANDLORD HAD WAS FORCED
TO THAT THE SO I MEAN THAT THAT
THAT'S WHY I MEAN UNFORTUNATE
OFTEN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION --
IF IF IT HAD BEEN WORDED MORE
NARROWLY THAN I WOULD HAVE LIKED
TO BUT SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THOSE THAT
ARE PRESENT.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
STEVE I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS THE YELLOW SECT IN MANY
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE
INCLUDING MY OWN.
HAS BEEN USED.
TO EFFECT HUNDREDS OF NOT
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS -- AND IN
MANY INSTANCES THE ELLIS ACT HAS
BEEN FOUND TO BE A PRETEXT FOR
MOVING FOLKS OUT WITH CERTAIN
OWNERS WHO THEN.
OUR RENT OUT APARTMENTS -- AFTER
NOT HAVING -- MOVE FOR WITH WHAT
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DONE ON
THE ELLIS ACT.
AND IN OTHER INSTANCES -- IT I
DON'T THINK ANYONE HERE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT IF YOU'VE LIVED IN
YOUR HOME FOR DECADES -- YOU
SHOULD DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO
TRY TO STAY TO LIVE IN YOUR HOME
WHEN THE ALTERNATIVE IS BEING
FORCED OUT ON THE STREET AND
THAT'S AGAIN THE CIRCUMSTANCE WE
FIND A LOT OF THESE FAMILIES AND
AND SO.
THE CHOICE THAT.
I THINK THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO
ADDRESSES. FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
TO EXERCISE ALL OF THE LEGAL
RIGHT TO HAVE -- BUT BUT IN THIS
CASE THEY'RE FORCED -- TO
POTENTIALLY RISK HAVING THEIR
NAME BE PUT ON A COMMERCIAL
BLACKLIST THAT WOULD PREVENT
THEM FROM BEING A WELL
CONSIDERED BY FUTURE LANDLORDS
FOR UP TO SEVEN YEARS AND AND
AND I THINK THE IDEA THAT.
GIVEN THAT THE STARTED --
BECAUSE OF AN ADDICTION THAT DID
NOT HAVE TO DO WITH ANYTHING
THAT WAS AT THE FAULT OF THE
TENANT -- WE SHOULD NOT FORCE
THEM TO THIS CHOICE OF WHETHER
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS OR BE
PLACED ON A BLACKLIST FOR THE
NEXT SEVEN YEARS AND BECAUSE OF
THAT -- I WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
SUPPORTING THIS AND HAVE BEEN
WITH US BEFORE THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION SIR SECOND.
AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
FEATURED OR CAN I JUST CAN I
CLARIFY AND THE CAT CATEGORIES
AS INDIVIDUAL THAT YOU SAID THAT
THIS WOULD APPLY TO SO YOU THINK
YOU SAID THAT.
THERE ARE THE PEOPLE IN STROBEL
EVERNOTE HE NOTED I WHO.
REFUSED TO LEAVE THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENGAGED IN A
LEGITIMATE DISPUTE ABOUT THE
EVICTION PROCEEDINGS.
SOUND LIKE YOU SAID THERE IS A
THIRD CATEGORY OF INDIVIDUAL WHO
ACTUALLY HAVE LEFT.
WHEN THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BUT
ARE STILL BEING FALSELY LISTED
AS BEING AFFECTED WITH THE DATA
THAT IS A POSSIBLE OUTCOME YEAH
I MEAN I THINK WE HAVE SEEN
INSTANCES IN WHICH AND?
MR TO DID A BILL COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO TO TRY.
TO DEAL WITH THIS PROBLEM BUT WE
WERE SEEING.
INSTANCES IN WHICH THE ACTION IS
FILED THEN THE TENANT.
MOVED OUT OR MAYBE THEY MOVE OUT
SIMULTANEOUS DETECTION BEING
FILED THEY MAY NEVER GET NOTICE
OF THE ACTION THEY GET A DEFAULT
AND THAT DEFAULT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE LANDLORD TO GET AN ORDER OF
POSSESSION.
AND THEN THAT WOULD.
WOULD THEN BE REFLECTED ON THE
TENANTS CREDIT REPORT AND SO I
THINK.
THERE IS THAT THAT IS A POSSIBLE
OUTCOME THERE'S ALSO THE
POSSIBLE OUTCOME IS YOU --
REITERATING OF A PERSON IS
DEFENDING THEMSELVES AND I THINK
JUST THE OTHER POINT THAT I
FAILED TO MAKE THERE WAS.
IF YOU HAVE.
THE COURT THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THE
LANDLORD CAN GET POSSESSION BACK
THERE THEY CAN FILE THEIR
EVICTION ACTION THEY CAN PROCEED
TO A JUDGMENT QUESTION IS
WHETHER IT REFLECTS ON THE
TENANTS.
CREDIT WORTHINESS AND IN THIS
INSTANCE BECAUSE AS MR SHE WAS
DISCUSSING AND THE AUTHORS
POINTED OUT.
A THERE'S REALLY NO FAULTS HERE
MAYBE THERE WAS A DISPUTE MAYBE
THERE WAS A DIFFICULTY SECURING
OTHER HOUSING BUT IT REALLY CAN
REFLECT ON THEM AS A TENANT.
THAT THAT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE
KIND OF THING THAT WE SHOULD PUT
ON THE TENNIS GREAT REPORT FOR
SEVEN YEARS AND THAT'S I THINK
THE CENTRAL PREMISE BEHIND THIS
BILL.
RIGHT NOW I DO I APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND YES WHEN
IT COMES IN THE BUSINESS WORLD
THE IMPORTANCE OF BEING ABLE TO
HEAR HAVE DATA TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS.
BUT I THINK IN THIS CASE
PARTICULARLY WHEN THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE THAT DATA IS
FLAWED.
AND THE IMPLICATIONS AND THE AND
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THAT DATA
BEING FIRED.
ON SOMEONE'S CREDIT REPORT FOR
SEVEN YEARS IS.
MEANS ABSOLUTELY CATASTROPHIC
AND SO TO ME I THINK.
YEAH THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE
I'M GONNA.
YOU'RE ON THE SIDE OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT HI.
RUNNING SOMEONE'S LIFE --
PERMANENTLY BECAUSE OF A
POTENTIALLY FIVE DATA.
I AND SOME HAVE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS ALL IN.
YES I WAS GOING TO I WAS KIND OF
FOLLOW ALONG THE SAME LINES AT
THE THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS
ARE ARE -- NOTED AND AS I WAS
REFLECTING ON THE QUESTION BACK
AND FORTH I WAS ALSO TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF AFTER. THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS IF THEY
STAY IN THE UNIT THAT THAT SORT
OF SPARKS AND NEED TO TAKE SOME
TYPE OF ACTION BUT I BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CLARITY OF WHAT.
THE CHALLENGE WOULD REPRESENT
THAT THEY'RE STILL BLACKLISTED
FOR SEVEN YEARS AS I UNDERSTAND
IT AND THAT.
SEEMS TO BE A BIT EXCESSIVE IN
TERMS OF THEIR TRYING TO
CHALLENGE OR BETTER CLARIFY --
THE POSITION AND I GUESS ALL OF
THESE SITUATIONS WE KNOW THERE
ARE -- PROPERTY OWNERS OUT THERE
WHO -- CAN USE THESE.
THEY ALL SUCK AND OTHER TOOLS TO
DO THE RIGHT THING AND THEN
THERE ARE THOSE WHO MAY NOT OR
MAY BE USING IT FOR OTHER
PURPOSES AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO -- NOTED SO -- I%
THINK UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
INTENT OF TRYING TO PROTECT --
FOLKS WHO ARE IN A SITUATION.
BY NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN -- TO
SAFEGUARD THEM FROM BEING PUT IN
JEOPARDY -- WITH THEIR CREDIT --
BEING PUT.
ON A SEVEN YEAR -- STATUS I
THINK THAT.
IT'S WORTHY OF THE SUPPORT I I'D
LIKE TO HAVE THOUGHT THAT THERE
WAS A WAY TO MAYBE EVEN.
FINE TUNE IT A LITTLE BIT MORE --
WITH SOME TYPE OF AN AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD ADDRESS.
WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS RAISED SO
THAT THERE'S?
ABOUT THAT LIGHT SHINING THROUGH
HERE THAT IT COULD BE SEALED A
LITTLE TIGHTER -- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT WOULD BE AT THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT -- BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THERE TO CONTINUE TO
BE CONVERSATION AND AND THAT
PROCESS IF THERE'S A WAY.
TO SORT OF FINE TUNE A LITTLE
BIT MORE I CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE
THAT BUT AS IT'S WRITTEN TODAY
AND WITHOUT HAVING ANY.
OF SUGGESTED.
ALTERNATIVE I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT [inaudible] TWO OTHERS.
RIGHT THIS CALL NOT GONNA BE MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED
ANY PROPOSED AMENDMENTS FROM THE
OPPOSITION BUT BASED ON THE
CONVERSATION HAD HEARING
COMMITTEE I AM CERTAINLY WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE SO THAT WE
CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO TIGHTEN
THE LANGUAGE SO THAT IT IS
EXPLICIT AND AND YOU WHO IT IS --
TRYING TO PROTECT -- THE
OPPOSITION IS IS CORRECT IN MANY
INSTANCES THESE LANDLORDS ARE
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS ON THAT
HAVE VERY SMALL NUMBERS OF UNITS
AND THEIR RELOCATION ASSISTANT
COSTS ARE EXORBITANT.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN THEY ARE
LOOKING TO RECLAIM PROPERTY
THROUGH NO AT YOU KNOW IN A
DATING ATTENDANT TO NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN IT IS.
THEIR INCREDIBLE FINANCIAL
STRAIN OFTEN TIMES THAT THEY'RE
DOING SO AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
TO FIND WAYS TO BOTH PROTECT
THEM BUT ALSO TO PROTECT THE
TENANTS.
WHO WILL NOW HAVE TO LOOK YOU
KNOW FOR OTHER -- SPACES TO RENT
AND SHOULDN'T BE BLACKLISTED OR
BLACKBALLED BECAUSE THEY WERE
EVICTED THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN -- WITH THIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
BY STONE ARE GALLAGHER.
ALGOR DON'T NO CHILD. TO TWO
ARKANSAS IS HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CHOLERA.
CALLER I. KYLIE.
MAIN SHINE.
OVER NINETY OVER NINETEEN NO
PETRI NORRIS BETWEEN NORTH I
RAISE.
THAT NEEDS TO MORE VOTES I'M
GONNA PUT IT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
TEXAS TO MR BONTA.
I REMEMBER THIRTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES MORNING STAFF.
I FIRST WAS ONE OF THEIR FRONT
THANK YOU FOR THE WHAT I
CONSIDERED OUTSTANDING.
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BOB VERY
THOROUGH -- VERY NUANCED AND I'M
JUST REALLY.
EXPLAINED AND AND AND AND MADE
THIS ISSUE.
I'M ALIVE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
OUTSTANDING WORK BY EIGHT BY
YOUR TEAM MISTER CHAIR IN AND
YOUR STAFF.
WE'RE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HAS A HOUSING CRISIS.
YOU MUST CALL IT WHAT IT IS THAT
WE MUST ACT.
ACCORDINGLY SEVENTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS READ THE PLACE THEY
CALL HOME.
OUR FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORS ARE
FACING SKYROCKETING RENTS AND
MANY FACE EVICTIONS THAT FORCE
THEM FROM THEIR HOMES.
I REPRESENT ONE OF THE HARDEST
CITIES OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
BUT OAKLAND IS NOT ALONE IN THIS
CRISIS ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
DISPLACEMENT DUE TO LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IS CHANGING THE VERY FACE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT MANY PEOPLE CAN
NO LONGER AFFORD. TO LIVE WHERE
THEY GREW UP.
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO WHERE THEY
WORK.
OR IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT THEY
LOVE.
A B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE WILL
ADDRESS WRONG PHONE AND ON
JUSTIFICATIONS IT WILL HELP TO
KEEP MORE FAMILIES.
IN THEIR HOMES.
UNDER A BE FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
TENANTS WOULD BE PROTECTED FROM
DISCRIMINATORY RETALIATORY.
OR ARBITRARY EVICTIONS LANDLORDS
WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO EVICT.
TENANTS FOR FAIR REASONS FOR
JUST REASONS FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
BREACH THAT LEASES REFUSED TO
PAY RENT.
OR BREAK LAWS RELATED TO THEIR
TENANCY.
LAST WEEK THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
AND HOUSING PAST AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY SOME
REMEMBER.
TO MR CHOOSE RENT STABILIZATION
ANTI GOUGING BILL GOES HAND IN
HAND WITH THIS BILL.
IF A TENANT IS PROTECTED FROM
RENT GOUGING BUT CAN BE EVICTED
FOR ANY REASON.
OR FOR TEN IT CAN ONLY BE
EVICTED FOR FAIR AND JUST
REASONS BUT CAN BE ECONOMICALLY
AFFECTED BY AN EXCESSIVE RENT
INCREASE.
THEY ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED.
TENNIS NEEDS NEED AND DESERVE
BOTH ANTI RENT GOUGING AND JUST
BECAUSE PROTECTIONS.
TODAY.
RENTERS CAN BE EVICTED WITHOUT
ANY INDICATION AS TO WHY.
THIS LEAVES SO MANY OF
CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY MILLION
TENANTS WONDERING.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF I LOSE MY
HOME?
WHERE WILL I GO?
HOW WILL I FIND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING?
HOW WILL I TAKE CARE OF MY
FAMILY?
OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT
LIMITED TO JUST THE SUPPLY
PROBLEM.
WE DO NEED MORE SUPPLY AND I
HAVE AND I DO SUPPORT BUILDING
MORE UNITS ESPECIALLY AFFORDABLE
UNITS.
BUT WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT A
HOUSING CRISIS HOLISTICALLY.
AND USE EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX TO BRING RELIEF TO AS
MANY CALIFORNIANS.
AS POSSIBLE.
WE CAN AND WE SHOULD STIMULATE
SUPPLY AND PROTECT OUR TENANTS.
THESE THESE APPROACHES ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE.
A B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
OUR HOUSING CRISIS. FOR THAT
REASON I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE I
VOTE TODAY.
HERE WITH ME TODAY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
ONE OUR OUR EXIT SASHA HARNDEN
REPRESENTING ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
STARSHIP HOW.
A TENANT FROM REDWOOD CITY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SASHA POWELL I AM ONE OF
THE LEADERS OF FAIR RUNS FOR
REDWOOD CITY AND COALITION WITH
FAITH IN ACTION BAY AREA.
PART OF PICO CALIFORNIA.
I'VE LIVED IN MY APARTMENT IN
REDWOOD CITY FOR OVER SIXTEEN
YEARS.
I AM HERE TO SHARE MY STORY OF
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND EXPRESS
MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE FOR JUST
CAUSE OF ACTION PROTECTIONS.
WITH THE LACK OF STRONG LOCAL
KIND OF PROTECTIONS TENANTS LIKE
MYSELF BECOME VICTIMS OF NO
BECAUSE OF ACTIONS AND RENT
GOUGING.
HOWEVER WITH THE PASSING OF NEW
BILL SUCH AS THE ONE HER TODAY
A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE TENNIS NOT
ONLY IN REDWOOD CITY BUT ALL
ACROSS THE STATE WOULD BE
PROTECTED FROM VICIOUS LANDLORD
EVICTION TACTICS WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO STAY IN OUR HOMES.
WHEN MY BUILDING TRANSITION TO
NEW OWNERSHIP LAST YEAR I WAS
SERVED THE SIXTY DAY KNOWS CAUSE
OF ACTION NOTICED ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OF THEM TAKING POSSESSION?
ALTHOUGH NO SPECIFIC REASON WAS
GIVEN I CAN SPECULATE I MAY HAVE
BEEN FOR SEVERAL REASONS IN
RETALIATION FOR MY REQUEST
REPAIRS.
AND COMPLAINTS ABOUT LIVING
CONDITIONS SUCH AS NO HOT WATER
FOR FIVE MONTHS. FOR MY EFFORT
IN ATTEMPTING TO ORGANIZE OTHER
TENANTS. FOR THE SIMPLE REASON
TO REMOVE ME SO THAT A HIGHER
INCOME RESIDENT COULD MOVE IN
WHO COULD PAY MORE OR EVEN FOR
DISCRIMINATORY PURPOSES.
THIS ADDICTION NOTICE GIVEN
AFTER MY SIXTEEN YEARS THERE.
I WAS NOT THE ONLY ONE SEVERAL
OTHER TENANTS IN MY BUILDING
LONG TERM TENANTS WERE ALSO
SERVE NO BECAUSE OF ACTIONS
AFTER YEARS OF LIVING IN THEIR
HOMES.
NO REASON GIVEN WE JUST KNEW WE
HAD TO LEAVE.
I FELT LIKE GIVING UP HONESTLY.
I'VE LIVED THERE LONGER THAN I
WOULD ANYWHERE IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
I AM DISABLED IT IS MY SANCTUARY
AND WITHOUT IT I FEAR I WON'T BE
ABLE TO HOLD ON TO MY PRECARIOUS
HEALTH.
FORTUNATELY FOR ME AFTER USING
THE THREAT OF LEGAL ACTION UNDER
THE PROMISE OF RETALIATION.
THE OWNERS DECIDED TO RETRACT
THE NO CAUSE OF ACTION.
HOWEVER IT DID NOT REPLACE THE
SEVERAL MONTHS OF ANGUISH AND
STRESS I FELT DURING THOSE DAYS
WONDERING IF I COULD STAY AT MY
HOME.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK OF
OTHER TENANTS IN THE STATE WHO
DO NOT HAVE THE WILL POWER
ACCESS YOUR INFORMATION TO
ADDRESS SUCH ATROCIOUS ACTIONS.
ALTHOUGH THAT OBJECTION WAS
ADDRESSED AS SOON EXPERIENCE A
NOTICE OF RENT INCREASE THAT
WOULD MORE THAN DOUBLE MY RENT.
I AM NOW BEING FORCED TO LOOK
FOR NEW HOUSING AND MOVE OUT BY
THE END OF JULY BECAUSE I CANNOT
AFFORD THE NEW ROUND.
AND WITH A NEWLY ISSUED SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHER FINDING A PLACE IS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE.
I AM HERE TO SUPPORT A BE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE AND JUST
BECAUSE OF ACTION PROTECTIONS
BUT TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT.
THAT IT WILL TAKE MULTIPLE AND
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS TO FIX
OUR HOUSING CRISIS SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS I'M JUST NOW BECAUSE OF
ACTIONS IN ADDITION TO
SKYROCKETING RENTS THEY MUST GO
TOGETHER.
IN REDWOOD CITY WE HAVE LITTLE
TO NO REAL RENTER PROTECTIONS
AND ABSOLUTELY NO RENT
STABILIZATION POLICY WE NEED
STRONG AND REAL PROTECTIONS NOW.
PROTECTIONS LIKE THOSE IN A B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE AND AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WHICH
PROTECTS TENNIS FROM ADDICTION
WITHOUT REASON.
AND PREVENT UNCONSCIONABLE RENT
HIKES LIKE THE ONE I JUST
EXPERIENCED.
LAST THURSDAY THE GOVERNOR
STATED IN REMARKS THAT
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS SENIORS
FAMILIES WITH SMALL CHILDREN AND
PEOPLE ON A FIXED INCOME.
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO LIVE IN
CONSTANT FEAR OF ADDICTION BUT
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
ARE HOUSING AND SECURE FACING
EVICTION AND WONDERING IF THEY
WILL BE HOMELESS THE NEXT TIME
THEY COMPLAIN OR GET SERVED A
RATE HIKE.
WE MUST PROTECT OUR PEOPLE
PLEASE SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
ANYONE ABOUT TO PROTECT US TO
PROTECT ME TODAY.
THE TIME IS NOW MILLIONS OF
TENANTS ARE DEPENDING ON YOU
THANK YOU.
HOLD ON HOLD ON YOU GUYS WERE
VERY WELL BEHAVED.
EARLIER ON BUT I DO WE WE CANNOT
HAVE.
WE WE CANNOT HAVE OUTBURSTS IF
THE YOU HAD READ EARLIER IF YOU
WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT.
THAT'S PERFECTLY FINE BUT NO
OUTBURSTS PLEASE NO TALKING OVER
OTHER WITNESSES [inaudible]
PLEASE NO.
COMMENTING FROM THE AUDIENCE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE CAN HEAR
AND LISTEN TO EVERY WITNESS
THAT'S TALKING TODAY SO YOU
YOU'VE DONE GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALRIGHT NEXT WITNESS PLEASE GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBERS I'M SUCH A
HARD TIME WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR A BE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE THIS BILL
WOULD ELIMINATE ARBITRARY
AFFECTIONS AND PROTECT TENANTS
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION AND
RETALIATION BY REQUIRING
LANDLORDS TO STATE IT THE REASON
BEFORE EVICTING TENANTS FROM
THEIR HOMES.
THE BILL LET'S SETTLE ALLOWABLE
REASONS FOR EVICTION INTO
CATEGORIES OUT FAULT AND NO
FAULT EVICTIONS.
OUT FAULT OF ACTIONS INCLUDE
THOSE BASED ON TEN AND CONDUCT
SUCH AS NON PAYMENT OF RENT
VIOLATION OF THE LEASE OR
DISTURBING NEIGHBORS.
AND NO FAULT EVICTIONS INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE ON OUR MOVE AND
DEMOLITION OR RENOVATION -- FOR
NO FAULT EVICTIONS THE BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE PAYMENT
OF RELOCATION ASSISTANCE TO
TENANTS AND RECOGNITION OF THE
HARDSHIP IMPOSE ONE ONCE FORCE
FROM YOUR HOME.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT NOVEL THEY
HAVE BEEN IN PLACE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND IN CONNECTION
WITH ALMOST EVERY SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING PROGRAM FOR DECADES AND
OF LANDLORDS BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS PROBLEMS THAT MAY ARISE
IN PROPERTIES.
OR TO BE ABLE TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO WITH THEIR PROPERTIES
SUCH AS UNDER THE ALLIS ACT --
IT'S ALSO A CRITICAL BELT TO
ENSURING THAT OUR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS SKYROCKETING RENTS AND
PRICE GOUGING ARE EFFECTIVE.
BY PREVENTING LANDLORDS FROM
ESSENTIALLY ACCESSING A LOOPHOLE
WHEREBY THEY COULD EFFECT A
TENANT FOR NO REASON AND THEN
RAISE THE RENT. FOR THE NEXT
TOWN AND IN VIOLATION OF OUR
EFFORTS AROUND AROUND PRICE
GOUGING SO -- THIS BILL SIMPLY
STATES THAT OF LANDMARKS DON'T
HAVE A VALID REASON TO EVICT A
TENANT THEY SHOULDN'T FORCE THAT
TENET FROM THEIR HOME AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OR DRIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHERS AND
SUPPORTS.
YOU WANNA COME INDICATE SUPPORT.
CAN COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND GIVE HIS NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION BUT I'M AFRAID WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AT THIS
POINT.
BRIAN GUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND SPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE PARASITE WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES PRO BECAUSE SPONSORS
AND SUPPORT.
VVC LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAME IN DEAN POLICY LINK PROUD
CO SPONSORS AND SUPPORT.
I'D RATHER YES CENTRAL VALLEY
EMPOWERMENT ALLIANCE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MATTHEW MAKE YOUR PLANNING
CONSERVATION LAKE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
A LOUIS MONTANA WE HAVE OF
CALIFORNIA BE AND SUPPORT I JUST
ALSO NOTE THAT HALF A DOZEN
OTHER YOU ME WORDS SUCH AS YOURS
AND IN YOUR DISTRICT ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I A SEVENTY I WAS WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS I'M HERE ALSO
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZE FOR
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT.
CENTER FOR POLICY INITIATIVES IN
SAN DIEGO LOS ANGELES AS WELL
ALLIANCE FOR NEW ECONOMY THE
CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE UNITED
FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY.
IN SILICON VALLEY RISING THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
CHARLOTTE FIVE SOLD BAY AREA
LEGAL AID IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
HI MY DEBATE IS TREES FROM
ALAMEDA MATURE PERSON.
THE L. -- DEMOCRATIC PARTY
RENTERS CAUCASUS CENTRAL VALLEY
APARTMENT ALLIANCE.
ENCOMPASSING US A NEW DOES THAT
BY THIS I'M WORKING. TO SUPPORT.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE AT
YOU I HAVE P. T. LOCAL TWENTY
ONE ENGINEERS SCIENCES
CALIFORNIA -- UTILITY WORKERS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WAS SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
STRONG SUPPORT.
HEAVY ARMOR SOMEBODY HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
MY SECOND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK.
MY ANGER MAY CELIA OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
MADISON WILLIAM HAVE A SO CALLED
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT -- CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT --
RUBBER COUPLE SECRETARIES YOU'RE
STRONG SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MEETING WITH WHITE
HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF THE SILICON VALLEY AT HOME AS
WELL AS HABITAT FOR HUMANITY THE
SPACE ALL KIND OF RALLY IN
SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DO YOU THINK I GUESS ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ASSOCIATION IN SPORT.
SEP BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
CITY WHEREVER LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT.
READ MORE NUMBER YOU HAVE THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WANDA JACKSON SEIU LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHOULD BE THE HARD ROCK.
SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN AND I
MEAN A LOT STRONG SUPPORT --
MEGARA REPRESENTING SEIU LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHN JAPAN WITH SEIU LOCAL TEN
TO ONE STRUCK SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JAMES DALE MAZE RICHMAN
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
EDDIE CARMONA A CO SPONSOR AND
PROUD SUPPORTER OF BECAUSE
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL FIVE EIGHTHS ACTION
OAKLAND STRONG SUPPORT.
FRANCISCO TOWARDS PITTSBURGH
COUNTRY COST A STRONG SUPPORT.
NICOLE DEAN OAKLAND ACE ACTION
STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN I LIVED IN MARTINEZ A
SACRAMENTAL STRONG SUPPORT?
MEGHAN ABLE TEKAKWITHA
COLLABORATIVE STRONG SUPPORT.
RYAN BEESON AT THE NATIONAL
UNION OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
SUPPORT.
HI MCAT ARE FROM CONCORD WITH
ACE STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT THREES BUT THE SAVIOR FROM
ETS FROM CONCORD CALIFORNIA A
STRONG SUPPORT.
LAURA HUMANNESS A SECOND MAN
KNOWN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOIN UP AHEAD OF THE WITH ACE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND SUPPORT.
IBRAHIM AND GROW WITH ACE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE CHRIS RESPONSE OF THE
TRAILER CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
EMITTER RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
INSTRUCTS APART.
I'D BE JENKINS RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA ACE -- CONTRIBUTOR.
OF STRIP.
IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU -- WELL CHAIRMAN STONE --
SORRY ABOUT THAT -- SURE SAY BUT
STRONG SUPPORT -- WHOLE -- KERA --
THERE'S A FEW OTHERS BUT ANYWAY.
HOUSING AND OTHER THINGS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ISRAEL UP IS THE ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA'S FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT AND STRONG SUPPORT
FOURTEEN ONE THANK YOU.
WHAT A CLONE WITH ACE AND STRONG
SUPPORT -- CAL PILOT COURAGE
CAMPAIGN AND STRONG SUPPORT.
YES WILLIAM CASEY WITH ACE AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ON YES MONO WITH ACE IN OAKLAND
DAVID SHARPLES WITH ACE IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
AM SURE WITH S. BASED IN LOS
ANGELES THE RENT IS TOO HIGH
STRUNG SUPPORT.
CASE YOU DON'T KNOW.
HI CHRISTINA LIVINGSTON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ACE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO BECAUSE ONE TO THE
BILL IN SONG STRONG SUPPORT.
SHE'S A STRONG SUPPORTER.
JANUARY ALI UP PHELPS OAKLAND A
STRONG SUPPORT.
ROBERT E. GEARY -- TENANT IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY MEMBER OF
PACKED PICO AND SENT -- SICK AT
HEART COMMUNITY SERVICES IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI ANA GARCIA ACE OAKLAND VERY
HI EVERYONE CHRISTIAN A LOT
ATTENDANT FROM SAN JOSE PARTICLE
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS PIERRE CRAWL
JEFF I'M WITH SEGMENT A TENANT'S
UNION AND ALSO FAITH IN THE
VALLEY I'VE MOVED AROUND BETWEEN
STOCK IS THAT WHEN A LOT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
SOFIA HOME GRANITE WITH ACE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
CELIA RINGS FROM WITH ACE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SING DONE NICELY DONE
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
COULD YOU.
CLEAR THE TABLES FOR THE
OPPOSITION PLACE THANK YOU --
TAKE THREE WITH.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS -- IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OPPOSES AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE WHICH
PROHIBITS A RENTAL PROPERTY
UNDER FROM TERMINATING A LEASE
WITHOUT JUST CAUSE.
HOWEVER BASED ON CONVERSATIONS
HE OURS HAD WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE SPONSORS AND
STAFF SEE OUR WILL BE DISCUSSING
MAYBE FOURTEEN EIGHTY WANTED ITS
UPCOMING BUSINESS MEETINGS LATER
THIS WEEK.
DURING THIS MEETING C. R. WILL
EVALUATE THE BILL AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INPUT ON THE MEASURE.
SEE OUR LOOKS FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND THE LEGISLATURES OF
HOLES IT EXPLORES VARIOUS PUBLIC
POLICY OPTIONS THAT SEEK TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TEXAS WITH.
BUT CHECK -- TWENTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
MASS SPLIT MY TIME WITH MY IN
HOUSE COUNSEL TO GIVE A
PERSPECTIVE A MECHANICS MY TIME
FOR THAT OKAY UP IT'S NOT YOUR
TIME I'LL START.
MY TIME RIGHT -- BUT ALL RIGHT I
WILL I WILL DO THAT IN THIS CASE --
YOU ABOUT A MINUTE HALF CATCH.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY SAYING
WE'RE NOT HERE TO DEFEND BAD
ACTING OWNERS AND THEIR ACTIONS --
OUT ALSO BEGIN BY SAYING THAT
DISCRIMINATORY AND RESULTS WERE
AFFECTIONS ARE ILLEGAL.
UNDER CURRENT LAW TODAY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY WE FEAR THAT
THIS BILL WOULD NOT PROVIDE THE
PERFECT -- PROTECTIONS AS
INTENDED -- AN EFFECT OF SOMEONE
JUST BECAUSE POLICIES COULD BE.
COULD BE INCREASED RENTS NOW I'M
NOT SAYING THAT'S ACTION IS
RIGHT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT JUST BECAUSE
POLICIES STARTED RECTAL
JURISDICTIONS AS A WAY TO ENSURE
OWNERS WILL NOT.
GET AROUND LOCAL RENTAL WALLS.
ADDITIONALLY IN PROPERTIES SUBS
JUST BECAUSE OWNERS STRUGGLE TO
REMOVE BAD ACTING TENETS SELLING
DRUGS ON THE PRINCE'S.
OWNERS MUST RELY ON THIRD PARTY
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN COURT
AND NEIGHBORING TENNIS OFFICE DO
NOT WANT TO PUT THEMSELVES IN
THAT SITUATION.
WELL TODAY IN ORDER TO SERVE A
THIRTY OR SIXTY DAY NOTICE TO
TERMINATE THIS BAD ACTING TENET.
UNDER AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE ON
THIS WILL NOT BE AND WOULD BE
UNABLE TO DO SO UNLESS NEIGHBORS
ARE WILLING TO TEST BY WHICH
MOST TENNIS WILL NOT AND WITH
THAT I'LL TURN OVER.
TO GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NOW UNDER GREAT WALL I'M
AN ATTORNEY WITH C. EIGHT BEFORE
JOINING CA I WAS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE.
SPECIALIZING IN LANDLORD TENANT
LAW I HAD TONS OF CASES WHERE
THERE WAS A LOT OF ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY ON THE PROPERTY AND
OWNERS ARE UNABLE TO MEET THE
BURDEN OF PROOF TO PREVAIL IN A
JUST CAUSE LAWSUIT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO RELY ON THIRD WHITE.
PARTY WITNESSES THESE ARE THE
WITNESSES THAT ARE THE GOOD
TENANTS ON THE PROPERTY GOOD
TENANTS ARE AFRAID AND DO NOT
WANT TO GET INVOLVED IN LAWSUITS.
PRESIDENTS MAY CALL THE POLICE
BUT DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
NUISANCE ON THE PROPERTY POLICE
OFTEN SAY THAT THIS IS A CIVIL
MATTER AND THAT THE LANDLORD
WILL NEED TO VIC THE TENET.
SO WITHOUT ACTUAL PROOF OR
WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY A
LAND OWNER PREVAILING IN IT JUST
BECAUSE LAWSUIT IS PRETTY SLIM
WITHOUT THE USE OF AN ATTORNEY
AND AN ATTORNEY WILL NOT FILE A
CASE WHERE.
THERE IS NO PROOF AND SO OWNERS
WILL BE ASKED TO WAIT AND BUILD
THEIR CASE AND CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THESE TYPES OF BAD TENANTS ON
THE PROPERTY.
LEADING GOOD TENANTS WILL
CONTINUE TO SUFFER WALL GOOD
TENANTS SOME OF THEM WHO CAN
AFFORD IT MAY VACATE OTHERS WILL
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO LIVE IN
UNSAFE COMMUNITIES.
A TYPICAL FICTION CASE ONCE IT'S
FILED TAKE SIXTY TO NINETY DAYS
AND THAT'S WHEN THERE ISN'T A
REQUEST FOR A JURY TRIAL THIS
COSTS A MOM AND POP OWNER.
SIX YOU KNOW FOR FIVE SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN FEES --
LANDLORDS ARE IN THE BUSINESS OF
THE VICTIM TENETS SO JUST THIS
JUST CAUSES AND PROVIDE.
TEXANS FOR THESE LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS BUT INCREASES THE COST
AND IT REDUCES THE SAFETY OF
THESE GOOD RESIDENTS ON THESE
PROPERTIES WILL BE FORCED TO
LIVE IN THESE UNSAFE COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RUN KINGSTON
REPRESENTING THE SAME THREE
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS.
EACH BE RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION -- OF CALIFORNIA
SOUTHERN CITIES AND ALSO ORANGE
COUNTY.
I'M TERMINATIONS ARE.
SOLELY BASED ON ONE ISSUE THAT
THIS BILL TURNS ON CONDUCT OF
THE TENANT.
CONDUCTIVITY TENANT.
YOU HAVE TO REMEDY SET LAW TODAY
YOU CAN EITHER PURSUE AN
INFECTION OR TERMINATION.
IF THE CONTACT IS BASED ON
COMPLAINTS BY OTHER TENANTS.
NO WAYS -- PLAYING A STEREO FOR
EXAMPLE VERY VERY LOUD
THREATENING BEHAVIOR
[inaudible]
THE WE WOULD THINK UNDER MISTER
BOTCHES BILL THAT THE EASY
REMEDY IS TO AFFECT IT'S NOT.
KNOW WHETHER TEN IT WILL APPEAR
IN COURT TO SUBSTANTIATE THE
CLAIM -- THAT THEY THAT THEY ARE
FACING AND HAVE TALKED -- TO
WITH THE PROPERTY OWNER NOBODY
ELSE SO WE ARE NOW PLACED IN A
QUANDARY WITH THIS BILL.
AND THE ISSUE THAT THIS BILL
TURNS ON IS.
HOW DO WE [inaudible]
I HAVE THAT TENANT MOVE ON THAT
IS CAUSING THE MASSIVE
DISTURBANCE OF OTHER TENANTS.
THE OVERALL QUESTION IS WHO IS
THIS BILL TRYING TO PROTECT
[inaudible]
THE OTHER.
OTHER ALL THE OTHER TENANTS THAT
ARE HAPPY WHERE THEY ARE BUT
THEY'RE HAVING ONE PROBLEM WITH --
ONE OF THE TENETS.
WAR WE PROTECTING THE TENET THAT
HAS.
TREMENDOUS BAD BEHAVIOR AND WE
CAN'T SUBSTANTIATE.
THE CLAIM.
AND THEN TO THE LAST WITNESS IF
WE CAN'T SUBSTANTIATE THE CLAIM
WE ARE IN PANDORA'S BOX AND THIS
BILL PUTS US IN THERE AND KEEPS
US.
IN THERE FOR GOOD -- AND WITH
THAT WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION OF
COURSE GOOD MORNING TERRY
MEMBERS KATE BELL CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION.
WE HAVE OVER TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND HALF MILLION FROM
THE STATE AND WE OPPOSE BECAUSE
OF THE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
CORRECT AS WELL THANK YOU.
JENNIFER TOWN HELL WITH ERIN
READING ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
STEVE CARLSON FOR THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES IN THE SANTA BARBARA
RENTAL PROPERTY ASSOCIATION OF
POST.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SINA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEEING NONE [inaudible]
MISTER GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SO -- LOOK THE REASON WHY I
CAN'T SUPPORT THIS BILL AT
THERE'S SEVERAL DIFFERENT
REASONS BUT I THINK THE MOST.
FUNDAMENTAL IS THAT I THINK IT
TURNS THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF
PRIVATE PROPERTY ON IT SAID AND
AND I'M I'M I BELIEVE
FUNDAMENTALLY -- THE PROTECTION
OF PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS IS
THE THING THAT THAT MAXIMIZES
THE BENEFITS TO SOCIETY -- NO
ONE MORE THAN THAN THAN AN OWNER
OF LAND HIS MADE THE INVESTMENT
IN THAT LAND.
IS MORE VESTED IN ENSURING THE
LONG TERM -- PRODUCTIVITY AND
BENEFITS.
BENEFITS OF THAT PROPERTY -- AND
I THINK HISTORY IS JUST SHOWING
THAT VERY CLEARLY -- AND WHAT
WE'RE STARTING TO DO WITH THESE
TYPES OF LAWS IS.
BEND IT MORE IN FAVOR OF NO NOW
THE TENET IS IS THE ONE THAT'S
IN CONTROL.
OF THE PROPERTY -- NOW.
OF COURSE THE TENANT WHO IS
LIVING IN A AN APARTMENT HAS A
VERY MUCH AN INTEREST -- IN THAT
PROPERTY -- BUT SO LONG AS THAT
TEN AND I THINK AGAIN THE THE
RECORD IS SEAN THIS VERY CLEARLY
AND SO LONG AS THAT TENANT.
IS PAYING RENT AND IS KEEPING UP
THAT PROPERTY AS IN KEEPING UP
THEIR OBLIGATIONS.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO PRIVATE
INTERESTS ANY VICTIM THAT PERSON.
WHATSOEVER BECAUSE THAT'S EXOTIC
ZACH LEE WHAT.
IS GONNA KEEP THAT PROPERTY
PRODUCTIVE AND BENEFICIAL FOR
THAT LANDLORD LONG TERM.
I DON'T SAY THIS IN A VACUUM.
I'M A TENANT.
I'M A TENANT FARMER.
AND WE HAVE FORMED THIS THE SAME
PROPERTY FOR A LANDLORD FOR
FORTY PLUS YEARS NOW -- WE
HAVEN'T BEEN KICKED OFF LINE I'M
SURE THERE'S OTHERS WHO COULD
OFFER MORE MONEY. FOR THAT
PROPERTY BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS WE'VE MADE THE
PROPERTY PRODUCTIVE AND LONG
TERM THAT LANDLORD IS SEEN THE
BENEFIT.
BUT THEY HAVE THE FULL RIGHT TO
DO SO IF OUR LEASE IS UP.
YOU KNOW THEY COULD MAKE THAT
DECISION TO GO HEY THIS IS MY
PRIVATE PROPERTY AND AND AND
ULTIMATELY.
THAT IS THE THING THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO LONG TERM
PRODUCTIVITY.
OF THAT AND AND I THINK THE SAME
THING IS IS IS CLEAR HERE.
HERE'S THE OTHER THING IT DOES
TO ME.
IS I THINK WITH THE MORE WE GO
DOWN THIS ROAD WITH THESE LAWS
IT ACTUALLY ENCOURAGES MORE.
SLUM LORD TYPE ACTIVITY.
WHO'S GOING TO COME IN AND MAKE
THE INVESTMENT ON A PROPERTY
THAT HAS BECOME DEBILITATED IT'S
FULL OF COCKROACHES THAT HAS.
IN UNINHABITABLE -- CONDITIONS
IF THEY WON'T THEN HAVE THE
RIGHT TO ACTUALLY UPGRADE THAT
PROPERTY.
DEATH TO DO ELECTIONS TO CLEAN
IT UP AND AND AND BRING YOU
BRING IT UP TO STANDARD AND THEN
WE OFFER IT TO PEOPLE.
REBEL WHO'S GONNA MAKE THAT IF
THEY CAN'T FULLY CONTROL.
THAT PRIVATE PROPERTY WHEN THEY
COME IN TO MAKE THE INVESTMENT.
TO MAKE IT BETTER -- YOU KNOW
AND I THINK THAT IS VERY OFTEN
THE CASES WE HAVE INVESTORS WERE
WILLING TO GO INTO -- PROPERTIES
THAT HAVE FALLEN INTO DISREPAIR.
MAKE THAT INVESTMENT WITH ALL
THE RULES AND RESTRICTIONS THAT
WE ARE NOW PUTTING ON LANDLORDS.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO DO THAT.
THERE'S GONNA BE LESS INCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO DO SO AND TO ME
THAT MEANS THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE
MORE -- HIM THEY MIGHT BE RENT
CONTROLLED.
THEY MIGHT MAYBE WE IMPLEMENT
JUST BECAUSE BUT THEY'RE STILL
GONNA BE SLUMS AND THEY'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO BE BECAUSE NO
ONE'S GONNA MAKE THAT INVESTMENT
TO MAKE THEM BETTER -- SO I
WOULD THINK IT'S AN OVERALL BEST
INTERESTS LONG TERM OF OF
INCREASING THE QUALITY OF OUR
HOUSING. TO ENSURE THAT
LANDLORDS HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
WITH THEIR PROPERTY.
AS THEY SEE FIT -- YOU KNOW IT
OTHERWISE I THINK THERE'S GONNA
BE A DISINCENTIVE -- AND THEN I
THINK YOU KNOW FINALLY THE REAL
REASON THAT WE HAVE MANY OF
THESE PROBLEMS AS WE HAVE.
AS WE ALL KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS MANY TIMES BUT WE WE
DON'T REALLY DO MUCH ABOUT IT.
IS WE HAVE A HOUSING SUPPLY
PROBLEM.
THERE IS A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
HOUSING.
THERE'S NOT A LOT THERE'S NO
ROOM THERE'S NOT A LOT OF ROOM
TO GO ANYWHERE THERE'S NOT
COMPETITION.
SO WHEN THERE ARE SLAMMED RENT
CONTROLLED MAYBE THE RENT
CONTROLLED SLUMS WHERE ELSE YOU
GONNA GO.
RIGHT -- WHEN YOU GET EVICTED
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T SUPPLY AND
WE CONTINUE TO PUT LAWS IN PLACE
THE GREATEST ENEMY?
OF THE TENANTS TODAY IS MORE LAW.
IN MY OPINION ACTUALLY.
WE'VE WE'VE CREATED MORE MORE
LAWS THE BIGGEST ONE NICK DID
THAT KEEPS MANY PROJECTS --
MOVING FOR THE SEQUEL WE ALL
KNOW THAT.
AND EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM KNOWS
THAT CALIFORNIA BARMAN EQUALITY
ACT STOPS GOOD PROJECTS FROM
GOING FORWARD AND ALL OF OUR
URBAN AREAS -- NIMBY ISM.
STOPS GOOD PROJECTS FROM GOING
FORWARD IN ALL THESE AREAS AND
THEY USE THE LAW.
DIFFERENT LAWS ARE PUT IN PLACE
THE ABUSE IT. TO STOP THOSE
PROJECTS FROM GOING AND SO WE
DON'T GET THE LOW INCOME.
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THAT WE COULD GET IN MANY AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BOUNCING
BODY CHANGING SEQUEL.
EXCEPT FOR A FEW PEOPLE.
AND MY AND THE ONLY TIMES THAT
WE DO DO IT SEEMS TO BE FOR
STADIUMS AND ARENAS.
BUT WE DON'T WE'RE NOT REALLY
DOING THAT YOU KNOW -- TO ENSURE
THAT MORE HOUSING COMES ONLINE
THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM.
THAT IS WHY HOUSING AND RENTS
ARE SO HIGH.
AS WHY AT THE PRICE TO BUY YOUR
FIRST HOUSE IS SO HIGH.
IN THESE TYPES OF BILLS DON'T DO
ANYTHING TO GET AT THE HEART.
OF THAT ISSUE -- SO FOR ME I
THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
REAL FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM AND I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
ESTABLISHING A DISINCENTIVE IS
THAT LONG TERM.
IS GOING TO LEAD -- TO LESS
QUALITY HOUSING FOR ALL.
THIS IS TRUE.
LET ME START BY -- RESPOND TO A
FEW POINTS OUT THAT I WASN'T
GONNA RAISE BUT I THINK THE
SUGGESTION OF THAT IF YOU ARE A
GOOD TENANT THERE'S NO REASON TO
RAISE THE RENT.
HAS BEEN PROVEN WRONG.
HAS BEEN PROVEN WRONG MILLIONS
OF TIMES IN RECENT YEARS RENTS
HAVE BEEN RAISED.
ON THE GOOD PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS
IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY IN THE
PAST TEN YEARS ALONE THE MEDIAN
RENTING CALIFORNIA'S BEEN
INCREASED BY OVER A THIRD WHILE
MEDIAN INCOME HAS REMAINED FLAT.
AND AT THIS TIME OVER HALF OF
ALL RENTERS OVER 80% OF LOW
INCOME RENTERS THEIR RENT BURDEN
WHICH MEANS THAT THEY'RE PAYING
OVER A THIRD OF THEIR INCOME
TOWARDS RENT -- AT THIS TIME
THERE CALIFORNIA PAIN FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS MORE FOR HOUSING.
AND THEY CAN AFFORD IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT PROBLEM THAT I THINK --
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT THE MEALS
RESPONDED THE SUGGESTION THAT WE
CAN BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THIS.
IT'S THE ESTIMATE IS
CALIFORNIA'S THREE AND A HALF
MILLION UNITS BEHIND WHERE WE
NEED TO BE.
IN THE BUILDING INDUSTRY WILL
TELL YOU.
THAT IF WE ENTITLE THREE AND A
HALF MILLION UNITS OF HOUSING TO
DAY.
IT WILL TAKE US YEARS OF NOT
DECADES TO BUILD.
AND YET WE HAVE MILLIONS OF
TENANTS WHO ARE ONE TO RENT
INCREASE AWAY FROM BEING FORCED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES OF DECADES
BEING FORCED OUT ON THEIR
STREETS FORCED OUT OF OUR STATE.
LET ME SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT
THIS BILL -- THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE --
THAT TO WHILE WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THE CRISIS
WE'RE ALSO PROTECTING TENANTS --
THIS IS A BILL THAT WORKS HAND
IN HAND WITH AN ANTI RANK OUT
YOUR BILL THAT I HAVE PROPOSED
WHICH WOULD PREVENT RAIN
INCREASES ABOVE.
CPI PLUS 5% OR ESSENTIALLY 8% A
YEAR -- AND AS MR BONTA SAID
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BOTH OF THESE
BILLS MOVE FORWARD.
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE RANK OUTING
PROTECTIONS WITH NO JUST CAUSE
PROTECTIONS IF YOU CAN'T RAISE
RENTS ABOVE A CERTAIN LEVEL YOU
CONVICT THEM FOR ANY REASON BUT
IF THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
IF YOU CAN'T VIC SOMEONE FOR ANY
REASON BUT YOU CAN
CONSTRUCTIVELY EVICTED BY
DOUBLING THE RANT.
WE'RE BACK IN THE SAME PROBLEM.
I WANT TO SAY A FEW THINGS.
TO THE INDUSTRY AND I DO KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS.
WE HAVE HEARD THE INDUSTRY
POTENTIALLY REFERENCE THE OREGON
BILL THE CPI PLUS SEVEN BILLS A
MODEL TO LOOK AT I'LL JUST POINT
OUT THAT THAT IS A BILL THAT
INCLUDES JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS AND SO AGAIN.
MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN WORK OUR
WAY TO A SOLUTION IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND MONTHS ON THIS -- I
WOULD ALSO SUGGEST I'VE HEARD.
IT I'VE HEARD SOME OF THE THE
THE OPPOSITION ARGUMENTS TO WHY
THIS BILL SHOULDN'T MOVE FORWARD
AND AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS.
MY HOPE IS THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON
SPECIFIC CAUSES THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER CAN CONTINUING -- OR
ADDING IF THEY'RE AT FAULT
CAUSES OR NO FAULT CAUSES THAT
THIS BILL IS MISSING I THINK
THAT IS A WELCOME DISCUSSION --
I'VE HEARD THE SUGGESTION THAT
SOMEHOW CURRENT LAW DOESN'T
ALLOW US TO ADDRESS THE THE
STORY OF THE DRUG DEALING TENET.
AND THE CHALLENGES FACING THIRD
PARTY WITNESSES AS A FORMER
CRIMINAL PROSECUTOR I DO THINK
THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO GET OUT
THOSE CASES BUT I THINK THAT IS
A LEGITIMATE CONVERSATION.
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE -- BUT
TAKING A STEP BACK I DON'T THINK
THAT'S A REASON TO SUGGEST THAT
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE A JUST CAUSE
LAW IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AT ALL -- IS.
WE WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF SUCH
AN INTENSE CRISIS AND WE NEED
SOLUTIONS HERE -- WE'VE HAD MANY
CITIES THAT HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED JUST COST
PROTECTIONS IT HAS NOT HARMED
THE RENTAL MARKET IN THOSE
CITIES.
AND AND I DO THINK THIS IS A
VERY REASONABLE -- SET OF
POLICIES AGAIN TO PROTECT --
SEVENTEEN MILLION RENTERS WHO
ARE ALL AT RISK AT THIS TIME SO
WITH THAT.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS HOPE WE
CAN MOVE THIS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND WILL MAKE THE
MOTION THAT WE DO SO THANK YOU
IF YOU HAVE A MOTION IS THERE A
SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THIS CAR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF MISTER
BOND TO AND MR CHEW ON THESE
REALLY DIFFICULT ISSUES AND YOU
KNOW THE I LIVE AND I REPRESENT.
SAN JOSE -- OUR METRO AREA IS
THE MOST EXPENSIVE HOUSING
MARKET IN THE NATION
[inaudible]
AND MY DISTRICT INCLUDES NOT
ONLY SOME OF THE WEALTHIEST.
PORTIONS OF OF CALIFORNIA --
INCLUDING THE CAPITAL OF THE
DOWNTOWN OF SAN JOSE IT ALSO
INCLUDES THE LOWEST INCOME AND
POOR A CENSUS TRACTS OF SILICON
VALLEY AS WELL.
I WOULD NEVER REFERRED ANY THE
MUSLIMS I GO THERE OFTEN AND
THEY'LL GIVE ME A PLEASE NO
AUDIBLE RESPONSE AND THEY'RE
GREAT FAMILIES THAT LIVE THERE.
I WILL SAY THAT ON A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS IN FACT I WAS WHEN THE
INSTIGATORS LAWS ON CITY COUNCIL
THE RESPONSIBLE LANDLORD
IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE --
STARGAZER INITIATIVE BECAUSE WE
HAD A LOT OF MULTI FAMILY
APARTMENT BUILDINGS ARE ON THAT
BILL THE OWNERS WERE NOT UP
KEEPING THE PROPERTY AND THE
FAMILIES IS HARD WORKING
FAMILIES.
WERE SUBJECTED TO REALLY POOR
LIVING CONDITIONS WE LITERALLY
HAD TO TAKE -- PROSECUTORIAL
ACTION -- IN ORDER TO FORCE THEM
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF THEIR
PROPERTIES AND TO MAKE IT SAFER.
FOR THEIR TENANTS.
I MENTION THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THE BAD APPLE ARGUMENT IS
ALWAYS USED WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
JUST BECAUSE THE REALITY IS A
LOT OF GOOD APPLES ARE BEING
THROWN OUT.
BY EITHER -- OF ADDICTION
WITHOUT THE NEED FOR CAUSE OR
BUT WHAT WHAT AMOUNTS TO
ADDICTION BY THEIR DRAMATIC
INCREASE OF RENT.
WE'RE IN A CRISIS MAYBE NOT I'D
BE PART OF THE STATE SEES IT IN
THAT SAME WAY THAT I SEE IT
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WITH THE NUMBER OF CHRONIC
HOMELESS INCREASING WITH
FAMILIES THAT CONTACT OUR OFFICE
BECAUSE THEY'RE AT THE BRIDGE OF
BEING A VICTIM I CAN'T DO
ANYTHING TO STOP IT.
I'M NOT SAYING LOOK.
HI MY FAMILIES LIVE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I'VE BEEN A
RENTER.
HOMEOWNER AND UP -- MY AWARE WE
HAVE A SON IN POP OR SODA POP
LANDLORDS.
I GET IT I'M I I DON'T THINK
THAT ANYONE IS SAYING THAT THERE
SHOULD BE AN ABILITY FOR SOMEONE
TO PROFIT.
BUT TO SUGGEST SOMEHOW THAT
PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS SHOULD
BE ABOVE ALL THE ONLY THING THAT
WE SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT AND
THAT THEY'LL JUST TAKE CARE OF
THEIR OWN.
ALTHOUGH TAKE CARE THE BUT IT
WILL THAT WHAT WAS SAID WAS WELL
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT THE BEST
VALUE COMES OUT OF THAT PROPERTY
YEAH THEY'RE RIGHT.
THE BEST VALUE WILL COME OUT OF
THAT PROPERTY FOR THAT OWNER.
BUT WE HAVE A PUBLIC PLAN IN
FACT THIS COUNTRY IS FOUNDED.
BY GIVING RIGHTS ONLY TO WHITE
PROPERTY OWNERS.
AND SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW IS WE AS LEGISLATORS
OF A PUBLIC POLICY.
CRISIS ON OUR HANDS BECAUSE OF
THE OUT OF CONTROL PROPERTY
VALUES HOME CLASS RENTAL.
COSTS AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND I AND I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT EVEN THE
OPPOSITION.
OF UNDERSTANDS THAT I MEAN I
THINK I'VE TALKED TO MANY OF
THEM BUT CERTAINLY THE LOCAL
LEVEL THEY GET THAT WE'RE IN A
CRISIS MODE WE ALL AGREE WE NEED
TO BUILD MORE.
YOU COME TO SAN JOSE YOU'LL SEE
PLENTY OF BUILDING HAPPENING --
AND I'M GONNA KEEP BUILDING
AFFORDABLE MARKET RATE YOU NAME
IT ALWAYS ENCOURAGE THAT.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME -- FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING AND AND AT THE
END AND TOO MANY OF THEM ARE ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY ONE MEDICAL
EMERGENCY AWAY -- FROM BEING
HOMELESS AND FAR TOO MANY LIVE
IN THEIR CARS OR OR OR IN STABLE
RIGHT NOW.
AND SO I I THINK THAT THESE ARE
TOOLS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CRISIS.
AND I I THINK THAT THE THE FEARS --
HAVING AGAIN.
BEEN IN SITUATIONS WHERE WE'VE
HAD TENANTS THAT WERE TROUBLE
TENANTS AND YES IT TAKES SOME
EFFORT -- MEANT TO DEAL WITH
THOSE ISSUES BY THE END OF THE
DAY.
THE OBLIGATIONS IT SHOULD BE
SUCH THAT PEOPLE'S HOMES ARE
PROTECTED WHAT THAT THOUGH THE
WEATHER THE RENTING OR NOT
THAT'S THE HOME.
THIS IS NOT TALK MY REVEAL IT
WITH RENTING A LOCKER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THIS IS OUR
HOME.
AND WE HAVE TO BE VERY COGNIZANT
OF THAT AND I HAVE PRACTICED
THEM OR TENANT LAWS WELL.
AND UNDERSTAND HOW HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS WHEN TENANTS ARE TRYING.
TO HAVE SOME SENSE OF
EMPOWERMENT EVEN IF THEY HAVE
LAWS PROTECTING THEM THE RED THE
REALITY IS THAT -- THE DATA THAT
THE THE DECK IS STACKED AGAINST
THEM -- AND FOR THAT REASON I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THE SPONSOR.
I THINK JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS
A IT IT IT SADDENS ME TO QUITE
TENANTS AND PRODUCTIVITY ON THE
LANDS WHICH IS CLEARLY AN
AGRICULTURAL CONCEPT AND THE
ANALOGY IS ESSENTIALLY.
ASCRIBING TENDENCY TO HOW WE
TREAT CROPS ON THE LAND AND I
THINK THAT'S I'M GONNA STRUGGLE
WITH THAT WITH THAT ANALOGY AND
AND I'LL ALSO.
SAY THAT THE PROBLEM IS NOT
SEEKING A SEQUEL HAS BEEN A KIND
OF A WHIPPING BOY WAY FOR LAND
USE ISSUES BUT IF YOU LOOK
STATISTICALLY.
AT HOUSE EQUITIES USE IT IS
CLEARLY NOT THE PROBLEM THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM WE FACE RIGHT
NOW.
WITH GETTING MORE HOUSING BUILT.
IS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE FOR ALL THE COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT THE COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF STUDIES
ECONOMIC STUDIES THAT THAT ARE
THAT ARE SHOWING THIS RIGHT NOW.
THAT THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY IS
AND GIVEN THE TERRACE ON STEEL
ON THE TERRACE ON CONCRETE AND
THE LACK OF A WORK FORCE TO
PROVIDE. TO IT TO BE BUILDING
THOSE ARE GOING TO THE PLACES
THAT CAN AFFORD TO THE PROJECTS
HE CAN AFFORD TO PAY THE HIGHEST
COST OF CONSTRUCTION.
AND THAT'S THESE LARGE
COMMERCIAL PROJECTS WHICH BY THE
WAY ARE NOT CARING THEIR SHARE
OF PROPERTY TAX BURDEN. TO TO
REALLY FUN THE LEVEL OF SERVICES
AND THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
THE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CURRENT STUDIES THAT ARE SHOWING
WHAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
NOT HAPPEN WITH RESPECT TO
DEVELOPMENT.
DON'T EVEN MENTION THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT THAT SO
FAR DOWN THE THE LIST WHEN THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC PRESSURES THAT
ARE DRIVING THE KINDS OF
PROJECTS WHERE ALL OF THOSE
RESOURCES ARE GOING.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HOUSING SO
EVEN IF WE ARE.
PUSHING TO BUILD HOUSING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE ALL THOSE
RESOURCES GOING INTO THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION IN THE IN THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE A LOT OF THE
MEGA CAMPUSES THAT ARE HAPPENING
AND AND LARGE DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE GOING ON SO IN HE MEANTIME.
WHAT DO WE DO WITH THE TENDENCY
IS WHAT WE DO WITH THE EXISTING
HOUSING STOCK AND PROTECTING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE THAT'S WHAT
THIS CONVERSATION IS AN EVEN
THAT THE?
LANDLORD THAT I'VE TALKED TO IN
IT OUT OF MY DISTRICT AND IN
ENVIRONS CLOSE [inaudible]
REALLY.
TALK ABOUT THAT [inaudible]
THE CAPS ON RENSE RENT CONTROL
HOWEVER THEY GETS FRAMED AND
PROTECTION OF TENDENCIES AS
GOING HAND IN HAND AND THEY
OFTEN DON'T LIKE ONE OR THE
OTHER BUT THEY CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU CANNOT WE
CANNOT HAVE A SYSTEM OF
PROTECTING TENDENCIES UNLESS WE
HAVE.
THE BREADTH OF CONTROLS THAT ARE
THERE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES THAT'S WHAT MR TO CHOOSE
BILL DOES AND THAT'S WHAT MR
GRAYSON'S BILL IS TALKING ABOUT
IN THAT AND THAT'S GOING TO COME
UP NEXT.
SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
YOU BRING IN THIS FORD THIS IS A
CONVERSATION WE HAVE TO BE
HAVING IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PROTECTING THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN HOUSING NOW SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT LOSING HOUSING THAT
THEY'RE HAVING STABLE AND SECURE
HOUSING.
AS WE THEN TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE HOUSING
ACTUALLY BUILT WE HAVE PROBLEMS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL GETTING
PROJECTS ENTITLED WE'VE GOT
ZONING CHALLENGES THAT'S WHAT
THIS LEGISLATURE IS WORKING ON
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS.
EVEN IF THOSE HAPPEN.
THE HOUSING PROJECTS SPECIALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS JUST
REALLY CANNOT GET BUILT UNTIL
THE LABOR SUPPLY THE MATERIAL
SUPPLY TURNS AROUND AND THAT
SITUATION CHANGES OTHERWISE ALL
THAT IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO GO.
TO COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD BUT SINCE YOU'RE HERE
AND SINCE MR GRAYSON IS THERE
ALSO YOU TOO HAVE VERY SIMILAR
BILLS AND I'LL SAY THIS WHEN MR
GRACE COMES UP AS WELL.
I KNOW YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
BRINGING THEM TOGETHER AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT THAT HAPPENS FOR
THIS COMMITTEE.
I'M NOT MAKING THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE COMBINE
THE TWO BILLS BUT I KNOW THAT
THAT'S THE DIRECTION THAT THAT
I'M HOPING YOU'RE GOING TO BE
HEADING IN TO BRING THESE BILLS
TOGETHER SO THAT WHEN WE GET TO
THE FLOOR.
GETS TO THE OTHER HOUSE THAT
WE'RE MOVING A VEHICLE THAT
EVERYONE CAN FOCUS ON AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE TRY TO GET IT
PASSED WITHIN.
THE THE PURVIEW OF THE
LEGISLATURE SO WITH THAT THE
SPONSOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- ME
ADDRESS YOUR MOST RECENT POINT
FIRST AND SAY THAT MR GRACE AND
I ARE DEFINITELY TALKING WE HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR ONE BILL
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES WELL AFTER
COLLEGE TO VOTE ON WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE ANY CONFUSION OR
CONSTERNATION ABOUT THE TWO
BILLS AND SO WERE GETTING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
GET THERE FOR THIS COMMITTEE --
BUT WE HOPE TO GET THERE AND OUR
GOAL IS TO GET THERE BY THE TIME
WITH THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IT
SHOULD IT SHOULD OUR BILLS GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
I WANT TO JUST A COUPLE QUICK
ITEMS THAT WERE MADE IN
OPPOSITION AND ABBOTT AS I CLOSE
ONE IS.
IT WAS MENTIONED BY THE IN
OPPOSITION THAT DISCRIMINATION
AND RETALIATION ALREADY ILLEGAL --
THAT'S TRUE.
BUT IS ALSO A LOOPHOLE THAT YOU
COULD DRIVE A TRUCK THROUGH.
AND THAT'S THE FACT THAT THE
LANDLORD NEED NOT STATED REASON
FOR AFFECTION IT'S JUST A NOTICE
OF AFFECTION.
AND SO WHEN THAT HAPPENS IT CAN
BE FOR ANY REASON OR NO REASON
AT ALL IT COULD BE FOR AN
ARBITRARY REASON IT COULD BE FOR
DISCRIMINATORY REASON IT COULD
BE FOR RETALIATORY THAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
BECAUSE IT'S A BLACK BOX IT'S A
MYSTERY TO QUESTION MARK.
IT'S NOT BEEN ARTICULATED BY
HAVING THIS ADDED.
LEVEL OF DISCLOSURE OF
TRANSPARENCY OF OPENNESS ABOUT
WHAT THAT ARTICULATED REASON IS
FOR THE EVICTION WE PROVIDE MORE
PROTECTIONS -- TO OUR TENANTS
WHO ARE IN A STATE OF CRISIS
THROUGHOUT -- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO HEARD IN OPPOSITION THAT
INCREASE RENT IS IS THE POSSIBLE
OUTCOME OF THIS JUST BECAUSE
BILL.
THAT MAY BE.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHY WE NEED.
MR CHOOSE BILL THEY GO HAND IN
HAND JUST BECAUSE GOES HAND IN
HAND WITH AFTER RECOUNTING WE
NEED BOTH.
AND SO -- WHERE WHERE WHERE THAT
POTENTIAL IF JUST BECAUSE MOVED
ALONE BUT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
JUST BECAUSE ALONE BUT IT'S IT'S
COUPLE TO MR CHOOSE ANTI RENT
GOUGING BILL?
NOW DOES A LOT OF QUESTION ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WITH JUST BECAUSE
OF ACTIONS.
AS PROPOSED UNDER THIS BILL.
LANDLORDS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFECT TENANTS FOR JUSTIN FAIR
REASONS.
AND A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
WITNESSES AT TRIAL.
AND BEING IN FRONT OF A JUDGE IN
IN IN A TRIAL.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER THAT
TENANTS RARELY HAVE THE LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO GO TO A
CONTESTED TRIAL.
AND THAT THE VACATIONS ARE NOT
RESOLVED AT TRIAL.
MANY TENANTS WERE THEY RECEIVE
AN EVICTION NOTICE.
COMPLY AND VACATE.
IF A IF LITIGATION.
AND LEGAL ACTION MUST BE TAKEN
[inaudible]
THEN.
I IT'S USUALLY IT'S TO A
DETAINER ACTION.
AND BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
REPRESENTATION TENANTS 40% OF
THE TIME.
THIS IS RIGHT OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS -- LOSE THEIR
IT UNLAWFUL DETAINER CASE BY
DEFAULT.
SO YOU DON'T DON'T IN A TRIAL
DON'T IN FRONT OF QUARTERS NORTH
WITNESS BEING ASKED TO TESTIFY --
WHEN A TENET DOESN'T?
VACATE AFTER RECEIVING AN
EVICTION NOTICE OR DOESN'T LOSE
UNLAWFUL DETAINER CASE BY --
DEFAULT OFTENTIMES THEY LOSE BY
MISS MOTION FOR SUMMARY JUDGMENT.
AND ONLY IN VERY FEW CASES DO WE
GO TO COURT FOR A CONTEST TO
TRIAL SO SO LET'S NOT.
USE -- THE EXCEPTION.
AND TURN THAT INTO THE BIGGEST
ARGUMENT AGAINST US BECAUSE
BECAUSE IT BECAUSE IT REALLY
HAPPENS AND FRANKLY NO IT WAS
SAID THAT THERE ARE.
TENANTS WITH QUOTE TREMENDOUS
BAD BEHAVIOR.
WHO WE CANNOT -- AFFECT IF IT'S
TREMENDOUS BAD BEHAVIOR.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SUBSTANTIATE THAT QUITE EASILY.
I IN YOUR IN YOUR FILINGS WITH
THE COURT OR CERTAINLY IN A
TRIAL.
SO.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE THIS
BILL IS NOT. TO TO PROTECT
TENANTS WHO THAT FROM THERE
THERE IS CAUSE FOR THEIR
ADDICTION -- WHEN IT'S FAIR AND
JUST?
TENNIS CAN BE AFFECTED.
WHEN IT'S NOT WHEN IT'S
ARBITRARY?
WHEN IT'S RETALIATE FOR WHEN
IT'S DISCRIMINATORY THEY OUGHT
NOT BE -- WE ALSO HAD AT SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT ABOUT PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHTS.
YOU KNOW THIS JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT.
ENOUGH FLIP THE POWER DYNAMIC
HERE AND AND MAKE TENANTS ALL
POWERFUL [inaudible]
IT.
DOESN'T EVEN COME CLOSE TO EVEN
IN THE SCALES.
THIS IS A MODICUM AFFAIR MODICUM
OF PROTECTION. FOR TENANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO ARE IN
A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
IT'S A POWER RELATIONSHIP THAT
VERY MUCH FAVORS LANDLORDS AND
WILL CONTINUE.
TO BUT IT PROVIDES A EIGHT A
LEVEL OF OF DECENT DIGNIFIED
PROTECTION. FOR TENANTS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND YOU
KNOW.
I APPRECIATE MY MY COLLEAGUE'S
COMMENTS ABOUT ABOUT -- HE
WRITES A YOU KNOW.
I I HAVE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND YOUR
APPROACH WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM.
I THINK SOME OF THAT THOUGH IS
IN MY VIEW IS IS IS.
A CONCEPT AND THEORY THAT'S NOT
PLAYING OUT ON THE GROUND WE WE
ONLY NEED LOOK AT THE OUTCOME SO
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS NOT WORKING -- AND
OUR JOB HERE IS TO PROVIDE A
PUBLIC POLICY THAT PROTECTS ALL
OF US -- NOT JUST PROPERTY
OWNERS NOT JUST LANDLORDS -- BUT
EVERYONE INCLUDING OUR TO OUR
TENANTS WHO ARE BEING HURT.
A LOT RIGHT NOW.
AND I WANT TO CLEAR BUT ONE ITEM
THERE WAS A POINT MADE THAT
BECAUSE OF JUST BECAUSE THE
LANDLORD WOULD BE ENCOURAGED TO
BE.
I THINK THE WORD WAS USED A SLUM
LORDS OR OR TO NOT UP KEEPER
MAINTAIN THEIR PROMISES. TO BE
CLEAR THAT OUT WE HAVE
ARTICULATED NO FALL JUST CAUSES
ONE OF IT IS UNSAFE HABITATION.
OR SUBSTANTIAL REMODEL.
SO LANDLORDS CAN EVICT OF AS A
NO FAULT JUST BECAUSE A TENANT
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT UPKEEP AND
MAINTENANCE.
OTHER PROPERTIES THAT'S THAT'S
NECESSARY.
SO YOU KNOW I WANT TO END BY
SAYING THIS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING TODAY ABOUT A
GARDEN VARIETY FINANCIAL
TRANSACTION -- WHEN I TALK ABOUT
WIDGETS WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
COMMODITIES?
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOMEONE'S
HOME.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THEIR
SHELTER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE PLACE
THEY PUT THEIR HEAD DOWN AT
NIGHT.
THE PLACE WHERE THEY FEEL SAFE.
WHETHER FAMILIES ARE SAFE WITH
THEIR KIDS ARE SAFE.
AND I BELIEVE WE OWE IT.
IN THE STATE OF CRISIS THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY.
AT AT A TIME WHEN SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ARE SCREAMING FOR
HELP THAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY'RE
SCARED.
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT HAVE AN
EVICTION NOTICE THE NEXT DAY
WHEN THEY'RE SCARED TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT -- UNMAINTAINED PART TO
THEIR PROPERTY BECAUSE THEY
THINK IT MIGHT BE TURNED TO AN
INFECTION NOTICE.
THAT WE PROVIDE THEM A LITTLE
SUPPORT.
AND THIS JUST BECAUSE BILL IS
THAT IT PROVIDES A MODICUM OF
SUPPORT.
AN ADDED LEVEL OF PROTECTION. TO
HELP WITH THIS TIME OF CRISIS
FOR A SEVENTEEN MILLION TENANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYEBALLS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
BY STONE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHU.
CHU I GONZALEZ HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CHOLERA.
CALLER I. KYLIE MAIN SHINE.
OVER MULTI.
OVER **** NO PEACHY NORRIS
[inaudible]
RACE.
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
WE NEED A FEW MORE VOTES ON THAT
SO WE'LL PLACE IT ON CALL.
AND TAKE IT UP BUT WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS HERE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU COLLEAGUE THANK
YOU STAFF THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN AV SIXTY NINETY
SEVEN MISTER GRACE.
AND AS HE COMES UP I WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS COMMITTEE
OFTEN HAS THE BENEFIT.
OF HAVING INTERNS WHO ARE LAW
STUDENTS HELPING US OUT.
AND IT'S NOT SOMEONE IN FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU DON'T
ALWAYS SEE THE RESULT BECAUSE
YOU SEE COMMITTEE STAFF.
AS HAVING WRITTEN IN THE
ANALYSES.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO POINT OUT IS
OFTEN TIMES WE HAVE INTERNS THEY
PROVIDE A INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
VALUE.
AND AND GIVE US THE ABILITY TO
DO MORE RESEARCH AND MORE WORK
ON THE THE ANALYSES THAT WE DO
SO I WANT TO POINT OUT CHANTELLE
JOHNSON.
WHO'S SORT OF HIDING IN THE
CORNER HERE WHO IS BEN A AND
THEN TURNED ON THIS COMMITTEE
FOR THE LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS
AND TODAY IS HER LAST DAY.
COMMITTEE WANT TO SAY OFFICIALLY
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
AND THE TIME THAT YOU'VE PUT IN
YOU'VE MADE THIS COMMITTEE.
BETTER YOU HAVE HELPED US
ANALYZE BILLS AND MOVE US
THROUGH THE PROCESS I JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTS MR GRAYSON
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTY NINETY SEVEN FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE GOOD WORK ON THIS
BILL AND LET YOU KNOW THAT I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AS AUTHOR AUTHORS AMENDMENTS I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
FOR SHARING HIS STORY AND SO
ELOQUENTLY AND ABLY.
SHARING HIS PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
ISSUE.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT THE LONG TERM MULTI
DIMENSIONAL NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THAT ANY VICTIM HAS
ON RENTER'S ESPECIALLY MOTHERS
AND THEIR CHILDREN.
I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT WHAT I
HAVE HEARD.
IN MY COMMUNITY AND WHY I FEEL
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE MORAL
IMPERATIVE TO ADDRESS JUST CAUSE
INFECTION.
I BECAME INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE
THROUGH A FAMILY IN CONCORD.
THEY CAME TO ME TO ASK WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO WHEN THEY WERE GIVEN A
NOTICE TO VACATE THEIR PROPERTY
WITHOUT CAUSE.
THIS FAMILY INCLUDED SENIORS AND
A MEMBER ON LONG TERM DISABILITY.
THEIR APARTMENT WAS CLEAN AND
WELL KEPT THEY PAID THE RENT ON
TIME THEY WERE GOOD TENANTS.
THEY ASKED ME WHAT THEY SHOULD
DO SHOULD THEY STAY IN THE UNIT
AND MAKE THE LAMB OR GO THROUGH
THE FORMALLY FICTION PROCESS.
AND I TOLD THEM THE RIGHT THING
TO DO WAS TO SIMPLY COMPLY WITH
THE LAW.
BUT I SAW THE FEAR THE
UNCERTAINTY AFFECTING THIS
FAMILY THEY DIDN'T KNOW IF THEY
COULD AFFORD TO STAY IN THE SAME
COMMUNITY THE COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY WORKED WHERE THEIR KIDS
WENT TO SCHOOL.
WHERE THEY WENT TO CHURCH?
I REALIZE THAT IT WASN'T THIS
FAMILY WHO SHOULD BE ASKING WHAT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO WAS BUT
RATHER US.
AS THEIR ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES.
AND THAT IS WHY I DECIDED TO
CARRY THIS BILL BECAUSE THE HARM
CAUSED BY THE VISION IS SO GREAT.
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
A COMPELLING INTEREST TO
INTERVENE.
THE REQUIREMENT TO STATE OF
BECAUSE IN AN ADDICTION NOTICE
GUARANTEES TENETS DUE PROCESS OF
LAW THAT GUARDS AGAINST
ARBITRARY RETALIATORY AND
DISCRIMINATORY EVICTIONS.
WHAT IT IS ILLEGAL FOR A
LANDLORD TO EVICT SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY ARE A MEMBER OF A
PROTECTED CLASS?
A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
BECAUSE THE FILE HABIT THE HABIT
OF THAT -- ABILITY -- COMPLAINT.
IT IS LEGAL TO EVICT THEM FOR NO
CAUSE AT ALL.
IT IS EASY TO IMAGINE A
SITUATION IN WHICH A LANDLORD
ACTING IN BAD FAITH COULD USE
THIS LOOPHOLE TO MASK THE
INTENTION BEHIND A TRULY ILLEGAL
EVICTION.
A B. SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
SIMPLY REQUIRED THAT A LANDLORD
LISTED BECAUSE IN THEIR WRITTEN
NOTICE TO TERMINATE A TENANCY.
PROVIDE TENANTS WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE ANY
CORRECTABLE LEAST VIOLATIONS.
AND GIVE THEM NOTICE OF THEIR
RIGHTS IN THEIR LEASE DOCUMENT.
RECOGNIZING THAT A HEALTHY
RENTAL MARKET BENEFITS TEN IT'S
AN APARTMENT OWNERS ALIKE THIS
BILL ALSO INCLUDES SEVERAL
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THAT THE
POLICY DOES NOT PLACE AN UNDUE
BURDEN ON LANDLORDS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE REQUIREMENT
TO LIST THE COST IN ANY
TERMINATION NOTICE WILL NOT
BECOME OPERATIVE UNTIL A TENET
HAS OCCUPIED A RENTAL UNIT FOR
AT LEAST TEN MONTHS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT LANDLORD
SOMETIMES HAVE TO TAKE A CHANCE
ON A TENANT THIS PROVISION WILL
GIVE THEM A SIGNIFICANT PERIOD
OF TIME TO EVALUATE NEW TENANTS.
IF THE TENANT DOES NOT LIVE UP
TO THE LANDLORDS EXPECTATION FOR
ANY REASON DURING THIS TIME THEY
CAN BE SERVED A NOTICE TO VACATE
WITHOUT A CAUSE.
JUST LIKE UNDER EXISTING LAW.
THIS MEANS THAT THE RENTERS
SUBJECT TO THE JUST CAUSE
PROVISIONS WILL NOT BE SHORT
TERM UNKNOWN ENTITIES.
THESE ARE TENANTS WHO HAVE
ESTABLISHED THEIR HOMES WHO HAVE
PAID RENT AND PLAY BY THE RULES
FOR A LONG TIME.
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY ARISE IN WHICH
A LANDLORD NEEDS TO PULL A UNIT
OFF THE RENTAL MARKET.
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR A LANDLORD
TO REMOVE A TEN IN A NUMBER OF
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING ORDER
INTENT TO OCCUPY THE PROPERTY
WITHDRAWAL FROM PROPERTY FROM
THE RENTAL MARKET I'D SAVE
HABITATION OR INTENT TO DEMOLISH
OR TO SUBSTANTIALLY REMODEL.
THE PROPERTY FINALLY IN ORDER TO
RENT COMPASS OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT WE HAVE NOT FORCING THE
BILL WILL ALLOW FOR A LANDLORD
TO TERMINATE A TENDENCY.
IN OTHER NO FAULT CIRCUMSTANCES
AS LONG AS THEY ARTICULATE A
CAUSE AND PROVIDE COMPENSATION
TO THE TENANT IN THE FORM OF
RELOCATION ASSISTANCE.
AB SIXTY NINETY SEVEN INSURERS
THAT TENANTS ARE ARE PROVIDED
DUE PROCESS GUARDS AGAINST
RETALIATORY AND DISCRIMINATORY
EVICTIONS THAT HAVE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS ON FAMILIES CHILDREN.
AND THE MILLIONS OF THE FAMILIES
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WHO DO
RENT THEY DESERVE THE CERTAINTY
AND STABILITY THAT WITH THAT WE
WOULD EXPECT THEM TO FIND IN ANY
HOME.
AB SIXTY NINETY SEVEN IS A
BALANCED APPROACH TO THIS
CRITICAL TENANT PROTECTION ISSUE
AND TODAY MY WITNESS IS --
DENISE PINKSTON FROM DMG
PARTNERS.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S DENISE
PINKSTON I'M WITH TI NG PARTNERS
WE ARE A FULL SERVICE REAL
ESTATE DEVELOPMENT COMPANY IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA WE
FOCUS ON URBAN INFILL PROJECTS
SO YES I AM A BUILDER OF HOUSING.
AM I ALSO SERVE CURRENTLY ON THE
OAKLAND CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
BOARD AND I HAVE BEEN THE CHAIR
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL HOUSING
COMMITTEE.
IN MY MY MY COMPANY AND A NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE BUSINESS
AND DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY ARE
INCREASINGLY SEEING THAT IS
ESSENTIAL IN HOUSING POLICY FOR
US TO COLLECTIVELY DISPENSE.
WITH FINGER POINTING AND
ACCUSATIONS AND TO FIND A PLACE
TO COME TOGETHER AND SUPPORT A
HOUSING PACKAGE THAT ADDRESSES
PRODUCTION OF NEW HOUSING.
AND THE PRESERVATION AND
PROTECTION OF EXISTING TENANTS
AN EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
COME TO THAT IN A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I SERVED ON A TWO
YEAR PAINFUL COMMITTEE IN THE
BAY AREA THE COMMITTEE TO HOUSE
THE BAY AREA.
WHERE WE WE MADE COMPROMISES ON
TO GREET THE THINGS THAT WE
DIDN'T LOVE BUT WE CAN LIVE WITH?
AND SO DID TENANT ADVOCATES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND PLANNERS.
THIS BILL EXACTLY REPRESENTS THE
KIND OF AGREEMENT THAT
REASONABLE PEOPLE WHO WERE
WILLING TO LAY DOWN THEIR POLICY
SWORDS AND FIND A NEW WAY
FORWARD.
CAN COME TOGETHER ON AND A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SUPPORTED THIS BILL IF AMENDED --
SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF A PACKAGE THAT
PROVIDES PROTECTION TO RENTERS
WHILE ALLOWING BUSINESS OWNERS
LIKE MYSELF TO OPERATE
SUCCESSFULLY.
IT IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT MANY
CALIFORNIA CITIES HAVE THIS THE
STATE OF NEW JERSEY HAS HAD A
SIMILAR JUST CAUSE OF ACTION
REQUIREMENT FOR DECADES.
AND THE KINDS OF THINGS YOU
WORRY ABOUT IN THE NEW POLICY IN
A BIGGER ECONOMY LIKE CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN VETTED IN CALIFORNIA
IN NEW JERSEY AND MOST RECENTLY
IN OREGON.
JUST BECAUSE A FICTION STANDARDS
CAN EXIST HOUSING MARKETS CAN
WORK WELL LANDLORDS CAN DO THEIR
BUSINESS IN A REASONABLE WAY IF
THEY'RE WELL CRAFTED.
THIS BILL IS WELL CRAFTED TO
ENSURE THAT JUST BECAUSE POLICY
DOES NOT PLACE AN UNDUE BURDEN
ON PROPERTY OWNERS.
IT GIVES TIME TO VET THE TENANT
WHICH IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
THIS BILL THAT CURRENTLY IS NOT
REFLECTED AS MUCH IN THE BOND TO
BILL -- IN THIS CASE IT'S TEN
MONTHS TO VET TENANTS THAT COULD
HAVE POTENTIALLY POSE A DANGER
OR A HOUSE OR TO OTHER TENANTS
IN THE BUILDING.
IT ALLOWS CUSTOMARY JUST BECAUSE
STANDARDS LIKE OWNER MOVE IN AND
THINGS THAT ALLOW ONE OWNER TO
CONDUCT THEIR BUSINESS -- AND IT
PROVIDES RELOCATION ASSISTANCE
WHEN A TENANT IS AFFECTED FOR NO
FAULT FOR AN OWNER BUSINESS
PURPOSE -- AT WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED OUR COMPANY IS
RECOMMENDED THAT THAT RELOCATION
ASSISTANCE BE CAPPED.
AND AS AN EXAMPLE THE RECENT
OREGON LAW WHICH DOES INCLUDE
JUST BECAUSE OF ACTION
PROVISIONS CAPREOL CATION
ASSISTANCE AT ONE MONTH'S RENT
SO THAT THAT'S A CONVERSATION I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
ACKNOWLEDGE SHOULD CONTINUE.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS POLICIES TO
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
HOMES AT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
AS WELL AS POLICIES TO KEEP
PEOPLE HOUSED WHERE THEY ARE
TODAY SO IF THEY HIT AN
UNEXPECTED BUMP IN THE ROAD OF
LIFE WHICH WE ALL WILL.
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD WE DON'T LOSE
THE ROOF OVER OUR HEADS.
AB SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN IS A
CRITICAL PART OF THE HUMANE AND
ECONOMICALLY SUCCESSFUL HOUSING
POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS AND SUPPORTS.
HOLLY FOR MANY ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME AND
SUPPORT AS WELL AS HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY IS SPACE ALL KIND OF
ALLEY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SING THAT IS THEIR
OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED C. R.
OPPOSES AB SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN
WHICH PROHIBITS RENTAL PROPERTY
OWNER FROM TERMINATING A LEASE
WITHOUT JUST CAUSE.
AS NOTED EARLIER IN THE HEARING --
SP SIX SO EIGHT WAS ENACTED IN
OREGON EARLIER THIS YEAR -- THAT
LAW APPLIES JUST CAUSE TO
TENDENCIES AFTER TWELVE MONTHS.
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS SEE OURS
HAD WITH THE AUTHOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THE SPONSORS AND
STAFF SEE OUR WILL BE DISCUSSING
A B. SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN ITS
UPCOMING BUSINESS MEETINGS LATER
THIS WEEK.
DURING THESE MEETING C. R. WILL
EVALUATE THE BILL AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INPUT.
SEE OUR LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATORS A HOLE AS IT
EXPLORES VARIOUS PUBLIC POLICY
OPTIONS THAT SEEK TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
UP. TO THREE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE RUN KINGSTON
REPRESENTING FREE OF PARK RIDGE
APARTMENTS SOCIAIS SHINS ORANGE
COUNTY EAST BAY.
AND ORANGE COUNTY THE THE YES
THE ISSUE HERE IS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH MR GRACE AND A MOST
RECENTLY ON CRAFTING.
AMENDMENTS THAT MAKES SENSE --
THE BOTH OF THESE BILLS THAT --
YOU ARE CONSIDERING TODAY --
TRADE WIDE AND HOW WE HOW WE
APPROACH THIS SUBJECT MATTER
VERY VERY DELICATELY PROTECTING.
EXISTING TENANTS WHO HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH THAT.
ATTEN AT THAT IT IS COSTING
CONDUCT ISSUES WHAT THE SAME
TIME -- PROCEEDING IN AN
EFFECTIVE.
WAY TO DO THIS WE HAVE PRESENTED
SOME IDEAS TO MISTER GRACE AND
AS WE WILL DEAL WITH MISTER
BONTA AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
COME TOGETHER -- BEFORE THE TWO
MEASURES ARE CONSIDERED ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AT THIS PLACE. TWENTY BOY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION -- DON'T GO AD IS
AGAIN WE'RE NOT HERE.
TO DEFEND BAD ACTING --
LANDLORDS AND THEIR ACTIONS --
OWNERS REALLY DO STRUGGLE -- IN
SITUATIONS WHERE TENANTS ARE IT
IS ENGAGED IN ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
OR REPEATED NUISANCES AND THAT'S
WHY WE STRUGGLE WITH THIS BILL
IN AND JUST BECAUSE ALL SEASON
ALL THE THAT THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER THAN OPPOSITION
IF YOU JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION WITH KATE
BELL BEHALF THAT CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSED TO DO APPRECIATE THE
OPENNESS OF THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF TO GET A CONVERSATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STEVE CARLSON PART ASSOCIATION
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES AND BUT
BUT MY RENTAL PROPERTY
ASSOCIATION WE LOOK FOR
DIRECTING MR GRAY SINCE YOU CAN
FIND THE SWEET SPOT HERE.
JENNIFER CAN I HELP ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
RIGHT SCENERY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT -- WHY MAKE
CO AUTHOR OF THE BOND TO BILL I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE -- MR
GRAYSON'S PASSION AND COMMITMENT
FOR ADDRESSING THE PLIGHT OF
TENANTS IN THIS.
HOUSING CRISIS AND I THINK THIS
IS A PROPOSAL THAT IS VERY
REASONABLE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
YOUR PERSPECTIVE HAPPY TO MAKE
THE MOTION TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
AND AND VERY MUCH TO HOPE THAT.
THE TWO AUTHORS WILL BE ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER -- TO MOVE FORWARD --
A A A JOINT VEHICLE -- THAT WE
CAN ALL SUPPORT SO WITH THAT
HAVE BEEN WITH US FOR THANK YOU
WOULD GIVE THE MOST AND IS THERE
A SECOND.
THANK YOU MOTION AND A SECOND
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTSTHANK
YOU AND AGAIN MR GRACE AND SAM
COMMENTS ABOUT BRINGING THESE
BILLS TOGETHER I KNOW WERE THERE
VERY SIMILAR WHICH IS NOT SOME
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD OFTEN DO.
BUT EVEN THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
BEEN DOING THIS ABOUT TO BEEN
DOING THAT IS ABSOLUTELY FINE AT
THIS POINT SAID.
WE KNOW YOU'RE TARGETING BRING
THESE TOGETHER ON THE FLOOR TO
AVOID CONFUSION WHICH WOULD BE
FABULOUS.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU -- FOR YOUR OPENNESS TO BOTH
MR BARTER MR BOUGHT AND I
WORKING TOGETHER.
AND CONTINUING THESE BILLS
FORWARD IF MINE WOULD BE ABLE --
TO MOVE FORWARD I WANT TO THANK
THE THE DISCUSSION THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE AND IN SOME
INSTANCES A ROBUST DISCUSSION
BETWEEN THE TWO BILLS.
ENGINE PROTECTION IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE WITH MANY COMPETING
INTERESTS.
I'M WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ACCOUNT FOR ANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
I'VE MADE AN EFFORT TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO APPROVE THIS BILL
AS WELL AS OTHER MANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND I APPRECIATE
THE GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN
WILLING TO COMMON ENGAGE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION OF THIS BILL WOULD
GET OUT TODAY AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MEDICAL THE ROLE
PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHU. TWO I CONSOLIDATES HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
CALL RIGHT KYLIE MAIN SHINE OVER
MULTI.
AVRIL TINO PEACHY NORRIS RACE.
THREE THAT IS A FEW MORE VOTES
TO GET OUT OF THE COMMITTEE BUT
WHEN I WILL PUT THE BILL A CALL
AND WE'LL TAKE IT UP WHEN WE GET
MORE MA'AM THANK YOU DEAR.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT MR GABRIEL
ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE A B. O.
.
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHAT GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT A BE ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WHICH WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS TO ALLOW
AN INDIVIDUAL AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS. TO TEMPORARILY
RESIDE ON THEIR PROPERTY.
THE GENESIS OF THIS BILL IS
CONVERSATIONS WITH RESEARCHERS
AT UCSF WHO HAVE IDENTIFIED
TEMPORARY HOUSING WITH FAMILY OR
FRIENDS AS AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO
ALLOW STRUGGLING INDIVIDUALS TO
SECURE SHELTER.
SAVE RESOURCES REGROUP AND
SEARCH FOR MORE PERMANENT OPTION.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT SIX TO
FACILITATE THIS PROCESS BY
PROTECTING TENANTS WHO WISHED TO
HOUSE A FAMILY MEMBER OR FRIEND.
AND PROVIDES A LEGAL FRAMEWORK
THAT WILL INCENTIVIZE BOTH
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS TO ALLOW
PERSONS AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
TO OCCUPY A UNIT ON THEIR
PROPERTY FOR UP TO TWELVE MONTHS
WHICH MAY BE EXTENDED BY MUTUAL
AGREEMENT.
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BALANCES THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF THE INVOLVED
PARTIES SEEKING TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS AND
INCENTIVES TO LANDLORDS TENANTS
AND INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS.
IN SHORT WHILE IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANYONE TO DO ANYTHING IT
PROVIDES LEGAL PROTECTIONS AND A
FRAMEWORK THAT WILL ENABLE
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS.
WHO WISHED TO DO SOMETHING TO
PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
ADDRESSING OUR STATE'S
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS?
I'D ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE THE
RESULT OF EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH APARTMENT OWNERS AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION AND TEN
IN ADVERSITY ADVOCACY GROUPS.
AND A PARTICULAR LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR VERY HELPFUL FEEDBACK
AND SUGGESTIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS DR KELLY
NIGHT A RESEARCHER FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU TO BE CLEAR YOU'RE
TAKING THE AMENDMENT RIGHTS AS
OTHERS OF THEM YES SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
RIGHT THANK YOU A TEAR STONE AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS DR KELLY NIGHT AND
I'M AN ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
MEDICAL ANTHROPOLOGY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO.
I'M IN AN I. H. FUNDED
RESEARCHER WITH OVER TWO DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE RESEARCHING
HOMELESSNESS.
MY REMARKS TODAY REFLECT THE
WORK THAT MYSELF AND DOCTOR
MARGOT WHO SHALL PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AND LEADING RESEARCHER
ON HOMELESSNESS HAVE CONDUCTED
TOGETHER.
ON THE CAUSES AND SOLUTIONS
SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS IN
OLDER ADULTS.
IN OUR RESEARCH WE FOUND THAT
AMONG THE HOMELESS ADULTS AGED
FIFTY AND OLDER 29% HAD STAYED
OVERNIGHT WITH A FAMILY OR
FRIEND IN THE PRIOR SIX MONTHS.
AND 9% REPORTED MOVING IN WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WE WERE
SURPRISED TO LEARN HOW COMMON IT
WAS FOR PERSONS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO STAY WITH FAMILY
OR FRIENDS FOR A SHORT WHILE.
AND THEN RETURNED TO THE SHELTER
ON THE STREETS.
AND WE'VE BEEN CONDUCTING AN H.
FUNDED RESEARCHERS RESEARCH TO
INCREASE THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
BASED TO UNDERSTAND THIS ISSUE.
WE FOUND THAT FAMILIES AND CLOSE
FRIENDS ARE FOR MANY PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AN
ONGOING SOURCE OF SUPPORT BOTH
EMOTIONALLY AND MATERIALLY.
WHILE MANY FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
WILLING TO TAKE IN THEIR LOVED
ONES THEY FACE MANY BARRIERS IN
DOING SO. ONE COMMON REASON THAT
HOMELESS OLDER ADULTS DID NOT
STAY LONG TERM WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WAS DUE TO THE HOUSE
FAMILY MEMBERS FEAR OF VIOLATING
THEIR LEASE BY HAVING A NON
LEASEHOLDER STAY WITH THEM.
THIS FEAR OF CAUSING ADDICTION
CAME UP IN OUR INTERVIEWS WITH
HOMELESS ADULTS WOULD STAY WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS BUT THEN LEFT.
SUCH AS THIS OLDER MAN WHO
STAYED ONLY TEMPORARILY WITH HIS
SISTER.
HE SAID I DON'T STAY THERE WITH
MY SISTER OF COURSE NOT SHE
WOULD BE AFFECTED IF THEY LACK
OF THE LANDLORD KNEW SO
OFFICIALLY I DON'T STAY THERE
BECAUSE I'M NOT ON THE LEASE.
WE ALSO HEARD THIS FROM FAMILY
MEMBERS AS WELL WHO EXPRESSED
CONCERN THAT HOSTING A ABOUT
HOSTING A HOMELESS FAMILY MEMBER.
ONE WOMAN WE INTERVIEWED WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO OFFER HER BROTHER
A PLACE TO STAY AFTER HE HAD
WITNESSED A SHOOTING WHILE
LIVING ON THE STREET AND WAS
TRAUMATIZED.
BUT SHE FEARED THAT THE FOR
LANDLORD KNEW ABOUT HER BROTHER
STAY SHE WOULD LOSE HER HOUSING.
WE FOUND THAT STAYING WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS BOUGHT ALSO
BROUGHT BENEFITS BEYOND JUST
PROVIDING RESPITE.
FROM SHELTER OR THE STREETS FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS OFTEN PROVIDED
NEEDED ASSISTANCE SUCH AS
GETTING HELP TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS GETTING HELP
GETTING PAPERWORK IN ORDER
MANAGING MONEY AND HELP FIGHT
FINDING PERMANENT HOUSING.
HOMELESS ADULTS WHO STAYED WITH
FAMILY VIEW THIS OPTION A SAFER
AND MORE DIGNIFIED THAN STAYING
IN SHELTERS OR ON THE STREET BUT
THEY ALSO SOUGHT.
A LONG TERM PERMANENT HOUSING SO
THEY SAW IT AS AN EXIT AWAY TO
EXIT HOMELESSNESS QUICKLY
REGROUP SAVE THE RESOURCES AND
LOOK FOR A MORE PERMANENT OPTION.
WE BELIEVE THAT HOUSING WITH
FAMILY SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
BRIDGE HOUSING A LOWER COST WAY
TO HOUSE PEOPLE TEMPORARILY
RATHER THAN NECESSARILY A
PERMANENT SOLUTION.
BUT WITH THE ENORMOUS TOLL OF
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS.
THAT.
WE NEED TO BE SUPPORTING OUR
FAMILIES TO PROVIDE ONE SOLUTION
TO GETTING HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
INSIDE AND STABILIZED WHILE
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR SEEKING MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING.
AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT IN A WAY THAT HOLDS
FAMILIES AND YOUR FRIENDS
HARMLESS SO THEY DO NOT RISK
THEIR OWN EVICTION.
OR HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE THEIR OF
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO HELP A
LOVED ONE IS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
TONY WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SO SHE SHE'S WANTED
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US.
EARLY ON WE DON'T HAVE POSITION
YET BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO -- IT'S A
GREAT CONCEPT AND GREAT -- BILL
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE A STEVE
CARLSON APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES PRETTY MUCH
THE SAME THING AS MY COLLEAGUE
OF MR BUT WE WE'RE MR GABRIEL
HOMETOWN APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AFFORD TO CONTINUE TO WORK WE
TAKE THIS A GOOD IDEA.
THANK YOU.
IN ON US.
AND SUPPORT.
I THINK THAT IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AS CURRENTLY IMPRINTS
C. R. HADN'T OPPOSE LIST AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL -- BECAUSE
IT DIDN'T REQUIRE THE ATTENDANT
TO OBTAIN A WRITTEN LANDLORD
APPROVAL HOWEVER THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS -- THAT I BELIEVE ARE
CONTAINED IN THE COMMITTEE
PACKAGE TODAY -- ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND SINCERELY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
IS WAS COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US TO RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS WE ARE NOW NEUTRAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
TROLL OTHERWISE.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE OF IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SAYING THAT THIS GAME REALLY
MAKE CLOTHES YEAH I JUST THINK
THE COMMITTEE -- I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AGAIN FOR YOUR VERY HELPFUL --
SUGGESTIONS AND FEEDBACK I
THOUGHT THERE WERE SOME VERY
ELEGANT SUGGESTIONS IN THE
COMMITTEE -- ANALYSIS -- YOU
KNOW THIS THIS TO ME IS -- WHAT
I SEE AS AS WHAT I HOPE TO BE
THE BEST A PUP POLICY MAKING
WHICH IS EVIDENCE BASED PUBLIC
POLICY MAKING WE WENT -- AS I
SAID AND SAT WITH SOME
RESEARCHERS AT THE UC SYSTEM
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO.
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS -- THE
WHOLE SOLUTION OR EVEN THE MAJOR
SOLUTION BUT I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO TO BE
HELPFUL AND SO -- HOPE THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION THAT MOTION WOULD BE DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
DOWN BY STONE I GALLAGHER CHOW
[inaudible] TO GONZALEZ HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CHOLERA.
CALLER I. KYLIE MAIN SHINE OVER
NINETY OVER MULTI I PETRI NORRIS.
PITCHING NORTHSIDE RADIUS.
THAT STILL LEAVES A COUPLE OF
FOLKS WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MISS SMITH THIS WAS A SIDE OF
NUMBER THREE AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN OH SIX MORNING MORNING.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THE HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SERVING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HOME OWNERS AND
TENANTS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE ENHANCED
HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
WAS ADOPTED INTO TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SPECIFICALLY TO
COMBAT THE EFFECTS OF THE
MORTGAGE CRISIS.
THE ENHANCED PORTION OF THE
PROGRAM HAS ALLOWED THE COUNTY
TO EXPAND ITS SERVICES TO
INCLUDE COUNSELING SUPPORT TENET
RELOCATION SERVICES AND LOAN
MODIFICATION ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW LA COUNTY TO CONTINUE THE
GOOD WORK OF THE PROGRAM FOR
ANOTHER TEN YEARS.
WITH ME TODAY IS BRIAN STEIGER
WITH LA COUNTY THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
I'M GOOD MORNING OUR BRAINS TO
CORRECT SETTINGS LOTS AND JUST
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF THE
BILL.
ELEVEN OH SIX IT AB LEVEL SIX
WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE ON AN ENHANCED PORTION OF A
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THE HOMEOWNER
NOTIFICATION PROGRAM.
THIS UNIQUE PROGRAM HELPS
DISTRESSED HOMEOWNERS SAVE THEIR
HOMES FROM FORECLOSURE AND
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS FROM BECOMING
VICTIMS ARE FRAUDULENT -- FOR
CLOTURE CONSULTANTS ALTHOUGH THE
RATE OF FORECLOSURES HAS
SOMEWHAT LEVELS SINCE THE HEIGHT
OF A CULTURE CRISIS WHEN THIS
PROGRAM WAS IMPLEMENTED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
HOMEOWNERS EACH MONTH RECIPROCAL
TO NOTICES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
MANY OF THESE HOMEOWNERS BECOME
TARGETED BY FRAUDULENT FOR
CLOSURE CONSULTANTS WHO
ADVERTISE SOLUTIONS IN EXCHANGE
FOR COFFEE SERVICES THAT ARE
NEVER ACTUALLY RENDERED.
THIS INCLUDES FALSE CLAIMS OF
GUARANTEES THAT THE CONSULTANT
CONSTRUCTED FOR CLOSURE PROMISES
OF A NEW LOAN OR LOAN
MODIFICATION OR THAT AN INVESTOR
WILL BUY TWENTY THIRTY THE
PORTION OF THIS PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS THE CAMERA TO COLLECT A
SEVEN DOLLAR RECORDING FEE. FOUR
NOTICES OF DEFAULT AND USED
THOSE FEES TO ALERT HOMEOWNERS
AT THEIR HOME IS IN FOR CLOSURE
EXPLAINED THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE
LAW AND ENABLE THE COUNTY TO
PROVIDE FREE AND TRUSTED
SERVICES SUCH AS MORTGAGE
COUNSELING.
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS RECEIVED OVER THIRTY
SEVEN HUNDRED FRAUD COMPLAINTS
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM WHICH HAS
LED TO OVER ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN RESTITUTION TO
HOMEOWNERS.
WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
FOR OFFERING A BI LEVEL SIX TO
ALLOW LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT WORK
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
THING THAT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT MISS WITH YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE EITHER
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND THAT IS.
DO PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE I GALLAGHER CHOW.
TWO AND SOLACE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA COLOR I KYLIE
MAIN SHINE OVER AN OLDIE.
OVER NO T. I. PEACHY NORRIS
PETER NORTH I RACE.
WE NEED TO MORE VOTES SO THE
BILL A CALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MR DAILY ITEM
NUMBER NINE A. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
THIS BILL ELIMINATES THE FEE FOR
PETITIONING THE COURT TO SEAL
JUVENILE RECORD.
ALL CUT MY REMARKS SHORT AND
INTRODUCE ERIN RUBBER WHO'S HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FIRST ONENESS WITH HI
THANK YOU COMMITTEE.
SO AS A MATTER OF POLICY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
RECOGNIZE THE BENEFIT OF RECORD
CEILING IN THE REHABILITATION OF
YOUTH AND I'VE ALREADY AND HAS
ALREADY REMOVED MOST OF THE
BARRIERS TO SEALING A JUVENILE
RECORD.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR EXPANDS
ON THAT POLICY BY NOT CHARGING
APPLICANTS OF ANY AGE FEES TO
SEAL THEIR JUVENILE RECORD THERE
FOR BRINGING THE THIS PHONE
ABOUT POPULATION THAT WAS LEFT
OUT OF PREVIOUS LEGISLATION.
IN LINE WITH -- JUVENILES FOR
THESE REASONS AND MORE CJ'S
PROUD TO SPONSOR A B. THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR AND THINK A SEMI
MEMBER DAILY FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
WE WERE OF QUEST RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. THOUGH.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDS ALSO BE HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NONE BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THE DAILY HAVING DONE QUITE A
BIT OF RECORD CEILING BILLS
MYSELF THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THIS IS
VERY APPROPRIATE.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
COLOR -- PLEASE -- I'M SORRY YOU
MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I VOTE.
TO THANK YOU KNOW ABOUT THE YOU
KNOW MORE ABOUT THE BACKGROUND
ON THIS THAN MANY OTHERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR.
PEROT PLACE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER CHOW TO CONSULT IS
HOLDING.
HOLDEN I CALL RED.
COLOR I KYLIE MAIN SHINE OVER
MULTI.
WE'RE GONNA TI PETER NORRIS
[inaudible]
NORTH IRIS.
WE NEED TO MORE AS WE HAVE A
DEARTH OF MEMBERS BUT WE'LL TAKE
THIS UP I'LL PUT IN A CALL FOR
NOW THANK YOU FOR MAKING THIS
DAILY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND SINCE MR OVER MULTI WHICH
LIKE 2%
[inaudible]
CHECK.
PLEASE THANK MISTER MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE A CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
CURRENTLY PROTECTS PARTIES IT
ENTER INTO PREMARITAL AGREEMENTS
BY REQUIRING THAT SEVEN DAYS
ELAPSED BETWEEN WHEN THE
AGREEMENT IS PRESENTED AND WHEN
THE AGREEMENT IS SIGNED.
HOWEVER SOME DISPUTE HAS ARISEN
OVER WHAT OCCURS WHEN AN
AMENDMENT IS IS PREPARED FOR A
PREMARITAL AGREEMENT WHETHER OR
NOT THAT SEVEN DAYS STARTS FROM
THE ORIGINAL AGREEMENT OR WHEN
THE AMENDMENT WAS PRESENTED.
ALSO THERE HAS BEEN SOME
CONFUSION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THAT SEVEN DAY PERIOD APPLIES TO
PARTIES THAT ARE REPRESENTED
PARTIES THAT ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED OR BOTH.
SO THIS BILL IS A COMMON SENSE
CLARIFICATION TO EXISTING STATE
LAW.
IT WOULD CLARIFY THAT THE SEVEN
DAY PERIOD STARTS FROM ANY
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENT THAT IS
PRESENTED TO THE AGREEMENT THAT
WOULD CLARIFY THAT STATE LAW
PROTECTS BOTH REPRESENTED IN
UNDER REPRESENTED PARTIES.
ALSO WE ARE CLARIFYING THAT
THESE CHANGES ARE PERSPECTIVE IN
OTHER WORDS JUST MOVING FORWARD
NOT RETROSPECTIVE -- APPLYING.
TO PREMARITAL AGREEMENTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ASSIGNED A
NEGOTIATED.
MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THE BILL I THINK THE
CHANGES THAT YOU PROPOSED ARE --
MERITORIOUS AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITMENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU WITH YOUR MOTION IS
THERE A SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU FOR
SWEETNESS PLACE.
LAURIE DOYLE ABOVE THE CONVERSE
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATIONS WITH
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS MICHAEL IN
AS A LOCK -- WHO IS A?
DELEGATE FROM THE CONFERENCE WHO
WILL SPEAK TO IT IN DETAIL.
THANK YOU THAT'S GOING TO USE --
I'M A FAMILY LAW ATTORNEY.
WITH AN OFFICE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND WE'RE SEEKING.
CLARITY TO AVOID LITIGATION AND
TO AVOID CONFUSION AND SO
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT THE RULES
ARE AND THEY CAN FOLLOW THEM.
AND WE AGREE WITH THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK THAT THIS.
CLARIFIES THE AMBIGUITIES IN A
WAY THAT'S MOST PROTECTIVE FOR
THE PEOPLE.
BEING ASKED TO SIGN THE
AGREEMENT.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MR WILL SEE THIS IS A
GOOD BILL WHICH SHOULD SEEK.
CLARITY WHERE WE CAN APPRECIATE
THAT.
RIGHT CNN MISERABLE TO BE MAKE
CLOTHES THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL WHICH IS CLARIFIES EXISTING
STATE LAW IN A WAY THAT
MAXIMIZES PROTECTIONS WOULD
REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
COLOR -- PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER CHOW CHU.
CHU I GONZALES HOLDEN.
ALDEN I KALRA.
COVER I KYLIE MAIN SHINE OVER
MULTI BY VERNAL TI NORRIS RATES.
IT'S TWO MORE ABOUT THAT BELOW
CALL.
WHAT DO WE GET OUR MEMBERS BACK?
AS WE ARE WAITING FOR A COUPLE
MORE AUTHORS IF WE COULD GET
OTHERS APPEARS WE CAN FINISH
THIS IS ALL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA.
DO YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE I GALLAGHER CHOW. TWO TWO
I'D GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CHOLERA.
CALLER I. KYLIE.
MAIN SHINE.
OVER MULTI.
OVER MULTI I'VE BETWEEN NORRIS
RACE.
THAT THE CONSENT AGENDA IS ON
CALL AS WELL THANK YOU MISTER
TUCCI A NUMBER SEVEN A. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM HERE TO PRESENT.
SOME LEBEL.
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX DEALING WITH
EASE SCOOTERS AND OTHER SHARED
MOBILITY.
DEVICES.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION -- E.
SCOOTERS AND BIKES AS WE KNOW.
AND HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THEY COULD BE FUN AFFORDABLE AND
ECO FRIENDLY WAYS TO GET AROUND.
HOWEVER LIKE WITH ANY NEW
INNOVATIVE PRODUCT SERVICE WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S SAFE.
FOR BOTH USERS AND PEDESTRIANS --
WITH BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTIONS --
I WOULD LIKE -- TO START OFF BY --
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS -- THAT
THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE --
WORKED ON ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
AND I ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THAT WE HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS -- AND
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION -- LAST WEEK
IN THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE WE
REMOVE THE ARBITRATION PROVISION.
AND THEREBY REMOVE THIS BILL
FROM THE JOB KILLER LISTS OF THE
CAL CHAMBER -- WE ALSO HEARD --
THE CONCERNS.
RAISED BY MEMBERS ABOUT.
USER CONDUCT -- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NO PROVIDE A
LIABILITY FOR DRUNK A RECKLESS
WRITERS AND SO WE MADE THAT
CLARIFICATION-- WE ALSO MADE
AMENDMENTS OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THE LIABILITY
THE MINIMUM LIABILITY INSURANCE
ISSUE -- SO WE HAVE LOWERED THAT
AMOUNT -- AS A RESULT OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- THE
OPPOSITION AS A RESULT OF OF
THOSE -- ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
ADDRESSED -- WE THE CHAMBER AS I
INDICATED THEY'VE TAKEN OUT THE
JOB KILLER LIST -- THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IS SUPPORTING
AND CONCEPT.
AND WE ARE OPTIMISTIC THAT ARE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WILL --
MAKE THIS A GOOD BILL FOR
EVERYONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS LAWRENCE RUSSO AND I
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I AM HERE TODAY TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX I WAS IN SAN
DIEGO IN OCTOBER AFTER
COMPLETING A THREE HUNDRED MILE
BIKE RIDE FROM SANTA BARBARA IN
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION.
AFTER THE RIDE I DECIDED TO
REMAIN IN SAN DIEGO FOR A FEW
DAYS.
AND VISIT THE NAVAL BASES I AM A
RETIRED NAVAL VETERAN.
I WAS GOING TO TAKE THE TROLLEY
TO THE BASE.
BUT I LEARNED IT WAS QUITE A
DISTANCE TO WALK SO I DECIDED.
TO RENT TO SCOOTER.
I'D BEEN ON TO THE PREVIOUS DAY
SO I WASN'T.
I'M FAMILIAR WITH THE USE AND
THEY WERE ALL.
ROB -- THEY WERE ALL -- BIRD
SCOOTERS.
WHEN I WAS ON THE SCOOTER I
DECIDED THAT I I WAS DESCENDING
A HILL WHICH BECAME QUITE STURDY?
WHEN I APPLIED THE BRAKES THEY
FAILED?
IMMEDIATELY I ASK MYSELF WHAT
SHOULD I DO NOW -- WHAT THING
THAT CAME TO MIND WAS?
STARING INTO A DRIVEWAY.
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD IN ONE OF
THE NEIGHBORS YARDS AND HOPING I
CAN GO OVER THE RETAINING WALL
THE EDGE OF THEIR PROPERTY.
A SECOND THOUGHT WAS TO GO TO
THE BOTTOM AND TURNED SHARPLY UP
THE ROAD THAT SEEM TO BE IN
ASCENDING.
ONE I REMEMBER NOTHING AFTER
THAT -- FRIGHT BLACKED OUT AND
DIDN'T WAKE UP UNTIL I WAS IN
THE EMERGENCY ROOM IT UCSD --
AND I HAD A HELMET ON AND I HAVE
A HELMET ON DOCTOR WAS TALKING
TO ME AND AND DESCRIBING BYE.
BYE INJURIES [inaudible]
AND THEN ASKED ME.
IF I WAS WILLING TO LET THEM
BRING ME -- TO ARE.
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
TOO PAINFUL TO KNOWN TO HAVE ALL
MY WOUNDS CLEAN [inaudible]
KNEES ELBOWS BACKS OF BOTH HANDS.
SO I SAID OKAY.
IF YOU MUST.
WOULD YOU AGREE TO DONATE YOUR
ORGANS IF WE IF YOU DON'T COME
OUT OF IT AS THAT WAS A REALITY
CHECK IT SAID.
CERTAINLY BUT I HOPE I DO MAKE
IT MAKE IT FROM THE OPERATING
ROOM -- I ALSO HAD TO HAVE
STITCHES ON MY LEFT HANDED AND
MY RIGHT ELBOW.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY -- I I HAD A
HELMET ON SO -- I SURVIVED THE
INCIDENT I NOT SURE I WOULD HAVE
HAD I NOT HAD THE HELMET ON I
WAS IN THE HOSPITAL FOR TWO AND
A HALF DAYS AND STILL HAVE SOME
RECURRING -- DISCOMFORT IN IN MY
HANDS IN THE ELBOW.
AND SOME COGNITIVE ISSUES.
ESCHOOL NEWS MAY PROVIDE AN
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS.
BUT THEY NEED TO BE YOU WELL
MAINTAINS.
SO THAT THOSE THAT RIDE UPON
THEM.
CAN BE SAFE.
RIGHT NOW THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ANY RECOURSE AGAINST THESE
COMPANIES.
IMAGINE YOURSELF RENTING A CAR
ONLY TO FIND THAT.
THE BRAKES DIDN'T WORK WHEN YOU
WERE DESCENDING A HILL.
AND YOU HIT A WALL -- WORSE A
CHILD -- BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T
STOP THE VEHICLE.
YOU HAVE SOME RECOURSE AGAINST.
CAR RENTAL AGENCY OR THE CAR
MANUFACTURER.
BUT IT'S THE SCOOTER COMPANIES
DON'T SEEM LIABLE FOR ANYTHING
RIGHT NOW.
THAT HARDLY SEEMS FAIR.
THE STATE HAS AN OBLIGATION I
BELIEVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
MINIMUM SAFETY AND INSURANCE
PROTECTIONS ARE IN PLACE.
A B. TWELVE EIGHTY SIX DOES THIS
AND I RICHER SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS.
HELLO I'M CHRISTOPHER DOLAN FROM
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IS A PAST PRESIDENT
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
PROVIDING US THIS TIME TODAY.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT AND
TIMELY BILL.
JUST LIKE WE DEALT WITH A FEW
YEARS BACK WHEN WE WERE LOOKING
AT THE TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
CARRIERS WE HAVE HAD.
A CARPET BOMBING OF SCOOTERS ALL
OVER OUR COMMUNITIES -- BEFORE
ANY REGULATIONS OR ANY
PERMISSION ADVENT SAW.
AS A RESULT WE'RE SEEING A RISE
IN INJURIES THAT ARE HAPPENING
FROM THE SCOOTERS.
AS YOU JUST HEARD.
CERTAIN PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
SUCH AS THE INSURANCE MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
PROVIDING THESE SCOOTERS ARE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE SOME SOLID
FOUNDATION TO THEM AND CAN BE.
IN A POSITION TO PAY FOR ANY
HARMS THAT THEY CAUSE.
ADDITIONALLY IT PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR REGULATION BY
THE LOCAL CITIES AND GOVERNMENTS
AND AND REQUIRES THEM TO PUT
FORTH THESE REGULATIONS SO THAT
THERE IS SOME FORM.
OF REGULATION OVER THESE DEVICES
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE WILD WEST.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL AND I
KNOW ONE OF THE ONES IT'S MOST
CUT THAT'S CONTROVERSIAL.
IS THE RELEASE AND WAIVER
LANGUAGE.
AND I WANT. TO DISCUSS WITH THE
COMMITTEE WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
SO WITH SOME OF THESE PROVISIONS
THAT ARE IN THESE PROVIDERS
CLICKING ACCEPT AGREEMENTS
INCLUDE A ONE HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP.
ON ANY DAMAGES THAT ARE CAUSED
BY THE PROVIDERS -- NEGLIGENCE
FOR THE PROVISION OF THE FAULTY
DEVICE FAILURE TO MAINTAIN IT.
IN ANOTHER ASPECT IS THAT THEY
CHANGE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS TO REDUCE IT SO THAT
AN INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT HAVE ANY
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THEY NEED TO
FIND A LAWYER.
AND THE INVESTIGATING PROSECUTOR
CLAIM.
NOW THESE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
ALTERATIONS IN THE RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY ARE ON
AWARE OF BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW
CLICKING ACCEPT.
IS A WAY THAT PEOPLE ARE JUST
GETTING ACCESS WITHOUT FULLY
KNOWING WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
IN THE RELEASE IN WAIVER THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING.
SO WHAT WOULD A RELEASING WAIVER --
PROVIDE PROTECTION FROM FOR
THESE COMPANIES.
WELL BIRD HAS JUST CREATED ITS
OWN SCOOTER.
AND NOT ONLY IS IT A PUTTING A
SCOOTER ON THE STREET BUT IT IS
DESIGNED IN MANUFACTURING THE
SCOOTER.
A BIRD IS A COMPANY THAT IS THE
FASTEST COMPANY TO REACH A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR VALUATION.
IT'S REAL IT'S RAISED OVER NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
VENTURE CAPITAL FUNDS AND IS
VALUED CURRENTLY AT OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
SO THESE ARE NOT COMPANIES ARE
GONNA BE PUT OUT OF BUSINESS BY
COMMON SENSE REGULATION.
BUT IF THEY'RE SCOOTER IS PUT ON
THE ROAD AND AS WE'VE HEARD THE
BRAKES FAIL.
ARE THERE INSTANCES THAT WE'VE
SEEN OF THE STEERING COLUMN
COLLAPSING ON THE VEHICLES AND
EVEN BATTERY FIRES.
IF THIS THESE WAIVERS AND
ASSUMPTION OF RISK -- CLAUSES
ARE NOT REMOVED IN THOSE
COMPANIES WOULD BE COMPLETELY
IMMUNE FROM ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE DEVICES THAT THEY NOT
ONLY PUT ON THE STREET.
BUT THEY ARE DESIGNING AND
THEY'RE PRODUCING.
MOREOVER THESE RELEASES EXTEND
TO OTHER MANUFACTURERS.
SO WHEN SOMEONE TAKES ONE OF THE
SCOOTERS OUT THE RELEASE IN
WAIVER RELEASES IN WAVES THE
MANUFACTURE.
OF A SCOOTER IF IT'S NOT THE
PROVIDER IN AND THAT'S UNHEARD
OF THAT'S LIKE RENTING A CAR AND
PROVIDING A RELEASE AND WAIVER
TO FORD OR GM OR ANOTHER
CORPORATION IF THEY HAVE A CAR.
THAT HAS FAULTY BRAKES OR
CATCHES ON FIRE.
SO THESE ARE REALLY OVER BROAD
AND THEY PROVIDE A PROTECTION
NOT TO THE CONSUMER BUT A
PROTECTION THAT ONLY PROTECTS
THE COMPANIES.
THAT ARE MAKING CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNTS OF MONEY OFF OF THESE.
WHAT ELSE IS IMPORTANT?
WELL WE HAVE THE JAM ON THE
JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION TALKING ABOUT A
MARKET INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
INJURIES TO PEOPLE WHO ARE USING
THE SCOOTERS.
THEY'RE A BAND -- POLLS OF
EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIANS SUCH
AS IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT ARE
TALKING ABOUT HAVING TEN OF
THESE INJURIES COMING IN A WEEK.
SO IF WE PROVIDE IN THE M. UNITY
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT A RELEASE
AND WAIVER IS TO THESE
MANUFACTURERS.
THEN THEN WHO'S GOING TO PICK UP
THE BILL FOR THESE INJURIES.
MANY OF THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD A CAR.
IN SO THEY'RE RIDING A SCOOTER
AND MANY OF THEM ARE UNINSURED
SO WHO'S GOING TO PICK THAT UP
MEDIC COW THE TAXPAYERS.
IN THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING WHEN YOU HAVE
COMPANIES THAT ARE VALUED AT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE ENTIRETY.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE OPPOSITION
TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS IS AN
ACTIVITY AND LIKE MANY
ACTIVITIES THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION
OF THE RISK IN THE ACTIVITIES.
THOSE ACTIVITIES OR SKY DIVING
SKIING THIS IS NOT AN ACTIVITY.
THIS IS A A BUSINESS PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES FOR
WHICH THEY CHARGE.
IT AND THEY'RE TRYING TO SAY
THAT BECAUSE YOU CAN ENJOY IT.
YOU SHOULDN'T ASSUME THE RISK
BUT THAT THE PARALLEL OF THAT IS
RENTING A CAR THAT'S A
CONVERTIBLE IN BECAUSE IT CAN BE
FUN BECAUSE THE WIND BLOWS
THROUGH YOUR HAIR.
DID THEN THERE SHOULD BE AN
ASSUMPTION OF THE RISK FOR USING
THAT VEHICLE.
THE ASSUMPTION OF THE RISK IS IS
BAD POLICY.
IT BENEFITS AND PROVIDES
PROTECTION FOR ONLY ONE ENTITY
THE ENTITY WORTH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT HAS NO INCENTIVE
THEN TO REPAIR MAINTAIN OR MAKE
SURE THEIR PRODUCTS ARE SAFE FOR
THEIR INTENDED USERS.
SO I I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE YES ON THIS
AND APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
ATTENTION IS BEING GIVEN.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
YOU COME FOR GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLACE.
YEAH.
AFTER THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUBBER TO GO HERE ON
BEHALF OF LEAVE CALIFORNIA
CITIES -- WANT TO SAY THAT WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKING
IN THE LAST COMMITTEE PLUS THE
MOMENT THAT THE AUTHORS AG HAS
AGREED TO IN THIS COMMITTEE.
OF THE LEAGUE WILL MOVE TO A
FORMAL SUPPORT POSITION -- AND
IF THE AUTHOR WOULD CONSIDER IT --
WE WOULD ALSO BE LIKE TO ADDED
AS A CO SPONSOR POTENTIALLY AT
THE IF THE IF THE AUTHOR SO
PLEASE IS SO -- WITH THAT JUST
WANTED -- TO LET'S START A
POSITION FOR THE RECORD THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
DANIEL TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE SIR OPPOSITION.
ONE IS ON HIM.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COURT IN
JENSEN ON BEHALF OF TECH THAT --
FIRST ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR AND
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ADDRESSING
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS I'M VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE IN THE DIRECTION THAT
THIS BILL IS HEADING.
I'M JUST UP HERE TODAY -- TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE REMAINING
ISSUES -- WITH AND CONTINUING
OUR POSE POSITION -- ON THE
WAIVERS AND RELEASE AND THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WHICH
PROHIBITS WAIVERS AND RELEASE
AND AND USER AGREEMENTS FOR
SHARED.
MOBILITY DEVICES ARE REMAINING
CONCERN THE WAIVERS AND RELEASES
ARE STANDARD FEATURES --
DESIGNED TO PROTECT COMPANIES
FROM LIABILITY FOR INCIDENTS
BECAUSE THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN -- WE BELIEVE THE
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD STILL
APPLIES AND SO THIS IS SIMPLY A
SOMETHING THAT WE THAT IN THE
WAIVER SOME LIABILITY IS REALLY
AT MAKING SURE THE COMPANY IS
NOT LIABLE FOR SOMETHING THERE'S
COST OR NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN --
SO JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR THIS WOULD BE -- SINGLING
OUT SHARED MOBILITY HOW AMONG
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
LIMITATIONS ON THEIR FREEDOM OF
CONTRACT -- AND THEN ALSO JUST
TWO SMALL REMAINING CONCERNS I'M
IN THE DEFINITION OF SHARED
MOBILITY DEVICE -- RELATED TO
LANGUAGE IT SAYS VIA A DIGITAL
APPLICATION OR OTHER ELECTRONIC
OR DIGITAL PLATFORM THIS
PROVISION WOULD PROHIBIT ACCESS
TO THE PRODUCTS FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE A DIGITAL APPLICATION.
FOR EXAMPLE SUCH INSTANCES WERE
RENTALS ARE COMPLETED VIA PHONE
SUPPORT -- AND THEN JUST SO IT'S
SMALL WANT ANY INSURANCE PROBE --
PORTION OF THE BILL WITH THE
LANGUAGE OF LESS THAN AND WE'RE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A CONSISTENCY ACROSS
LOCALITIES IN THE INSURANCE
COVERAGE PROVISIONS BUT AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S POSITIVE
DIRECTION OF THIS BILL.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ERIN RYE BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
GREAT CAMPBELL ON BEHALF OF LIME
ALSO IN OPPOSITION BUT
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HOPE WE CAN BE IN
SUPPORT.
ALICIA PECK ON BEHALF OF BIRD
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR WE'RE CURRENTLY OPPOSE
BUT HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET TO A
PLACE THAT'S WORKABLE.
MY CRIME SCENE ON BEHALF OF UBER --
CURRENTLY OPPOSE THE BILL THAT
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THE AUTHOR'S DOING AND LOOK FOR
THE CONTINUING THOSE EFFORTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I THINK THAT'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
IS WITH US AND THEN I I AM NOT
ASKING QUESTION I KNOW THE
ANSWER TO I I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT PROVISIONS WE HAVE -- OR IF
WE HAVE PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE
THIS TYPE OF LIABILITY --
SUPPORT FOR A RIDE CHER
COMPANIES.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO PASS A BILL -- THAT WAS
SPONSORED BY AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT DNIA.
THAT REQUIRED THE TEA AND SEES
THAT WERE REFUSING TO OBTAIN
INSURANCE TO OBTAIN INSURANCE UP
TO A MILLION DOLLARS TO COVER.
ANY TYPE OF INCIDENTS CAUSED BY
THEIR DRIVERS INCLUDING UNDER
INSURED UNINSURED MOTORIST
COVERAGE.
CURRENTLY THE TORT SYSTEM THE
NEGLIGENCE SYSTEM IS WORKING AS
IT RELATES TO THESE TN SEASON
THERE ARE LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
CASES RELATING.
TO NEGLIGENT DRIVING AND TO ANY
TYPE OF FAULTY EQUIPMENT THE
DRIVER MAY HAVE SO THE
NEGLIGENCE SYSTEM IS WORKING AND
I'M.
WITH DUE RESPECT TO TECH NET.
IF THESE THIS BILL IS NOT PASSED
THE NEGLIGENCE SYSTEM IS KILLED
IT IS CUT OUT BY THE RELEASE AND
WAIVER.
IF THERE IS NO ABILITY TO CLAIM
NEGLIGENCE AGAINST THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE PROVIDERS WITH
THIS RELEASE AND WAIVER.
DID I ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
SOMEWHAT I DO REMEMBER THE BENNY
A BELL MY CONCERN IS THIS AND
I'LL JUST SAY THIS OVER I'M
DEFINITELY VOTING FOR THAT SOME.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BEEN MOVED.
MY MY CONCERN IS -- AS CITIES --
A LOT OF WHICH GANG UP ON ON
THESE PRODUCTS -- AND THESE ARE
THE LAST MILE KIND OF US
SOLUTIONS FOR A LOT OF AREAS AND%
WE'RE TRYING TO REDUCE CLIMATE
CHANGE I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE REGULATIONS IN THE OWNERS --
HAVE REQUIREMENTS WE PLACE ON
THEM AREN'T -- AREN'T MORE THAN
WE PLACE ON CARS THAT ARE BEING
UTILIZED IN SIMILAR FASHION
THROWN OUT BASED -- S. SYSTEM
THAT'S ALL I'M YOU KNOW I I
DON'T WANT TO DISFAVOR -- ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION OF ANY SORT -- I
GUESS THIS IS MOTORIZED BUT
STILL -- OVER AT THE USE OF CARS
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S BETTER FOR
ENVIRONMENT WE NEED TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND THE BILL WILL PROVIDE
EQUALITY AMONGST ALL IT WILL NOT
IN ANY WAY PUT AN ONEROUS BURDEN.
IT WILL JUST MERELY RELEASED
SECULAR OVER TO THEM PART WAS AN
ACTUAL QUESTION THERE MISS CORA.
THANK YOU MR CHAD THANK YOU A
SOME MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IS A DEFINITELY A TOUGH
ISSUE THAT TO TAKE ON AND AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT -- WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION ON SOME OF THE
DETAILS BECAUSE AT THAT HIM
BEING IN SAN JOSE CERTAINLY.
UP I ACTUALLY USE THOSE TWO
COMPANIES I USE THEM FREQUENTLY --
THERE DEFINITELY PROVIDE A
SERVICE BY THE VALUE AT THE SAME
TIME -- THERE YOU KNOW THAT THE
LOCAL AND AND SOUNDS A IN CITY
HALL THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT -- HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
SAFETY ISSUES SOUNDS A STATE
CAMPUS IS BANNED THEM AS ACTION
IDEAL CAMPUS TO HAVE THEM BUT
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY
ACCIDENTS?
IT'S A NEW THING.
THAT LIKE WOULD LIKE ANYTHING
NEW WE WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PUT NOT JUST REGULAR
REGULATORY.
MEASURES BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE ARE USING IT ARE PROTECTED
IN A MANNER THAT STILL ALLOWS
INDUSTRY -- BUT TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE AND THAT'S ALWAYS THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE BUT I
THINK THAT -- I'M GLAD THAT THIS
BILL IS GOING FORWARD I'M
CONFIDENT OF THE FLORIDA THIS
COMMITTEE BUT AS IT DOES -- I I
LOOK FORWARD TO IT -- WILL.
THE THE ADDING THAT THE FOR THE
CLARITY AND DETAILS BUT I THINK
IT'S TOUGH ENOUGH SORRY SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUST.
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OF OUR
COLLEAGUES -- IN AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE GRAPPLE WITH IN
SAN FRANCISCO INTENSELY IT'S
GOOD TO SEE FOR SOME OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS HERE -- I AM
CERTAINLY LIKE MR CAR SOMEONE
WHO'S USED THESE DEVICES I
HAPPEN TO THINK ELECTRIC BIKES
AND SCOOTERS AND OTHER SHARE
MOBILITY DEVICES ARE.
CONVENIENT ARE ECO FRIENDLY ARE
GOOD ALTERNATIVE MODES FOR
TRANSIT TO DEAL WITH CONGESTION
BUT THAT BEING SAID WE NEED SOME
RULES OF THE ROAD WE NEED TO
HAVE.
SOME MINIMAL STANDARDS -- WE PUT
THEM IN PLACE IN SAN FRANCISCO I
THINK THIS BILL DOES PROVIDE
THAT AS WELL -- AND WITH THAT
HAPPY TO SECOND THE MOTION I
THINK WAS CALLED CONSULTS MADE.
RIGHT WILL TAKE THAT AS A MOTION
BY MEN THIS IS ALLISON A SECOND
BY MISTER [inaudible]
TOO ALL RIGHT.
SWEAR TO SEE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
APPRECIATE THAT I REMEMBER BACK
TO THE TNC DEBATE IN THIS.
HOUSE WHERE WE WERE ALL WRAPPED
AROUND THE AXLE IF YOU WILL
ABOUT.
THE GIG ECONOMY AND MOVING
FORWARD IN TECHNOLOGY AND ALL
THAT AND ULTIMATELY IT WAS
INSURANCE QUESTION BECAUSE WE
WERE LEAVING TO MANY PEOPLE
WITHOUT RECOURSE.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE DOING HERE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
AS WE DEVELOP NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND CAPACITIES AND CAPABILITIES
OF PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO USE
THESE INTERESTING NEW AND
INNOVATIVE PRODUCTS AND THAT'S
ALL WELL AND GOOD.
BUT IN THE END WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
SOMEONE IS INJURED AND THAT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
AND I THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE FOR JURISDICTIONS.
TO APPROPRIATELY REGULATE IN
FACT THEY SHOULD BE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SOME.
CONSEQUENCES ON STREETS AND
SIDEWALKS AND PARKING AND AND
OTHER PLACES WHERE I KNOW WE'RE
SEEING THIS IN SANTA CRUZ.
WHICH FAVORS BICYCLE MOBILITY
BUT YET.
HAS SOME REAL PROBLEMS WITH A
LOT OF THE ELECTRIC BIKES THAT
ARE THERE AND THE WAY THAT THEY
END UP BLOCKING SIDEWALKS THEIR
CHAINS TO EVERY SINGLE POST AND
I WOULD HOPE THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES JURISDICTIONS
UNIVERSITIES.
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY WITH SOME
BACKING FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
BE ABLE TO PUT REASONABLE RULES
IN PLACE.
REALLY THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE AFRAID.
SO WITH THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU SIR I
REALLY APPRECIATE AGAIN THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS BILL --
I THINK IT IT IS A MY MUCH
STRONGER BILL THAN WHEN WE
STARTED I I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS
TWO POINTS -- YOU KNOW A FIRST
TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES -- FOR BEFORE --
THE THE INVITATION -- TO TO BE
ADDED AS A CO SPONSOR I I THINK
THAT REALLY SHOWS THAT WE'RE
TRYING -- TO NOT IMPOSE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL BUT THAT WE WANT
TO LEAVE IT TO WHETHER IT'S THE%
SENATE'S A CAMPUS OR OR LOCAL
CITIES TO COME UP WITH THEIR OWN
RULES -- BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE THE MINIMUM BASELINE --
SAFE TO REQUIREMENTS THAT -- ARE
ARE ARE PROVIDED IN THE IN THIS
BILL SECOND.
NO AS AN ENVIRO MYSELF I MEAN I
WANT TO SEE THIS -- INDUSTRY --
SUCCEED AND SO WELL WE WANT TO
SEE IT SUCCEED TO THAT -- AS MS
GONZALEZ -- INDICATED THAT WE WE
ADDRESS THE LAST MILE -- ISSUE --
IT'S AN IMPORTANT -- MODE OF OF
IT CHEAP FUN AND AND ECO
FRIENDLY TRANSPORTATION AND SO
NOW I WANT TO MAKE IT SUCCEED --
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS DONE IN A IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS -- CALIFORNIANS AND SO
I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE I
GALLAGHER.
NO GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHU.
CHU I CONSOLIDATES.
GONZALEZ FIVE HOLDEN.
GOLDEN EYE CHOLERA.
CALLER I. KYLIE.
EARLY NO MAIN SHINE.
OVER NINETY FOUR NO TINO PEACH
NORRIS RADIUS.
IT'S TWO MORE VOTES THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU I THINK THIS -- WHAT?
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN NINETY WELCOME.
OUR NAME MISTER CHAIR AND MANY
MEMBERS FIRST I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REFERENCED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
A LOT OF MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU -- SIX TO PROVIDE A
STATEWIDE FRAMES.
WORK FOR DRONE REGULATION AND
UNMANNED AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS OR
DRONES ARE RAPIDLY GROWING
MARKET CURRENTLY THERE'S A LACK
OF STATE GUIDANCE AS TO WHEN
WHERE AND HOW AND MANNED
AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS CAN BE OPERATED.
SAFELY AND LEGALLY THE LACK OF
STATE STANDARDS MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR DRUG MANUFACTURERS
TO DIRECT USERS ON HOW TO COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW.
SO WE'VE WORKED WITH -- INDUSTRY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX PROVIDES STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK
AS I MENTIONED FOR DRONE
REGULATION GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING STILL MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE A
CHARLES HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
SUPPORT WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE -- AND AB ELEVEN NINETY AS
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED A
REFLECTIVE SENSE OF STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVES A
PRIVATE INDUSTRY IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED TO AUTHORIZE A LOCAL --
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT REASONABLE
TIME PLACE MANNER REGULATIONS ON
THE USE OF DRONES ARE REQUIRE
OPERATORS TO REGISTER THEIR
DRONES WITH THE FAA.
AND ADOPT LAWS AND ORDINANCES
THAT EMPOWER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
TO HELP THE LAW KEEP CURRENT --
WITH THIS NEW AND EVOLVING
TECHNOLOGY SO WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA HAVE A
DRONE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK THAT --
WHILE RESPECTING THE
JURISDICTION OF THE FAA --
PROVIDES FOR THE APPROPRIATE
USES OF THIS TECHNOLOGY WHILE
ALSO ADDRESSING IMPORTANT PUBLIC
SAFETY PRIVACY -- AND OTHER
ISSUES THAT WILL INEVITABLY
ARISES DRONES ARE INCREASINGLY
USE FOR RECREATIONAL BUSINESS
AND GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES AND SO.
WITH THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AND A RELATED
STAKEHOLDERS -- TO HELP ENHANCE
THE PROPOSED FRAMEWORK UNDER
THIS BILL AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU EXODUS PLEASE NOT CLUB
SCENE ON BEHALF OF DJ I WE JUST
WANT TO REALLY THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR UNDERTAKING THIS THIS BIG --
GROUP EFFORT TO FIND A COMMON
SENSE -- MIDDLE OF THE ROAD
SOLUTION HERE WELL JUST WANTED
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE --
CONSULTANT IN THE REST THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE REALLY
THOUGHTFUL AND ALSO SINCE DOES
SUGGEST AMENDMENTS THERE -- LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKE HOLDERS AS WE CONTINUE
THROUGH THE YEAR.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SIGNUP BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISERABLE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SPORT THE BILLING PRIVACY OF
CERTAINLY BE SPORTING AGAIN
TODAY I JUST ONE COMMENT THAT --
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO ASK AND
PRIVACY BECAUSE I WAS PRESENTING
ANOTHER BILL IT'S WHERE --
THERE'S A SECTION HERE THAT
PROHIBITS WEAPON ICING A DRONE
OR OP IN THE OPERATING A
WEAPONIZED DRONES WHICH I THINK
IS SOMETHING WE CAN ALL AGREE IS
A GOOD IDEA.
HOWEVER THERE IS A DEFINITION OF
WHAT EXACTLY THAT MEANS TO
WEAPONIZE A DRONE.
AND I'M NOT AWARE OF ANYWHERE
ELSE IN ST CODE WHERE THAT IS TO
FIND AND SO I WANT TO URGE YOU
TO THINK ABOUT MAYBE.
WRITING THAT DOWN AND DEFINING
EXACTLY WHAT WEAPONIZED DRONES
ARE YEAH I MEAN IT MIGHT SEEM
OBVIOUS THAT WE DON'T WANT A
DRONE DROPPING A BOMB SURE.
MADE ME THINK ABOUT LIKE A WATER
BALLOON IS THAT WEAPONIZED YOU
COULD ARGUE THAT ONE EITHER WAY.
SO -- I JUST THINK THAT THIS.
DESERVE SOME MORE SPECIFICITY.
AT THAT COMMENT.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS WAS
TOGETHER.
DONE HOW DO HOW DO WE GET AT YOU
KNOW I THINK THE LEGITIMATE
PRIVACY ISSUES POSED BY THIS YOU
KNOW I MEAN.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WE HAVE A
RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
AND I THINK MOST ESPECIALLY
THAT'S OUTLINED IN THE
CONSTITUTION THAT SURROUNDING
THE HOME OUR HOME IS SUPPOSED TO
BE KIND OF A HE A CIRCUS IT
SHOULD BE A SACROSANCT PLACE.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT DRONES.
IS YOU KNOW BEING ABLE TO YOU
KNOW.
VIDEO INTO SOMEONE'S BACKYARD
YOU KNOW WHERE WHERE THEIR KIDS
ARE PLAYING WHERE YOU'RE HAVING.
A FAMILY BARBECUE.
MAYBE EVEN TO SEE INSIDE
PEOPLE'S WINDOWS -- YOU KNOW SO
CONSIDERING THAT WE ARE REALLY
INTERESTED IN PROTECTING THAT.
THAT PRIVACY INTERESTS -- AND
AND YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW THE MAYBE MAKING THE
THE REFERENCE POINT TO LIKE YOU
KNOW WE DON'T ALLOW -- YOU KNOW
SEARCHES AND SEIZURES INTO THE
HOME BUT IN EFFECT YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY BY THE GOVERNMENT BUT
NOW BY THE MORE PRIVATE ENTITIES
YOU HAVE IN EFFECT MAY BE THE
SAME THING.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW HOW DOES THIS.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO HELP US GET
OUT THAT?
THAT ISSUE OR NOT.
SO WHAT -- THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT YOU HAVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
WORKING TOGETHER AND TRYING TO
FIND.
A BASIC FRAMEWORK FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN A BIT OF THE WILD WEST AND
AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF LOT OF
DISAGREEMENTS -- THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISAGREEMENTS ON WHAT'S
IN THE INITIAL BILL SHOULD LOOK
LIKE THE INITIAL THE INITIAL
REGULATORY SYSTEM SO THAT IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE THINGS TO
LOOK AT GOING FORWARD.
BUT WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
ESTABLISH BASICALLY WHAT WHERE
THERE IS FEDERAL PREEMPTION AND
WHAT THE ROLE IS OF THE STATE
AND WHAT THE POLICE POWERS ARE
OF THE OF LOCAL CITIES AND
CITIES AND COUNTIES SELF.
ONGOING CONVERSATION.
THE FEDERALS AT THE ANY OF THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS AT ALL
PROHIBIT THAT KIND OF PRACTICE --
USE OF USE OF DRONES LIKE FOR
INSTANCE.
TO YELL.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
NOT AT THIS TIME ANYWAY YEAH
OKAY THIS IS -- THE THINGS THAT
WERE WORK IF WE WERE GOING TO BE
WORKING ON IS WHAT IS THAT WHAT
ARE THE POLICE POWERS OF THE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO ENFORCE THOSE
PRIVACY REGULATIONS.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SIGNAL MISTER WHEN YOU
MAKE CLOTHES.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE I GALLAGHER.
CHOW. TWO HI TO ALL RIGHT GOOD
SOLID.
AS ALWAYS I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CHOLERA.
COLOR COLOR I KYLIE.
KYLIE I'D MAIN SHINE.
OVER NINETY FIVE OVER MULTI I
PETER NORRIS.
RADIUS.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS CAREER.
TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AV.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH IS
OUR LAST BILL IF WE COULD GET.
MEMBERS BACK TO THE DIET SO WE
CAN FINISH UP THIS BILL AND THE
REST OF OUR AGENDA [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
WOULD WHICH WOULD ENSURE THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS HAVE
THE DESERVE OPTION OF A STRAIGHT
FORWARD AN EXPEDITIOUS LEGAL
PATHWAY. TO JUSTICE IN THE CASE
OF THEIR EMPLOYERS WRONG DOING.
EMPLOYERS PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
IN SUPPORTING A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVOR WHO IS IN THE
PROCESS OF BREAKING FREE FROM AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP.
AND RECOVERING FROM TRAUMA A B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS NEEDED
BECAUSE THE METHOD VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS TO SERVE A CLEAR AND
DIRECT LEGAL LEGAL AVENUE TO
REDRESS DISCRIMINATION.
OR RETALIATION BY THEIR EMPLOYER
BASED ON THEIR STATUS AS A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVOR UNDER
THE CURRENT LAW SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND STALKING.
MUST BE PROVIDED JOB PROTECTION
TIME OFF TO SEEK MEDICAL LEGAL.
AND SOCIAL SERVICES AS WELL AS A
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS IN THE
WORKPLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
WHEN THESE RIGHTS ARE VIOLATED
SURVIVORS ARE OFTEN LEFT WITH
LITTLE TO NO RECOURSE TODAY
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TO EXPERIENCE MISCONDUCT AT THE
HANDS OF THEIR EMPLOYER ARE ABLE
TO FILE?
A COMPLAINT HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND A COMPLAINT WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
OR PURSUE A CLAIM UNDER THE
PRIVATE BUT UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS PAGA THESE EXISTING
OPTIONS OFFER IT -- INEFFECTIVE
REMEDIES THAT CAN TAKE MONTHS OR
EVEN YEARS. TO PROCESS.
AND I'LL TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
HAVE MY WITNESSES INTRODUCED.
AND OFFER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR SERVICE PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KRISTEN
I'M STUCK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FOR THE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION WORKING WITH LOCAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PROGRAMS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE REALLY PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE SPELL -- RIGHT
NOW THE EXISTING EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS FOR SURVIVORS
PROVIDE LIMITED PATHWAYS -- FOR
RELIEF THAT FAR WHEN SURVIVORS
RIGHTS IN THE WORKPLACE ARE
VIOLATED -- A TWENTY TEN SURVEY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOUND THAT
38% OF SURVIVORS DO YOU REPORT
EITHER HAVING BEEN FIRED OR
FEARING TERMINATION BECAUSE OF
THEIR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION. 34% OF SURVIVOR
SURVEYED HAD TO QUIT A JOB
BECAUSE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
IMPACTS CAN BE DEVASTATING TO
SAY NO THIS COMMITTEE IS WELL
AWARE.
OF THE LEADING CAUSE OF
HOMELESSNESS FOR WOMEN AND
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN AND THE
ECONOMIC REASONS ARE A KEY
FACTOR BY SURVIVORS RETURNED.
AS IT STANDS IT'S VERY CONFUSING
AND DIFFICULT FOR SURVIVORS TO
NAVIGATE THE CURRENT ENFORCEMENT --
MECHANISMS AND ENFORCE THEIR
RIGHTS A B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SURVIVORS TO HAVE A CLEAR PATH
TOWARDS REMEDY IS THAT THEY NEED
AND WITHOUT WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS WOULD.
DO WELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CONFERENCE CALIFORNIA BAR
ASSOCIATIONS.
THIS IS -- BILL TO CLARIFY%
EXISTING LONG KNOW. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME
THIS CLARITY AND SOME OF THE
OPINIONS.
THAT HAVE COME DOWN AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION EXISTS.
UNLIKELY IT DOES LIKE OTHER
PROVISIONS IN LABOR CODE. TO
HAVE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
WHICH PROVIDES.
THE VICTIMS OF IS STRAIGHT
FORWARD AND EFFECTIVE WAY OF
SEEING THEIR RIGHTS -- ACTED.
THIS ONE THIS.
FIGHTS THAT RIGHT IN A IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATIONS.
FOR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND FOR OTHERS LISTED IN THE
CURRENT STATUTE -- ONE THING I
WOULD NOTE THAT -- THE ONE OF
THE ARGUMENTS AGAINST THE BILL
IS THAT.
IT PROVIDES FOR POSSIBLY DOUBLE
DIPPING.
BY SOMEBODY FILING DUAL ACTIONS.
BUT I THINK THAT THE ANALYSIS --
PRETTY MUCH TO SPELLS THAT.
A POSSIBILITY BUT I KNOW IT
POINTING OUT THAT IF A PERSON
WERE TO GO TO THE TAKE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY AND OBTAIN.
OF GOVERNMENT AGAIN TO THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE THEN THERE WOULD BE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING FOR THEM TO
GET UNDER A A COURT CASE.
AND THEREFORE THERE'S NO POINT
IN GOING THAT DIRECTION.
HEY YOU WILL AS A VICTIM YOU GET
TO PICK YOUR REMEDIES.
OR PICK YOUR WAY OF A TRYING TO
OBTAIN YOUR REMEDIES.
AND THE V. -- FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT GIVES THEM A THE BEST WAY
OF TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED.
TOOK.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MICHAEL YOSHIHARA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
BUT SEEING THAT IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY.
MY NAME IS LAURA CURTIS ANDI'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH A B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT OF COURSE WE ARE
SYMPATHETIC TO THE ISSUE AT HAND.
HOWEVER OUR CONCERNS ARE THAT IT
ALLOWS FOR A NEW PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION AS WELL AS ONE SIDED
ATTORNEY'S FEES CURRENTLY UNDER
THE LAW THE VICTIMS ARE PROVIDED
REMEDY.
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT OR THROUGH
A PRIVATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT
CLAIM.
SO THERE ARE AVAILABLE AVENUES
FOR THE EMPLOYEE TO SEEK RELIEF
IN THOSE SITUATIONS WE'VE ALWAYS
HEARD THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
IS A CHAMPION FOR EMPLOYEES
WALKS IN THROUGH THE PROCESS THE
SYSTEM THROUGH THE INVESTIGATION
AND ALL THOSE ISSUES SO WE DON'T
SEE WHY THAT.
ISN'T IN A CORRECT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE EMPLOYEE TO SEEK RELIEF
IN THIS A SITUATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT ALLOWS AN
EMPLOYEE.
TO ADD TO FILE A CIVIL ACTION
FOR ANY LABOR CODE VIOLATION SO
AGAIN THERE IS A DIRECT -- CIVIL
ACTION THAT IS AVAILABLE TO THE
EMPLOYEE CURRENTLY.
WITH REGARD TO THE ATTORNEY'S
FEES PROVISION WE THINK THAT
OBVIOUSLY THAT AS ATTORNEYS FEES
PROVISION ISN'T NECESSARY IN
THIS SITUATION.
HOWEVER IF IT IS GOING TO BE
ADDED AND SHOULD NOT BE ONE
SIDED BOTH PARTIES SHOULD HAVE
AN EQUAL PLAYING FIELD WHEN IT
COMES.
TO LITIGATION IN ORDER TO REDUCE
FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION ALSO WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THESE BILLS
HOLISTICALLY THERE ARE CURRENTLY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILLS AMENDING
LABOR CODE.
TWO THIRTY AND OUR CONCERN IS IS
THAT IF YOU HAD A PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION TO THIS BILL AS WELL
ADDITIONALLY IMPACT THE OTHER
TWO BILLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY --
IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR LABOR CO TWO
THIRTY VIOLATIONS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
X. WITNESS MISTER CHAIR KRISTA
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION SORRY FOR
MY BACK TO THE OTHER MEMBERS --
JUST IF I COULD ADD A FEW POINTS --
TO MISS CURTIS'S COMMENTS --
THERE IS NO IN NO WAY WOULD WE
CONDONE -- ANY OF THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THAT IS TRYING TO BE
ADDRESSED HERE AND CERTAINLY THE
NOTION OF RETALIATION -- SHOULD
BECOME BATTED AT EVERY AVENUE
OUR BELIEF IS IS THAT THERE ARE
APPROPRIATE INSTANCES AND
REMEDIES AVAILABLE PARTICULARLY
THROUGH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
PROCESS.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF IS SPENT ON
THIS ISSUE I THINK THERE'S A
FUNDAMENTAL OR PHILOSOPHICAL.
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION WHETHER
THE LAW IS CLEAR UNCLEAR.
AND AS USUAL YOUR COMMITTEE
COUNSELS ANALYSIS IS THOROUGH IN
THAT DISCUSSION WE DON'T THINK
THAT ADDITIONAL LITIGATION IS
THE PREFERRED APPROACH WE THINK
THE ADMINISTRATIVE ROUTE.
THROUGH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
IS THE APPROPRIATE ROUTE WE'VE
BEEN HERE AND BEFORE THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES NUMEROUS TIMES
ENCOURAGING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND POWERS BE GRANTED TO OUR
LABOR COMMISSIONER TO COMBAT
THIS.
AND WE THINK IT IS A VERY
SERIOUS MATTER LABOR CODE.
SECTION TWO THIRTY FOR EXAMPLE
IS -- DEFINED IN PAGA AS A
SERIOUS VIOLATION OF WHAT THAT
MEANS OF COURSE IS THAT.
AN EMPLOYER IS NOT ALLOWED THE
ABILITY TO CURE.
A YOU CAN GO RIGHT TO THAT
LITIGATION -- OUR OTHER CONCERN
WITH THIS IS THAT IT UNDERMINES
PAGA.
NIGHTS DENYING YOU KNOW POCKET
WAS ENACTED INTO LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR AS AN AVENUE
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO BRING
ON BEHALF LABOR CODE VIOLATIONS
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALLOWING THIS ADDITIONAL P.
R. A. UNDERMINES THAT EFFORT AND
THEN LASTLY IS MISS CURTIS
INDICATED AND I THINK AS MR
CALLERS HERE HEARD HIS BILL AND
OTHER BILLS IN THE LABOR
COMMITTEE PRIOR TO YOUR
COMMITTEE MISTER CHAIR. ONE
SIDED ATTORNEY'S FEES WE DON'T
THINK IS THE RIGHT ROUTE TO TAKE
EITHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
A GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS ARTICULATED BY THE PRIOR
OPPOSITION WITNESSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ERIN RUBBER GONE WE HAVE THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION.
VAPOR JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
FOR THE REASONS STATED.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEEING NONE THIS CRAZY MAN
CLOSER THIS FEATURE NORRIS I'M.
WHAT IS THE RATIONALE I'M FOR
GOING DIRECTLY TO THE COURTS
RATHER THAN PURSUING THE
CURRENTS?
ODD MINISTER PROCESSING THROUGH.
THE FIVE AT LABOR COMMISSIONER.
WELL I THINK -- THE OPPOSITION
ACTUALLY STATED THAT IN TERMS OF
THEIR OVERWHELMED AND OVERWORKED
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH RESOURCES SO
WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO DO IS
ALLOW.
A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THAT HAS EXPERIENCED MISCONDUCT
IN THE WORKPLACE TO HAVE
DIFFERENT AVENUES TO ACTUALLY
PURSUE HER CASE HIS OR HER CASE.
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE [inaudible]
SCREAMING CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
IS THE BILL THAT WOULD PROMOTE
THE ECONOMIC STABILITY OF
SURVIVORS BY EMPOWERING THEM TO
OBTAIN LEGAL REPRESENTATION OF
RIDING OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO SEEK
JUSTICE THROUGH THE ASSISTANCE
IN NEGOTIATING THE RETURN TO
WORK.
AND THE RECOVERY OF LOST WAGES
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOUGHT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DO
PASSCODE ROLE PLEASE STONE BY
STONE I GALLAGHER.
ALGOR NO SHOW SHOW I CHOOSE. TO
ARKANSAS'.
CONSOLES I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I CHOLERA.
CALLER I. KYLIE.
KYLIE NO MAIN CHINE.
IN CHINA I OVER MULTI.
OVERALL TINO PETRI NORRIS.
BEACH NORTH I RADIUS.
RESIGN.
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S GO THROUGH OUR
AGENDA TO MAKE SURE WE ADD
EVERYONE ON THE CONSENT IS.
AGENDAS ON CALL I'M GONNA LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE EX MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER.
HI FELDER I'D CHOW CHOW ARKANSAS.
CONSOLES I KYLIE.
KYLIE I MAIN SHINE MAIN CHINA I
PETRI NORRIS.
BETWEEN NORTH I RADIUS RACE I
THERE ARE TWO BILLS ON BECAUSE
THAT THEY ARE OUT THAT IS A B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE PATTERSON
AND A B.. EIGHTEEN TWENTY WHICH
WAS THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BELL.
I DON'T NUMBER ONE IS A B. SIX
OH TWO I NEED A MOTION ON MISTER
BERMAN SPELL.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED COLOR -- PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER FIGHT CHOW CHOW I CHEW.
CHOO ARKANSAS WAS.
CONSULTS I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
COBRA HI KYLIE.
KYLIE I MAIN SHINE MAIN SHINE I
OVER MULTI OVER KNOWS HE I
PEACHY NORRIS.
PETER NORRIS I RACE.
RACE I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS ALREADY OUT BUT
THIS IS A V. SIX SEVENTY
FRIEDMAN CALL THE UP TO MEMBERS
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KYLIE.
KYLIE HI [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SURE.
OVERALL P..
EIGHTY SIXTEEN SEVENTY FIVE OVER
NOTING NO TIE ON A. B..
SIX SEVENTY SIX SEVENTY OKAY.
OKAY I'M NUMBER THREE AB ELEVEN
SIX OH SIX SMITH IS ON CALL
MIDDLE IF THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHOW I CHEW.
CHEW I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I KYLIE.
MAIN SHINE MAIN SHINE I RAISE
THIS.
RAISE I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER.
FOUR A B. ELEVEN TEN FRIEDMAN IS
ALREADY OUT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO HOLDEN.
GOLDEN EYE KYLIE.
KYLIE NO MAIN SHINE MAIN CHINA.
RIGHT ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT GABRIEL IS ON CALL
ON THE LIST TO CALL.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHOW.
CHOW I CHOOSE.
CHEW I CONSOLIDATES.
GONZALEZ HI KYLIE.
KYLIE I'D MAIN SHINE MAIN SHINE
I RADIUS.
RACE I THAT BILL IS OUT I DON'T
NUMBER SIX IS OUT BUT WE'LL CALL
THE UP TO MEMBERS THAT'S A B.
ELEVEN NINETY URBAN.
CHOW.
CHOW I MAIN SHINE MAIN CHINA I
PETRI NORRIS.
PETRI NORRIS I RAISE.
RAISE HIGH.
Q. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A B. TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX MARE TUCCI IS ON A
CALL WITH A LIFT THE CALL.
CHOW.
CHOW I MEAN SHINE MAIN CHINA I
PETER NORRIS.
PETER NORRIS I RADIUS.
RADIUS I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT ABC THIRTEEN EIGHTY
OVER NOLTE IS ON CALL AND LIFT
THE CALL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHOW.
CHOW I CONDOLENCES.
I HAVE OVER.
EIGHT GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT KYLIE.
KYLIE I MAIN SHINE MAIN SHINE I
PEACHY NORRIS.
PETER NORRIS I RADIUS.
RACE I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER NINE A B. THIRTEEN NINETY
FOUR DAILY IS ON CALL I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER KNOWN CHOW CHOW I CHEW.
CHEW I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HI KYLIE.
MAIN SHINE.
MAIN SHINE I RAISE.
RAISE I RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER TEN IS A B..
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE BLOOM IT'S
OUT BUT YOU CAN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KYLIE -- I REMEMBER A
LEVIN A B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN GLORIA IS ON CALL A MIDDLE
OF THE CALL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
NO.
CALGARY NO CHEW. TWO I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KYLIE.
KYLIE NO MAIN SHINE MENTION I
THANK YOU.
I REMEMBER TWELVE I BELIEVE WE
HAVE EVERYONE.
WE DO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN IS ON
CALL THIS IS A B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE BONTA I'M GONNA LIFT
THE CALL.
CHOW.
CHOW AIKENS WAS CONSOLIDATES I
KYLIE.
KYLIE NO MAIN SHINE [inaudible]
RACE [inaudible]
YES I THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE SANTIAGO IS
ALREADY OUT BUT CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW AIKENS AULUS CONSOLES I'D
KYLIE.
KYLIE NO RADIUS.
RACE I ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A B.
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN GRAYSON IS
ON CALL I'M GONNA LIVE THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHOW I INTELLISENSE GONZALEZ HI
KYLIE.
KYLIE NO MAIN SHINE [inaudible]
BETWEEN NORRIS [inaudible]
RADIUS [inaudible]
RACE I THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY FIVE COME UNDER THE IS ON
CALL I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
CHOW.
CHOW ARKANSAS WAS.
GONZALEZ HI KYLIE.
KYLIE NO MAIN CHINA.
MAN CHINA I RADIUS.
RESIDE.
THAT BILL IS OUT RIGHT THAT
COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND
WE ARE ADJOURNED